ALRIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME
TO OUR OUR FIRST HEARING IN THE
YEAR THE ASSEMBLY.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TO
JOIN HERE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
OF COURSE MR O'DONNELL SERVES ON
BOTH COMMITTEE SO.
IT'S OUR IT'S ARE A PLEASURE TO
HAVE THIS HEARING ON A SPECIAL
TOPIC TO US IN CALIFORNIA IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF COURSE.
THIS HEARING IS FOCUSED ON PRE
K. FOR ALL IN CALIFORNIA AND
WHAT WE COULD DO IN OUR GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO --
FOCUSING ON WHAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM OTHER STATES WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA IS THAT BEHIND THE
CURVE IN THIS IN THIS ISSUE AND
WE HAVE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR WHAT.
WE'RE DOING AND OTHER STATES AND
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT OUR
GOVERNOR IS TALKING ABOUT
FRIENDS CENTER SO IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO BE CAN GO FORWARD TO
LOOK AT WHERE WE HAVE BEEN IN
THE PAST BUT ALSO LOOK WHAT WHAT
OTHERS ARE DOING --
WILL BE JOINED IN A FEW MINUTES
AS WELL EIGHT SUPER ATTEND A
PUBLIC CONSTRUCT INSTRUCTION
TONY THURMOND.
LAST DECEMBER A SUPERINTENDENT
ELECT THEIR MAN I LED A
DELEGATION WITH EARLY ADS
CALIFORNIA AND SEVERAL PARTNERS
FROM CALIFORNIA TRAVELING.
TO A BOSTON NEW YORK AND NEW
JERSEY.
LEARNING ABOUT WHAT THEIR STATES
AND CITIES ARE DOING A FIRST
HAND -- TO
BRING ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXPAND HIGHER EARLY EDUCATION
EFFORTS FOR OUR OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS AND THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ZEROING IN ON TODAY --
WE ALL KNOW THE WISDOM OF EARLY
EDUCATION YOU ASKED --
NOBLE LOWER IT'S LIKE --
MISTER HECKMAN AND PRACTITIONERS
AND A FOCUS ON EARLY EDUCATION
REALLY IS A DIFFERENCE MAKER FOR
OUR KIDS AND OUR FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ADDRESSING.
OUR EDUCATION ACHIEVEMENT GAP --
DRESSING ISSUES LIKE CHILDHOOD
POVERTY AND INTER GENERATIONAL
POVERTY AND AS WELL AS LOOKING
AT THINGS LIKE OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND KEEPING KIDS.
OUT OF THAT PRISON UP --
TO SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE AND
SO WE KNOW THAT EARLY EDUCATION
WORKS A SOME OF OUR BIG TAKE
AWAY IS THAT WE GOT FROM OUR
EAST COAST TRIP WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT A LATER TODAY.
OUR POLITICAL LEADERSHIP WHICH
WERE FORGED OUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SOME LOGISTICS
FACILITIES INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INVESTMENTS IN THE WORK FORCE SO --
LOOKING FORWARD TO IT TO GETTING
TO IT TO WORK OUR COCHAIR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL TO SAY
A FEW WORDS.
THANK YOU --
MISTER MCCARTY AND I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HOLD THIS
HEARING AND AND LEARN FROM YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE FACT EVEN A CONSISTENT
CHAMPION --
ON THIS ISSUE --
AS WE ALL KNOW PROVIDING
CHILDREN WITH THE QUALITY
LEARNING PROGRAM PRIOR TO
KINDERGARTEN ENTRY IS OF
TREMENDOUS VALUE AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER.
AND I KNOW THIS I REMEMBER RIGHT
BY WAS AT A MIDDLE SCHOOL THAT
WE WENT TO THE KATE MODEL AND I
REMEMBER.
SITTING AROUND THE THE TEACHERS
LOUNGE FOR THE KINDERGARTEN
TEACHERS WHICH WERE NEW TO ME
BECAUSE I PREVIOUSLY HAD BEEN IN
A MIDDLE SCHOOL AND AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
IN PARTICULAR YOU WOULD HEAR
THEM SPEAK OF THEIR EXPERIENCE
WITH CHILDREN WHO HAD NOT HAD A
PRESCHOOL EXPERIENCE AND THE
DIFFERENCE.
IN IN IN.
IN THE IN THE IN THOSE TWO
GROUPS OF STUDENTS SAYS SO THAT
IS SOMETHING CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
ADDRESS TO ENSURE SUCCESS. FOR
ALL CHILDREN AND MY ONE CONCERN
ALL PERCENT HERE TODAY IS IS THE
FUNDING.
I'M HAPPY TO HEAR ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE BUT I THINK THE REAL
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO BE AROUND
THE FUNDING HOW DO WE FUND THIS
EFFORT.
IT CANNOT COME OUT OF THE
EXISTING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BUCKET OF DOLLARS THERE IS
NOT ENOUGH.
MONEY IN THAT BUCKET NOW TO
SERVE QUE --
SO WE NEED YOU AS A STATE IS A
KIND OF PERMANENT CONSISTENT AN
ONGOING SOURCE AN ONGOING SOURCE
OF FUNDING. FOR FOR THIS NEW.
THIS NEW A PRE K. VENTURE WHICH
WE ARE ABOUT TO EMBARK ON SO
AGAIN I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY ON THIS ISSUE AN
ALTERNATE BACK TO YOU MISTER
MCCARTY OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS AND WE
HAVE SOME GUEST HERE DURING
SURGERY NOT FROM THIS --
COMMITTEE --
NOR THE AT EDUCATION COMMITTEE
BUT LIKE TO ENTERTAIN ANYBODY
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ELOISE RIGHT IS
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
AS CHAIR OF THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMEDIANS [inaudible]
HELLO AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M ELOISE REYES AND I'M THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THE FORTY
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN SAN
BERNADINO.
AS CHAIR OF THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE AND AS A MEMBER OF THE
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION.
ON EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
THIS PARTICULAR HEARING IS OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE TO US --
GOVERNOR BROWN GOVERNOR NEWSOM
HAS BEEN A GREAT ADVOCATE FOR
THE VERY SUBJECT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND I WERE EVER SO
GRATEFUL TO HIM.
WE KNOW THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IS QUITE FRANKLY THE
GREAT EQUALIZER FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
HOWEVER WITHOUT ADEQUATE
FINANCING.
ON THESE PROGRAMS WILL SIMPLY
NOT REACH THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES
IN NEED.
ARE THIS IS WHY I'M A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB ONE TWENTY THREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
AND WHY I PERSONALLY INTRODUCED
AB ONE NINETY FOUR WHICH WOULD
ALLOCATE BILLION DOLLARS IN
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE SLOTS.
I'M GRATEFUL TO MY COLLEAGUES.
SPECIFICALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MCCARTY AND O'DONNELL FOR
ENSURING THAT THE BUDGET.
AND POLICY COMMITTEES.
SHARE DIALOGUE ON THIS TOPIC AS
WAS NOTED EARLIER IF WE DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY DOESN'T MATTER
HOW MUCH WE WANTED TO HELP AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
I DO WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT MANY
OF MY FEMALE COLLEAGUES AND I
ARE LEAVING FOR LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S.
OUR CAUCUS RETREAT AT THE MOMENT
BUT WE TO THINK THAT THE ISSUE
IS OF SERIOUS PRIORITY. FOR
WOMEN.
ARE AND AND FOR CHILDREN ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND I DON'T WANT TO
TO INTERPRET THE FACT THAT TOO
MANY OF THE WOMEN WILL BE GONE --
AS ANY INDICATION THAT THAT THIS
IS NOT OF INTEREST TO US THIS IS
OF GREAT INTEREST.
THAT IS WHY MANY OF US ARE HERE
BEFORE WE LEAVE TO OUR WOMEN'S
RETREAT.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU ALL AND I
SEE A GREAT FRIENDS FROM.
MIGHT FROM COLTON A SERRA WHO
WILL BE SPEAKING WHO IS ON THE
AGENDA --
I'M VERY PROUD OF HER AND ALL
THAT SHE HAS DONE ALSO --
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
ESTHER'S CHAIRS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER AT
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE MONTH.
THANK YOU AT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THIS A ONE ECHO
WHAT'S BEEN SAID AND THAT
HISTORICALLY AND THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AT HAS BEEN AT THE TABLE
WITH THIS CONVERSATION ALONG
WITH MANY OTHERS --
TO SUPPORT ACCESS AND QUALITY
CARE AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT WILL PERHAPS COME UP
IN THE DISCUSSION OVER TIME
WHETHER IT'S IN TODAY'S HEARING
OR ELSEWHERE THAT ADDRESSES --
BY MEMBERS WHO CARE A LOT ABOUT
THE ISSUE AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE THAT CREPT
UP ON US IT'S AN ISSUE.
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
DECADES SO I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT AND I REGRET THAT.
I YOU KNOW I I AND OTHER MEMBERS
WILL HAVE TO LEAVE TO CONTINUE
THIS DISCUSSION IN A IN A
DIFFERENT SPACE.
THANK YOU.
AND WE HOPE ON THE AGENDA TODAY
AT THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT EARLY EDUCATION.
YES OKAY WELL THANK YOU WILL --
MISTER TERRIBLY THERE ARE MORE
MALE LEGISLATORS HERE.
YEAH -- BUT
NO I II JUST WANT TO QUICKLY
JUMP IN BECAUSE AND AS A PARENT.
THIS IS A BIGGER ISSUE TO ME AS
A TEACHER IS A BIG ISSUE TO ME
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S A MALE
FEMALE SHIELDING IS A CALIFORNIA
ISSUE.
THAT WE NEED TO SOLVE ON OUR OWN
I DON'T THINK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S GONNA STEP IN AND
HELP US MUCH MORE THEY ALREADY
HAVE.
SO -- THIS
IS THIS IS OUR TIME GET AND I
CAN GOING --
TO AT A START NOW WE WE WILL
STOP IN A LITTLE BIT WHEN WE
HEAR FROM OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT HE WANTS TO COME
BY AND HIS WASN'T ABLE TO GET
THE VERY BEGINNING BUT HOPEFULLY --
BEFORE WE HEAR FROM OUR
DEPARTMENT OF ED WE COULD HAVE
INSIDE RIGHT NOW BUT IF NOT
WE'LL HAVE A A JUMP IN.
WITH WITH THE PROGRAM AND MISTER
O'DONNELL TALKED ABOUT
CALIFORNIA FUNDING --
EARLY YET SO IT'S PART OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT TODAY.
AND THAT WE HAVE THAT MAKES
DELIVERY SYSTEM FROM GENERAL
FUND AND PROP NINETY EIGHT OF
COURSE WE WANT TO INVITE UP OUR
LA -- WHO
APPARENTLY IS FROM CULT IN
CALIFORNIA?
DID NOT KNOW THAT. TO TO JOIN US
INTO GIVE US --
AN OVERVIEW OF EARLY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA --
HOW THEY'RE FUNDED WHO THEY SIR
THINGS ARE I WHERE THE GAS LEE
WHERE OPERA THIS TO CALIFORNIA
FOR HIGH QUALITY?
PROGRAMS THANK YOU --
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
SERRA CORTEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
I WAS ASKED TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW
OF STATE PROGRAMS THAT SERVE.
A PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WILL BE
SPEAKING FROM THE HAND OUT
THAT'S BEING DISTRIBUTED TO YOU --
SO FIRST I'LL BRIEFLY DISCUSS --
THE STATE'S CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS GENERALLY OF
THEN I'LL GO INTO MORE DETAIL ON
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY FOR THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLDS.
SO THE STATE ADMINISTERS SEVERAL
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS FOR PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN THE FIGURE ON PAGE ONE
SHOWS THE PROGRAMS AND KEY
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
FROM THIS FIGURE YOU CAN SEE
THAT THE TOP TWO PROGRAMS LISTED
ARE MORE GENERALLY FOR CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE.
THIRTEEN WELL THE BOTTOM TWO
PROGRAMS LISTED ARE FOR
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN CHILDREN
AGES THREE AND OR FOUR YEARS OLD.
THE STATE SPEND ROUGHLY FOUR
POINT SEVEN BILLION
ADMINISTERING THESE PROGRAMS.
ON PAGE TWO YOU CAN SEE THAT THE
STATE SERVES ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THOUSAND CHILDREN.
THE STATE --
FOR IT A SEVENTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN THESE PROGRAMS AND
THIS FIGURE SHOWS HOW SLAUGHTER
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS EACH PROGRAM.
SO A LITTLE MORE THAN HALF OF
THE SLOTS ARE FOR PROGRAMS THAT
SPECIFICALLY SIR PRESCHOOL AGE
SHOW OF PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
AND THAT'S THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN.
SO ON PAGE THREE OF YOUR HAND
OUT SHOWS THE TABLE COMPARING
STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS SERVING
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN MORE
SPECIFICALLY.
AND THIS TABLE ALSO INCLUDES
HEAD START A FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM.
THIS TABLES PRIMARILY FOR YOUR
RESOURCE BUT I DID WANT TO POINT
OUT A FEW THINGS.
SO STATE PRESCHOOL --
THE CONTRACTOR VOUCHER PROGRAMS
AND THE HEAD START PROGRAM ALL
HAVE INCOME ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS --
TO FAMILIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN
THESE PER LEARN WILL HAVE TO
EARN LESS THAN A SPECIFIED
INCOME AMOUNT FOR THEIR FAMILIES --
AND SO THE STATE PROGRAMS ALLOW
FAMILIES TO HAVE HIGHER INCOMES
COMPARED TO HEAD START AND YOU
COULD SEE THE INCOME.
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS HERE.
THE TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM IS A PROGRAM THAT
DOESN'T HAVE AN INCOME
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
THE OTHER THINGS I WILL POINT
OUT IS THAT THESE PROGRAMS CAN
VARY SIGNIFICANTLY PROGRAMMATIC
LEASE TO FOR EXAMPLE STATE
PRESCHOOL COULD OFFER A THREE
HOUR PROGRAM OR A TEN HOUR
PROGRAM --
DAILY PROGRAM FOR A CHILD --
A CHILD COULD ALSO RECEIVING THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
SOMETHING THAT ALIGNS A HUNDRED
SOMETHING THAT ALIGNS WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHICH WOULD BE
A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS OUT OF THE
YEAR OR SOMETHING THAT'S YEAR
ROUND THAT COULD WE OFFER
PROGRAMS FOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DAYS A YEAR.
AND TURNING TO PAGE FOUR ON THE
CHART ON PAGE FOUR SHOWS THAT
MORE THAN HALF OF LOW INCOME
FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE SERVED IN A
STATE FUNDED PROGRAM.
SO WE ESTIMATE THE STATE US THE
STATE HAS ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED
AND TEN THOUSAND LOW INCOME FOUR
YEAR OLDS. FOR PURPOSES OF THIS
CHART WERE DEFINING LOW INCOME
FOUR YEAR OLDS.
AS THE FOUR YEAR OLD IN A FAMILY
THAT HAS AN INCOME AT OR BELOW
THE 85% OF THE STATE MEDIAN
INCOME.
AND THIS IS THE INCOME
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
EFFECTIVE JULY.
TWENTY NINETEEN NOW I MENTION
THIS BECAUSE USING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY INCOME
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA INSTEAD OF
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN INCOME
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA.
AS AN ESTIMATED FIFTY THOUSAND
ELIGIBLE FOUR YEAR OLDS.
SO WE WERE TO DEVELOP THIS
FIGURE USING TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ELIGIBILITY THIS FIGURE
WOULD LOOK A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
SO FROM THIS TO FIGURE STATE
PRESCHOOL SERVES THE LARGER
SHARE OF THE POPULATION.
FOLLOWED BY TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND FOLLOWED BY
OTHER STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS.
THE OTHER STATE FOR UNDER
PROGRAMS CATEGORY INCLUDES
GENERAL CHILD CARE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT AND CAL WORKS CHILD CARE --
FROM THIS OTHER CATEGORY OF
ROUGHLY 40% --
IT'S ABOUT ROUGHLY 40% OF LOW
INCOME FOUR YEAR OLDS.
IN THIS CATEGORY INCLUDE
CHILDREN SERVED IN HEAD START
CHILDREN SERVED LOCALLY FUNDED
PROGRAMS.
CHILDREN WHOSE FAMILY PAY FOR
CHILD FOR PRESCHOOL PRIVATELY.
ON THIS CATEGORY ALSO INCLUDE
CHILDREN THAT ARE UNSERVED
HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE DATA TO
ESTIMATE WHICH SHARE OF THIS --
WHICH CHAIR OF THE OTHER
CATEGORY IS UNSERVED OR WHAT
SHARE PARTICIPATES IN SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT I JUST
MENTIONED.
SO WE GROUP THIS CATEGORY THIS
WAY BECAUSE OF OUR DATA
LIMITATIONS OF THE PRIME
EXAMPLES CHILDREN SERVED IN HEAD
START.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS MANY ARE
DULY ENROLLED IN HEAD START IN
STATE PRESCHOOL.
STILL WE WERE TO USE THE DATA
THAT HEAD START REPORTS --
THEY SERVE IN THIS FIGURE THAT
WOULD OVER --
THE CHILDREN SERVED.
UP AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
PREPARED REMARKS BUT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS OKAY.
THANK YOU.
I THINK I'LL START WITH WITH THE
KEY QUESTION KIND OF WHERE WE
HEAR TODAY IS WE THINK THERE ARE.
THOUSANDS IF NOT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME FOUR
YEAR OLDS WHO ARE NOT SERVICE.
AND SO I KNOW THAT --
THAT -- NEAR
AND OTHERS HAVE PUT OUT SOME
NUMBERS AS FAR AS HOW MANY.
LOW INCOME THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS ARE UNSERVED AND YOU KNOW.
THAT THE YOU KNOW THOSE NUMBERS
I'M SURE OF COURSE --
IF YOU COULD ELUDE TO THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IN YOUR
CHART YOU SAY WE DON'T NOW BUT
MAYBE YOU COULD TALK WHAT.
OTHERS ARE SAYING AS FAR AS HOW
MANY AYE AYE WE'VE HEARD BETWEEN
THIRTY AND FIFTY THOUSAND OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS OF LOW INCOME
FOUR YEAR OLDS AT ARTS IN EITHER
TKA.
STATE PRESCHOOL OR OR HEAD START
AND WONDER IF YOU COULD
ENLIGHTEN US A BIT MORE ON THAT.
YES A SOME SO SOME OF THE I'VE
SEEN -- HAVE
BEEN MORE GENERALLY.
FOR LOOKING AT ELIGIBLE FISH --
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES UNDER THE
AGE OF THIRTEEN SO I'VE SEEN
FIGURES --
RELATED TO THAT I'VE SEEN SOME
SPECIFIC --
BETWEEN AGES. THREE SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN --
THOSE OF PARTICULAR FIGURES
WOULD MAKE ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT --
DUAL ENROLLMENT THAT --
WE DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE MAKING
FUN BUT IT'S AN H. IT WOULD JUST
DEPEND --
BUT MY DOES THAT WORK ABOUT THE
WITH THE LEAD FINANCE OFFICE I
THINK RIGHT THEIR NUMBER NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT THE DIFFERENT
NUMBERS THAT ARE OUT THERE I
THINK.
AND ALL AND WE HAVE ALSO CHANGED
THE INCOME ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS SO --
THESE THESE DIFFERENT NUMBERS
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS ALL OF THEM
WILL BE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT --
AND AND SO I THINK THAT THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN --
SEND THE DIFFICULT INTERNET PAID
TO A SPECIFIC NUMBER BUT EITHER
WAY WITH ANY OF THE NUMBERS THAT
YOU HAVE YOUR WERE TALKING ABOUT --
AND THE OF MANY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ELIGIBLE FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS THAT ARE THAT THERE
WOULD NOT BE THAT ARE NOT BEING
SERVE RIGHT NOW SO REGARDLESS OF
WHICH NUMBER YOU TAKE I THINK
THEY'RE STILL.
A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF
CHILDREN ACROSS THE STATE IN
THAT ARE FOUR YEARS OLD THAT
THAT THAT ARE NOT BEING SERVED
AND THEN I'M NOT WHAT THEY ALSO --
THE FOUR YEAR OLD OF ALL OUR
AGES FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE PROBABLY
THE HIGHEST SERVE THE BALL SO WE
DID THE THING CHART FOR THREE
YEAR OLDS WE DON'T HAVE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WE
HAVEN'T MUCH.
SMALLER PROPORTION OF THEM BEING
SERVED IN THE PRESCHOOL YOU
WOULD HAVE A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THEM --
THAT ARE BEING SERVED SO.
THIS IS CHAU THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EXPENDING
SERVICES TO THE THE CHILDREN
THAT WE THINK ARE THE HIGHEST ME
WHICH OF CHILDREN WHO ARE OR LOW
INCOME.
AND THEN A FOLLOW UP QUESTION IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS SINCE THE
LAST FIVE YEARS WE I THINK HAD --
DIRECTING ITS LAST SIX YEARS FOR
MAJOR BUDGET INCREASES TO
INCREASE LOTS.
AND TO MAKE SUCCESS MAINLY
POSITIVE SUCCESS BUT IN THE LAST
COUPLE.
ITERATIONS OF BUDGET ACTIONS
WITH INCREASE LOTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM NOT THAT THE OTHER JUST
THIS SPECIFICALLY.
THERE ARE SOME LIMITATIONS ON
THE MONEY'S COMING BACK IN AND
WONDER IF THE LA --
HAS ANY THOUGHTS --
IDEAS ON WHY THAT IS OR WHAT WE
COULD BE DOING DIFFERENTLY WITH
WITH RELATION TO FACILITIES --
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WORKFORCE
NEEDS.
SO.
FOR THE FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE THE WHERE THERE WERE.
I THINK A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN
THREE THOUSAND SLOTS THAT WERE
APPROVED OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD THEY ALL WENT TO THEY
WERE AWFUL DAY SLOTS THAT WENT
TO EL THE ACE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE COUNTY UP.
EDUCATION ABOUT BECAUSE THE
FUNDING WAS LIMITED TO
PROPOSITION NINETY FUNDING.
I'M SO WE WE HAVE HEARD OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT THERE'S
BEEN SOME DIFFICULTY IN GETTING
THOSE SLOTS USED A LOT ABOUT
FUNDING HAVE COME BACK --
HAS AND IT'S BEEN IN USE THAT IN
SOME CASES THE DEPARTMENT HAS
TAKEN THAT INSTEAD OF ENDING
INSTEAD READ DURING OUR A NEW
REQUEST FOR APPLICATIONS AND
ISSUING THAT --
THOSE SLOTS AT THE SLOTS FOR
ELEAZAR AND SOMETIMES ALSO NON
NON ELLIE IS AS WELL --
SO WE HAVE HEARD THAT THERE IS
THIS CONCERNING THINK WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON AND IT'S IT'S
HARD TO KNOW THE EXACT REASON.
ONE POSSIBILITY IS THAT --
DISTRICTS FOR IF IN OUR
DISCUSSION WITH --
FOLKS IN THE FIELD DISTRICTS
SEEM TO BE MUCH LESS LIKELY TO
WANT TO OFFER FULL DAY PROGRAM
THEY PREFER OFFER THE PARTY
SCHOOL YOUR PROGRAM SO BY.
YOUR MARKING IT TO ELEAZAR MIGHT
HAVE LIMITED THAT THE SORT OF
TAKE UP OF THE SLOTS --
NOT LEDS ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
OFFER FULL DAY PROGRAMS IN MAY
AND SO --
PERHAPS DISTRIBUTING IT TO NOT
ALWAYS MIGHT INCREASE THE AMOUNT
THAT THAT WE WITH THE TAKEN UP.
DISTRICTS ARE DEALING WITH THEIR
OWN FACILITIES ARE BEFORE WHO'VE
BEEN --
THEY'VE BEEN USING SOME OF THEIR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CLASSROOMS TO
DO MORE TO QUE OUR EXPANDED TO
GET A WE MIGHT NOT HAVE SPACE
FOR SOME OF THESE ARE.
OF ADDITIONAL DAY PRESCHOOLS
LOTS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SMALL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR
THE LA A OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
ALREADY NEXT FOR OUR NEXT --
PANEL WE'RE GONNA HAVE DOCTOR
ELLEN FREAKY SHE'S WITH THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR EARLY.
EDUCATION RESEARCH --
NEAR FOR THOSE OF US THAT FOLLOW
YOUR WORK MORE CLOSELY.
AND SHE'S GOING TO BE DISCUSSING
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL PRE K. FOR
ALL BEST PRACTICES FROM OTHER
STATES AND RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE BEING INVITED HERE AS
AN OUTSIDER FROM ANOTHER STATE I
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT I IN THE
EARLY EIGHTIES.
I SPENT ALMOST TWO WEEKS OUT OF
EVERY MONTH IN LA WORKING WITH
LA COUNTY HEAD START AND SO I
KNOW HOW LONG YOU'VE.
MANY OF THOSE CLASSROOMS
ACTUALLY WERE ALSO STATE LONG
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE AND HOW MANY.
HOW HOW MUCH?
BROWN HAS ALREADY BEEN CELLS BUT
THERE'S CLEARLY STILL SOME WORK
TO DO AND I'M EXCITED THAT
YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE DOING IT.
SO I'M ALLEN FREE AND I'M SENIOR
CO DIRECTOR AT THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE FOR EARLY EDUCATION
RESEARCH --
WE'RE AT AN INSTITUTE OF RECORDS
UNIVERSITY AND CONDUCT RESEARCH
TO INFORM PUBLIC POLICY AROUND
MOST ON EARLY EDUCATION
GENERALLY BUT CPAS MOST
SPECIFICALLY AROUND PRESCHOOL
[inaudible]
AND ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE
ARMED BUT THAT MOST KNOWN FOR IS
ARE YOUR BOOK WHICH SHALL BE.
ALLUDING TO A LITTLE BIT TODAY
IN CHERRY SHOWING YOU SOME DATA
FROM THAT --
BUT FIRST I WANT TO IF YOU LOOK
AT THEM.
SLIDE TO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE RESEARCH MORE GENERALLY
AROUND WHAT IT TAKES TO ACTUALLY
HAVE A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THAT.
LEADS TO LASTING EFFECTS FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN.
AND I'M BORROWING AT A TERM FROM
ONE OF YOUR NATIVE DAUGHTERS
MARCY WHITE BURKE BUCK FROM
UNIVERSITY --
I'M FROM BERKELEY.
THE BUT I'VE BEEN NO SINGLE
INGREDIENT SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT WE CAN'T DO PRE K.
WITH JUST.
GETTING ONE THING RIGHT.
THIRD UP A CONSTELLATION OF
FACTORS THAT HAVE TO BE IN PLACE
TO REALLY MOVE THE BAR IN TERMS
OF CHILDREN'S OUT COMES.
THE AND WE HAVE SEARCH THAT
YOU'VE ALLUDED.
TO ABOUT --
THE HOW ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE AND
THE EFFECT OF PRESCHOOL BUT WE
ALSO HAVE.
THAT SAME BODY RESEARCH SHOWS US
HOW OFTEN WE GET IT WRONG.
AND SO I'M REALLY HOPEFUL THAT
WITH THIS MOVE YOU'RE GOING TO
GET IT RIGHT AND YOU'LL HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT THAT REALLY MAKES
THE DIFFERENCE AND SO.
IT'S LIKE --
TO DESCRIBES.
SOME OF THESE.
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENTS AND I'M
CALLING THEM THE CENTRAL ON
PURPOSE IN OTHER WORDS YOU CAN'T
JUST TAKE ONE FROM COLUMN A AND
NOT TAKE ONE FROM COLUMN BAY.
THE FIRST THREE I THINK COULD
GENERALLY BE TO DESCRIBE THIS.
CRITICAL --
STRUCTURAL POLICY ELEMENTS THERE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE REQUIRED
AND PUT IN PLACE --
AT THE POLICY LEVEL AND FUNDED.
AND AND THEIR THE HARDEST THINGS
IN MANY WAYS BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE ONES THAT CHEN THAT DO NEED
TO GENERATE MORE FUNDS --
THE FIRST IS THE THAT TEACHERS
NEED TO BE WELL EDUCATED AND AM.
FAIRLY COMPENSATED [inaudible]
AND AT THE SAME TIME THEY ALSO
NEED TO HAVE EXPERT LEADERS SAY
THE AGAIN IT'S IT'S NOT AN
EITHER OR IT'S A BOTH.
THEY AN ADEQUATE DOSAGE WE'RE
NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT IT TAKES
BUT WE KNOW THAT TWO YEARS GETS
BETTER RESULTS THAN.
ONE AND WE KNOW THAT FULL DAY
GETS BETTER RESULTS THAN HALF.
TWO YEARS OF A MEDIOCRE PROGRAM
PROBABLY DOESN'T DOUBLE THE A
FAX --
YOU'VE YOU'VE WE ARE PRETTY IT'S
PRETTY MUCH AGAIN ALL THE
INGREDIENTS HAVE TO BE IN PLACE --
FOR SMALL CLASS SIZES WITH
REASONABLE STAFF CHILD RATIOS
IT'S NOT THERE'S NOT A PERFECT
ANSWER TO THAT.
I'LL BE SHOWING YOU SOME
DIFFERENT EXAMPLES BUT SO WHAT
THE OTHER FEATURES ARE IN THE
PROGRAM THAT WE KNOW THAT HAVING
NO CLASS SIZE LIMIT IS NOT A
GOOD CHOICE.
AND THE THEN THE OTHER THROUGH
THE NEXT THREE ITEMS HERE ARE
INGREDIENTS TO REALLY LOOK AT
THE PROGRAMMATIC ELEMENTS WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE SYSTEM.
AND AND AND AND THAT SUPPORT
TEACHERS TEACH WELL.
AND THOSE HAVE TO DO WITH
SOMETHING THAT YOU HAVE MOST OF
IN PLACE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
GOOD LEARNING STANDARDS THAT ARE
COMPREHENSIVE --
THAT ARE.
THE ONE THING YOU'RE KIND OF
MISSING IS ENSURING THAT YOUR
CURRICULUM IS DIRECTLY RELATED.
TO THE STANDARDS AND DESIGNED.
TO ENSURE CHILDREN LEARN THEM.
AND AN ASSESSMENT SYSTEM THAT
HELPS INFORM TEACHING.
THAT'S RELATED TO THAT
CURRICULUM AND NOT JUST THE
STANDARDS BUT TO THE CURRICULUM
AS WELL AND THEN FINALLY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT.
THINK THAT AGAIN IS IS PART OF
THIS FULLY INTEGRATED.
APPROACH --
RELATED TO THAT OF COURSE IS A
COHERENT --
SYSTEM FOR REVIEW AND EFFORT FOR
PEOPLE TO KNOW HOW WELL THEY'RE
DOING AND YOU WANT TO HAVE THAT
AT AT AT AND THAT.
THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL SO THAT.
THAT OR AT SOME KIND OF LARGER
GOVERNING BODY LEVEL IT COULD BE
REGIONAL OR EVEN DISTRICT --
RELATED TO CONTINUOUS DATA
DRIVEN IMPROVEMENT SYSTEMS DATE
AT THE CHILD LEVEL AT THE
CLASSROOM LEVEL.
AT THE BUILDING LEVEL AT EVERY
LEVEL SO THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
AT HOW THEY'RE DOING AND
CORRECTING SHIP AS THEY'RE GOING
ALONG.
SO -- NOW
WILL TURN TO SOME DATA ABOUT
CALIFORNIA I KNOW THAT YOU WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT SOME NUMBERS
AND WE'RE GOING TO ARE GOING TO
CONTRADICT THE LA A LITTLE BIT
BUT IT'S JUST BECAUSE THE WAY WE
LOOK AT THINGS.
WHEN WE DO THE STATE PRE K.
YEARBOOK WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL
FIFTY STATES SEVEN OF WHICH HAVE
NO PRE K. PROGRAM AND THEY GET A
PAGE IN OUR YOUR BOOK THAT SAYS
NO PRESCHOOL PROGRAM?
IS THAT THE WALL OF SHAME OR THE
PAGE IF SHE TO CALL IN THE
WILDERNESS STATES BECAUSE MOST
OF OUR OUT IN THE NORTH WEST AND
HAVE.
THE WE LOOK AT THREE SORT OF
LEGS OF THE STOOL OF AT WILL --
AT THE STATE POLICY LEVEL SO ONE
IS FUNDING AND RESOURCES ONE IS
ACCESS AND HOW MANY CHILDREN --
ARNOLD.
AND THEN THE THIRD IS QUALITY --
AND WE THINK ABOUT THE QUALITY
AS THE MINIMAL POLICY STANDARDS
THAT NEED TO BE IN PLACE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT I SAY THAT
BECAUSE THESE DO NOT GUARANTEE.
YOU'LL GET LONGITUDINAL RESULTS
THIS IS THESE ARE JUST THE
MINIMAL POLICY STANDARDS SO HOW
DOES CALIFORNIA RANK WELL.
IF WE LOOK AT CAL ENROLLMENT IN
THE PERCENTAGE OF CHILDREN IN
THIS IS WHERE OUR NUMBERS DIFFER
A LITTLE BIT --
IF WE PUT THE CALIFORNIA.
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ANTI K.
TOGETHER FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS.
RANK THIRTEENTH OUT OF THE FIFTY
STATES BUT IF WE TAKE T. K. OUT --
THEN YOU'RE THE RANKING --
GOES DOWN --
TO THIRTY AND YOU'RE ONLY
SERVING ABOUT 17% OR LESS AND
17%.
ABOUT GRAHAM I APOLOGIZE THESE
ARE FIGURES FOR TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN SCHOOL YEAR
WE'RE DOESN'T JUST NOW WORKING
ON THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN YEAR
BUT AND THEN.
RESOURCES IS A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT WHERE YOUR THE
RESOURCE THAT ARE GOING INTO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM NOT T. K. ARE PRETTY SUS
COMPARABLE TO YOUR TICKET
RESOURCES.
SO YOU'RE AT YOUR RANK ABOUT OF
FORT FOURTEENTH OR THIRTEENTH
DEPENDING ON WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT FOR FOR RESOURCES BUT AN
IMPORTANT THING TO LOOK AT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE BOTTOM OF SITE.
THREE THAT LITTLE ASTERIX.
THERE'S NO REASON TO THINK THAT
PRESCHOOL SHOULD COSTS
DRAMATICALLY LESS.
BANGKIT TROUGH.
AND YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR
PREFERRED PK DOLLARS ARE
DRAMATICALLY LESS THAN TWELVE
DOLLARS SO THAT SOMETHING AND
AND AND THEN THAT SHOWS IF YOU
LOOK ON SLIDE. FOR THAT SHOWS IN
YOUR QUALITY BENCHMARKS --
WE HAVE TEN SPECIFIC --
POLICIES THAT WE LOOK AT A
CALIFORNIA STATE PRE K..
MEET SIX OF THOSE TEN AND THAT
THE FOR THAT YOU'RE MISSING
AGAIN ARE THE ONES THAT OFTEN
ARE THE MORE EXPENSIVE ONES
[inaudible]
THE SO THE CLASS SIZE OF TWINS
TO INTERPRET BECAUSE THAT EACH
THAT'S BECAUSE OF TKA.
ARE BIG CLASS I'D LIKE THINK YOU
ALSO DON'T HAVE A SIZE LIMIT IN
YOUR PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN ALL
YEAH WE HAVE THE RATIO BUT NOT
YEAH YOU HAVE THE RATIO BUT NOT
THAT LHASA YES SO YOU GET ONE OF
THEM.
AND MY CONCERN WITH THE RATIO I
WOULD JUST SAY IS.
A RATE RATIO --
IF IT'S JUST ADULTS TO CHILDREN
BUT GIVEN YOUR ASSISTANT TEACHER
QUALIFICATION RULES.
THAT.
AGAIN NOT.
MANY OF THOSE TEACHERS ARE GOING
TO BE EXCELLENT BUT MANY ARE NOT --
AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF THE PAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE HAVING A LOT OF TURN
OF ITS RESULT OF THAT --
SO THE THAT ONE TO EIGHT RATIOS
GREAT AND MAYBE YOU COULD DO
THAT WOULD AND CLASS AS A TWENTY
FOUR WE DON'T HAVE ANY GOOD DAY
TO SAY THAT YOU CAN DO THAT BUT
I THINK IT'S IT'S SOMETHING YOU
COULD.
ASK BET WHEN TO WHEN WHEN THAT
THAT ADULTS IN IN EVERY CASE IT
WELL IN. FOR TWO THIRDS OF THE
CLASSROOM AS AN ADULT WITH THE
HIS USE A CONSIDERED IT AT AN
ASSISTANT TEACHER THEN YOU'RE.
IT'S BEGINNING TO BE AN ISSUE I
THINK IN TERMS OF THE THE THE
FACT THAT [inaudible]
YOU.
YOU DON'T RECEIVE THE BENCHMARK
ON ONGOING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND ON TEACHER
QUALIFICATION AN ASSISTANT
TEACHER QUALIFICATION AND IT BE
IT BEGINS TO COMPOUND AND THAT'S
THAT'S A CONCERN THAT I WOULD
HAVE -- SO.
I'LL TURN OUT IT TO TALKING
ABOUT THE PROGRAM IN NEW JERSEY
THAT -- THE
DELEGATION WENT.
WENT TO VISIT ITS ON ON SLIDE
FIVE THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF ON
THIS SITE THAT ALL DOCTOR FREE.
TONIGHT CAN WE AT WE LOVE THIS
EVERYONE I WANT TO REALLY GET
INTO IT.
ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT WE TAKE TO
A TIME OUT FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND HAVE YOU COME BACK IN A SEC
YOU CAN ACTUALLY STAY RIGHT
THERE OKAY --
WE'RE GONNA BRING UP OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION MISTER THURMAN'S --
WELCOME BACK TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY TO THE END
COMMITTEE.
THE GOOD RIGHT YES THAT.
SORRY YEAH LIKE THIS IS THE MAN
WHO BROUGHT MY CHI THIS.
YEAH BUT THAT WAS WITHIN JUST A
I DO NOT MEAN TO IMPLY AS THEY
SAY.
NO SUCH THING AS OFF THE RIGHT.
WELCOME SUPERINTENDENT THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US THE STUFF LIKE
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE --
FORGIVE THE INTERRUPTION --
I DO HAVE A NOTE AND BUT WE
WE'RE JUST SO THRILLED THAT
YOU'VE CONVENE THIS CONVERSATION.
AND THAT HAD THE THE COMMITTEE
THAT YOU KNOW TAKE THE TRIP.
OUT TO THE EAST COAST TO SEE
THESE GREAT MODELS OF HOW
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED.
IN THEIR MANY TAKE AWAYS AND BUT
ONE OF THE MAIN TAKEAWAYS FROM
ME IS.
OUT WE ARE CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SHOULD LEAD.
AND AS THE STATE'S --
HAVE SHOWN US WHAT THEY'VE DONE
TO ACCOMPLISH UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS CLEAR TO ME --
THEY MADE SMART CHOICES AND GOOD
INVESTMENTS.
AND THEY'RE BEGINNING TO SEE THE
BENEFITS OF THOSE DECISIONS.
BUT THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING THAT
WE DON'T ALREADY KNOW HOW TO DO.
AND WE HAVEN'T HAD THE POLITICAL
WILL IN THE STATE TO DO IT AND
NOW WE DO --
BECAUSE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND A GOVERNOR WHO GETS IT --
AND GREAT EXPERTS IN PARTNERS
WE'VE HEARD FROM TODAY WHO SEND
ME OUT ON MISSIONS TO GET THEM
COFFEE AND TEA --
WHATEVER IT TAKES RIGHT SAYING
WHAT EVER IT TAKES TO GET THE
JOB DONE.
AND WE'RE DELIGHTED THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS ARTICULATED A
VISION FOR OUR UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL AND FOR EARLY CARE IN
ALL ASPECTS OF THE MENU OF
SERVICE DELIVERY --
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF STICKY ISSUES THAT HAVE TO
GET A DRESS LIKE WORK FORCE AND
IS IT RATES IN ITS SLOT --
TO START FOR YOU KNOW FOR YOUR
ROLES AND THEN YOU KNOW WORK
YOUR WAY DOWN --
BUT LET'S DO SOMETHING I THINK
THE GOVERNOR IS A A MARKER DOWN.
AND SAID THAT WE WILL GET THIS
DONE I'M SO THRILLED THAT WE
HAVE A GREAT DIVISION.
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ARE EARLY CARE
DIVISION IS READY OUR EARLY
LEARNING DIVISION IS READY TO
GET IT.
DONE WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A LEADER WHO YOU'LL HEAR
FROM IN A MOMENT --
WHO IS BAR NONE AND I THINK ONE
OF THE GREATEST LEADERS ON THESE
TOPICS ANYWHERE IN THE NATION?
AND I THINK EVERYTHING SHE TELL
ME WHAT TO SAY AT THE TIMING IS
NOW -- WE'RE
COMMITTED TO SAID JUST READ THE
NOTES --
PARTS ALWAYS BETTER YOU KNOW ME
AS SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW ME TO
CHAIR --
THIS IS SOMETHING I CARE ABOUT
BECAUSE WE CAN CLOSEST.
WE CAN ASSURE THAT EVERY TODAY
TODAY WE HOSTED OUR FIRST IN A
SERIES.
OF ROUND TABLES ABOUT CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP [inaudible]
AND A HUNDRED PEOPLE SHOWED UP.
THEN I ASK THE PEOPLE IN THAT
ROOM IF THEY WOULD COMMIT WITH
ME. TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
YOUNG PERSON.
WHO ENTERS SCHOOL IN SEPTEMBER?
WE WE DON'T TRACK THEM BUT WE
KEEP TRACK OF THEIR PROGRESS.
IN THEIR ABILITY TO LEARN TO
READ BY THIRD GRADE.
THE WE CAN CHANGE THE
CONVERSATION.
THAT WE CAN SAY THAT FROM THIS
POINT FORWARD FROM NOW ON ALL OF
OUR KIDS LEARN TO READ BY THIRD
GRADE.
AND THAT WE CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT STARZ
BEFORE KINDERGARTEN.
AND SO.
WITH YOUR PERMISSION MISTER
CHAIR LIKE TO TURN IT OVER. TO
OUR DIVISION DIRECTOR SERRA
NOBLE -- WHO
YOU GOT SPEND TIME WITH ON THE
TRIP WE ALL DID AND FOLLOWED HER
LEADERSHIP AND I THINK --
THE TRIP WAS REALLY GREAT THAT
FOR INVITING ME AND FOR ALL THE
LESSONS LEARNED AND FOR
CONTINUING THE WORK IN THE
MOMENTUM TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN --
AND ESTIMATE THE BALANCE OF MY
TIME -- TO
OUR DIVISION DIRECTOR OKAY THANK
YOU AND WE'RE GOING.
TO HAVE HER COME BACK IN A SEC
RUN GO BACK TO OUR PRESENTATION
BE BUT BEFORE YOU GO --
THANKS FOR LAYING OUT THE VISION
YOU KNOW IF YOU KNOW FEEL LIKE
WE SHOULD ADJOURN THE HEARING
HERE BECAUSE HE LAID IT ALL OUT
THERE.
BUT FOR ITS GOT BACK HE TELLS
THE DETAILS RIGHT THE NUANCES
HOW WE FIND IT WITH THE ELEMENTS
ARE.
NOT SAID THE REST OF THE HEARING
WILL SAY BUT I LIKE CALCULATED
OUT THERE ONE THING.
LIKE THINK SO IMPORTANT IS HE'S
TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA LEADING WE
LEAD IN.
VIA MENTAL ISSUES --
HEALTH CARE YOU KNOW TAKEN ON
THE GUN LOBBY TOBACCO INDUSTRY
IN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
BUT IN THIS ONE WERE WAY.
BOTTOM AND AND THERE'S A THING
FOR ME MOMENT HIGHEST PERCENTAGE
OF THEIR KIDS GOING TO PRE K.
PROGRAM.
THERE ARE RED STATES.
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE LED BY
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS SO THIS IS
NOT.
A RED VERSUS BLUE DEMOCRAT
REPUBLICAN THIS IS YOU KNOW
COMMONSENSE EARLY EDUCATION
MATTERS SO THANKS FOR THAT FOR
THE REMINDER SUPERINTENDENT
THANK YOU WERE AT YOUR DISPOSAL
YOU'VE GOT SOME GREAT MEMBERS ON
THIS COMMITTEE PLEASE GIVE OUR
REGARDS.
BUT TO THE CHAIR WHO I KNOW IS
PROBABLY ON IMPORTANT BUSINESS
ON WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH IT'S A MEMBER KALRA.
ADJOINING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SUSHI
I THINK --
AND SOME MEMBER KILEY
[inaudible]
AND LIMON.
YOU KNOW JUST A GREAT COMMITTEE
OF EDUCATORS AND WE STAND --
ALL TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED OF US OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STAND READY TO HELP
YOU IMPLEMENT THIS THE TIME IS
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH US.
DON'T GO FAR THIS LEVEL MORE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
A DOCTOR WILL COME BACK TO YOU.
KATE SO I WAS ACTUALLY JUST
GOING INTO NEW JERSEY SAID THAT
THAT WAS AGAIN A GOOD SPOT --
SO I WAS AN ASSISTANT TO THE
COMMISSIONER FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IN NEW JERSEY WHEN OUR
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WAS EXPANDING
AND BEING FORMED --
IT'S A UNUSUAL PROGRAM IN THAT
IT WAS COURT ORDERED AND UNDER
SCHOOL FUNDING --
COURT CASE THAT'S LONG STANDING
IT'S NOW. FIFTY YEARS OLD.
THE THE BUT I WON'T SPEND A LOT
OF TIME.
GOING INTO DETAIL ABOUT ABOUT
THAT THAT THAT BUT I DO WANT TO
TELL YOU THAT.
THE OUR NEW JERSEY PROGRAM MATT
ALL OF THOSE ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS
THAT ARE IN GREEDY KEY
INGREDIENTS THAT I TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER.
ON SLIDE --
TO FUNDING WAS WAS MANDATED FOR
ALL THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS.
AS IT WAS AT UNIVERSAL ACCESS IN
THIRTY ONE LOW INCOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
SO WE DID AND THAT WITH OF WHAT.
PRESCHOOL POPULATION OF THOSE.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WAS WAS.
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND SO IT'S
NOTHING LIKE THE MAGNITUDE OF
SCALE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT --
NEW JERSEY IS DENSELY POPULATED
BUT TINY SO OUR OUR TOTAL
POPULATION IS IS IS SMALL
COMPARED TO YOURS --
THE FUNDING THAT WENT INTO THIS
PROGRAM FIRST WAS USED TO
IMPROVE PROGRAM STANDARDS.
AND THE KINDS OF THINGS I TALKED
ABOUT TEACHERS WITH BACHELOR'S
DEGREES PAID.
AT PARITY ON THE SAME CELL RISK
LIST OF WHERE THEY TAUGHT --
IT WAS A MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND THAT IN THE BEGINNING TWO
THIRDS OF THE CHILDREN WERE
SERVED AND PRIVATE PROVIDER
CLASSROOMS EITHER CHILD LICENSED
CHILDCARE CENTERS OR HEAD START
PROGRAMS --
AND THEN THE OTHER THIRD IN
PUBLIC SCHOOL CLASSROOMS BUT
THERE WAS ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
AND THAT WAS BECAUSE IT WAS A
PUBLIC EDUCATION PROGRAM AND
IT'S A PUBLIC EDUCATION PROGRAM.
THE THE QUALITY AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT FUNDING AND IMPROVE
STANDARDS AND THEN PLAYED
RESOURCES.
AND A LOT OF SUPPORT TO PROGRAMS
QUALITY IN THE CLASSROOMS
IMPROVE DRAMATICALLY OVER THE
FIRST. THREE YEARS AND THEN BY
BY THE TIME THE PROGRAM WAS
EIGHT YEARS OLD IT WAS IT WAS
QUITE GOOD.
AND THAT YOU CAN SEE IN THE
SMALL SLIDE IN THIS INSIGHT IS.
INSERTED SLIGHT GOT GRAPH ON THE
LEFT HAND CORNER YOU'LL SEE HOW
AT THE CRAFT SKEWS TO THE RIGHT
AND THAT'S AS TIME GOES BY THAT.
THE PROGRAM IMPROVES AND REALLY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
NO CLASSROOMS SCORED AND THE
AREA THAT WOULD BE CALLED CAN TO
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS FOR
CHILDREN ARE HARMFUL TO CHILDREN.
AND VERY FEW SCORED BELOW THE
MIDLINE BY THE END OF THIS AT
THIS PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT IN THE
RESOURCES GOING AND SO IT TOOK
ABOUT THREE SOURCES AND PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENTS --
INITIATIVES.
WHAT HAPPENED AS A RESULT YOU'LL
SEE ON THE SLIDE AT THE?
RIGHT THAT GRAPH AT THE RIGHT
UPPER RIGHT HAND OF THE SLIDE --
FIVE FOURTH AND FIFTH GRADE WE
WERE DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THAT.
HAD THEIR MATIC EFFECTS ON
CHILDREN'S STATE TESTED --
ABILITIES AND AND THE STATE
ACHIEVEMENT TEST IN SOME CASES
ARE UP TO ALMOST CLOSE 240%.
OF AN EFFECT SIZE OF ALMOST
FORTY WHICH IS BEING ABOUT THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP SO WERE CAUSING
A GREAT A GREAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND AND SOME --
SUBJECT A MAN'S AN AN IMPORTANT
IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET WE ALSO
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND GRADE RETENTION.
BOTH OF WHICH ARE COSTLY AND
WHAT YOU SEE ON THE SMALL SIDE
AT THE TOP IS THAT TWO YEARS WAS
BETTER THAN.
ONE AND IT BUT WITH BUT ONE
STILL HAD SOME HAD HAD
CONSIDERABLE IMPACT.
SO WHAT I KNOW THAT YOU ALL ARE
VERY INTERESTED SORRY THAT'S MY
TEXAN ISM COMING OUT I GREW UP
IN TEXAS --
BY THE WAY THAT'S ONE OF THE
OTHER STATES THAT HAS NO CLASS
SIZE LIMIT ON PRE K. SO.
YOU GOT OUT SCORE TEXAS ON AS A
THE THE I WANNA TALK ABOUT HOW
WE GOT FROM.
A SYSTEM WHICH IN MOST AND MANY
OF THE CLASSROOM IN MOST OF THE
CLASSROOMS THAT.
THAT THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO THE
ABBOTT PRICKETT COMING AND THE
TEACHERS DIDN'T WERE NOT
QUALIFIED AND DID NOT HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE --
AND WE TOOK THAT WORK FORCE AND
GREW THEM TO BE --
TO BE QUALIFIED INTO WE WE BUILT
ON THE CURRENT WORK FORCE WHEN
WE DID THIS AND WETHINK THAT'S
A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THING
THEY BROUGHT EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE FREE FOR ME FROM
YEARS OF WORKING WITH CHILDREN.
THEY HAD SHOWN THEY HAD.
AT A GREAT APPLICATION FOR THIS
BUT DIDN'T YET HAVE THE FULL
PREPARATION.
AND THAT WAS NECESSARY FOR IT TO
BE A FULLY EDUCATIONAL PRIME
DOESN'T MEAN MANY OF THE MORE
EXCELLENT TEACHERS --
BUT BUT YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
QUALITY THAT THAT IMPROVE
DRAMATICALLY AS THEY WENT BACK
TO SCHOOL AND GOT MORE TRAINING --
SO HOW DO WE CALL HOW DO WE PAY
FOR THIS AND ITS IT'S AND WHAT
PERSONAL WHAT WHAT DID WE PAY --
FOR WE HAVEN'T SO.
ON THE ON THE NEXT SLIDE INSIDE
SEXUAL SEE THAT THEY WERE IT
STARTED AND THEN WHAT SOME OF
THE REMEDIES WERE ON THE ON THE
RIGHT HAND SIDE.
SO WE HAD A LIMITED QUALIFY
TEACHER POOL WE DON'T EVEN HAVE
A STATE CERTIFICATION AT THE
TIME.
SO WE WHAT WE PAID FOR WITH
SCHOLARSHIPS THESE ARE FULL
SCHOLARSHIPS THESE ARE NOT.
THIS IS COLLEGE SHIPS WHERE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO LAY OUT THE MONEY
IN ADVANCE --
AND SO THAT THE MONEY WAS WAS --
ADMINISTERED BY A THIRD PARTY
AND ED.
AND WE ALSO PROVIDED --
RELEASE TIME FOR THE TEACHERS IN
OTHER WORDS IF THEY HAD TO TAKE
A COURSE DURING THE DAY --
THAT CENTER WOULD GET MONEY FOR
A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER.
WE WERE WE WERE ALL IN ON THIS.
AND AND IT WAS MONEY WELL SPENT
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE ELEVATING THE
WORK FORCE AND AND AND MAKING
THIS A JOB THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD
JOB A GOOD QUALITY JOHN.
WE ALSO HAD IN PLACE WHICH AND I
THINK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
WE HAD A POST BACCALAUREATE
ALTERNATE ROUTE.
CERTIFICATE.
SO -- IN
FIFTEEN CREDITS VERY CLEARLY
DEFINED NOT THE COURSES
THEMSELVES BUT THE COMPETENCIES.
THAT --
TEACHERS WHO HAD OF ASHER STREET
EITHER PUBLIC SCHOOL CLASSROOM
OR IN A PRIVATE PROVIDER
CLASSROOM.
ENROLL IN THIS PROGRAM COMPLETE
WITH SUCCESSFULLY WITHIN TWO
YEARS AND THEN HAVE A SORT OF TO
BE CERTIFIED TO TEACH THEY WOULD
GET UP THEY WOULD GET PAID ON
THE PAY SCALE BUT IT'LL SLIGHTLY
LOWER RATE THAN SOMEONE WHO
ALREADY HAD THEIR CERTIFICATION --
WE HAD SOME SIGNING BONUSES THEN
THE BEGINNING TO GET PEOPLE TO
TO TO TEACH AND THEN BUT THAT
THAT WENT AWAY PRETTY QUICKLY
AND BUT THE BIGGEST THE REALLY
IMPORTANT THING WAS HAVING
COMPARABLE SALARIES.
THAT THIS ATTRACTED TEACHERS TO
THIS -- HE
WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE TAUGHT
KINDERGARTEN OR FIRST GRADE IF
THEY HAD THE P. THREE
CERTIFICATE.
WE TO REINSTATE THE CERTIFICATE --
BRING A GONE AWAY.
AND SO I COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE EVER NIGHT I MEAN I
REMEMBER I WAS A COLLEGE
PROFESSOR IN THE TEACHER
EDUCATION PROGRAM AT THE TIME.
AND WE HAD A WEEKEND TO GET HER
PROPOSAL TO AND I DID.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO
GET THIS ACCOMPLISHED.
WE ALSO THOUGH HAD SCARCITY OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
FACULTY.
AND AND PARTICULARLY.
THE SCARCITY OF THOSE WHO ARE
EXPERTS AND HOW TO TEACH
PRESCHOOLERS.
THEY MIGHT HAVE KNOWN FOR FIRST
GRADE BUT THAT'S NOT THE SAME
AND SO --
WHAT WE DID WHEN I WENT TO THE
STATE WAS AYE FORM THE EARLY
LEARNING IMPROVEMENT CONSORTIUM
WHICH WAS A HIGHER EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM THAT HELPED ME?
DEVELOP THE DATA SYSTEM FOR THE
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT --
SYSTEM THAT WE PUT IN PLACE BUT
ALSO. FIVE FORMING THIS NETWORK
THEY HELP EACH OTHER UPGRADE
THEIR KNOWLEDGE BASE AND AND IN
IN IN EARLY CHILDHOOD.
OF COURSE WE HAD TO HIRE PEOPLE
TO I MEAN COLLEGES HAD HEART
PEOPLE.
OF THE WE ALSO HAD CENTER
DIRECTORS WHO.
WHILE THEY MAY HAVE HAD
EXPERIENCE DIRECTING THEIR
CENTER DID NOT HAVE.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
EXPERTISE --
NOT ALL OF THEM SAYING THERE
WERE SOME LIKE THIS AND AND ALSO
MANY DID NOT HAVE GOOD
ADMINISTRATIVE.
EXPERTISE WE FOUND THIS OUT BY
EACH OF THEM SUBMITTED AN ANNUAL
BUDGET.
AND THERE WERE.
WAS A LOT OF REMEDIATION THAT
HAD TO BE DONE JUST ON HOW TO DO
A BUDGET AND AND SOMEWHERE USING
THEIR ATM MACHINES I'M.
AS THEIR WAY OF USING DOING ED
DOING PAYROLL ONE THING IT WAS
M..
SET SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THAT WENT INTO PLACE AND
TRAINING AND HELPING THEM GET
GET.
GET FULLY QUALIFIED AGAIN.
NOT ALL SENATOR AFTER SOME OF
THEM WERE THE ONES DOING
TRAINING --
IT IT IT VERY BUT IT WAS ONE OF
THE THINGS WE HAVE TO WORK ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN SERVICES --
DEVELOP DIRECTORS ACADEMIES TO
HELP WITH THIS AND WE A PUT
FISCAL SPECIALISTS AND EVERY --
DISTRICT TO HELP.
PROVIDE.
TRAINING FOR AND GUIDANCE TO THE
CENTER DIRECTOR STATES THAT THEY
COULD DO THE ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE
OF THIS.
WE ALSO PUT IN A CENTER DIRECTOR
SALARIES GOT HIS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE COULDN'T BE
RAISING THE TEACHER SALARY AND
THEN FORGETTING THE CENTER
DIRECTORS.
AND THE RIGHT WAY TO MAKE THE
MOST MONEY WAS TO HAVE A LARGE
CENTER HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
EXPERTISE IN ADMINISTRATION --
WE ALSO MADE IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO HAVE A VERY SMALL
CENTER BECAUSE THE COSTS OF THAT
TO FOR TAX THAT THE STATE.
OR JUST AT TOO EXPENSIVE TO TO
GENERATE THE MONEY FOR CENTER
DIRECTOR I CAN TALK MORE ABOUT
THAT IF YOU WANT BUT THIS IS
WEEDY.
SO -- AND
EVERYBODY EVERYBODY NEEDED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THIS
DATE THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN PARTICULAR COULD BARELY
WORKED WITH YOUNG CHILDREN AT
THAT TIME YOU YOU HAVE AN
ADVANTAGE HERE WERE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HERE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN --
AND WE HAVE SO WE HAD A LOT OF
WORK AT THE STATE WE HAD TO DO
TO ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY WAS UP
TO STANDARD --
AND THEN IMPORTANTLY.
THE STATE AGENCY CAPACITY WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I I WILL I
WILL.
URGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT THIS
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT EXPANSION --
DO YOU NEED TO HAVE AN ADEQUATE.
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE STATE
AGENCY TO SUPPORT QUALITY.
NOT AS IT NOT THE GOTCHA
MONITORING KINDS BUT REALLY TO
BE A PARTNER.
TO THE DISTRICTS AND THE
PROVIDERS AND TO HELP THEM.
COME IN THERE FOR PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT.
AND I ALSO WHEN THEY OFFERED ME
THE JOB OF ASSISTANT
COMMISSIONER I SAID NOT IF I'M
NOT SENIOR STAFF.
THE REASON IT WASN'T BECAUSE OF
MY EGO ALTHOUGH THAT ALWAYS
UNDERSTAND.
IT WAS.
IT WAS BECAUSE PRESCHOOL WAS NEW.
TO TO THIS AGENCY AND NOBODY
KNEW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
AND I SAID I HAVE TO BE AT THE
TABLE.
AND OR THE PERSON IN THIS
POSITION HAS TO BE AT THE TABLE
SO I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHERE
HOW YOUR CONFIGURED BUT I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT THING
TO CONSIDER.
IS -- THAT
THAT QUESTIONS ARE BEING
INFORMED SOMEWHAT BY PROVIDE AN
EXPERT AND EARLY CHILDHOOD --
IF YOU TURNED ASIDE SEVEN I JUST
WANTED TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
HEY HOW WE FINANCED THE WORK
FORCE SIDE OF THIS SHOULD FIRST
JUST SAY ALL OF THIS CAME OUT OF
THE GENERAL FUND DID NOT COME
OUT OF CONTROL FUNDING --
AND IT WAS.
A VERY VERY VERY VERY TINY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE TOTAL BUDGET I
DON'T REMEMBER EXACTLY NOW BUT
IT WAS LESS THAN 1%.
OF THE TOTAL GENERAL FUND --
THE BUT THE WAY THAT WE FUNDED
THE WORK.
FOR BUILDING OF THE WORK FORCE
WAS NOT WE DIDN'T DO THIS PLAN
FULLY IT'S JUST THE FACT THAT
THIS HAPPENS --
AND I'LL TRY TO EXPLAIN IT IN A
WAY THAT MAKES SENSE BUT WHEN
UNIVERSAL PRE K. IS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED.
THE COST PER YEAR IS ABOUT WHAT
KICK TWELVE COSTS.
AND SO IF YOU THINK OF THAT
YOU'RE ADDING A YEAR PUBLIC
EDUCATION THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
I MEAN IF YOU THINK IF YOU'RE
GOING TO DO UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL%
AND I MEAN THIS IS JUST A WAY TO
THINK ABOUT THIS --
BUT IN START UP YEARS IS NOT A
COST THAT MUCH.
BECAUSE TEACHERS ARE GOING TO BE
FULLY QUALIFIED THEY'RE NOT IN
BECOMING SAID AT THAT LEVEL YOU
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE JUST AREN'T
GOING TO HAVE THAT MANY COSTS
BUT SO THAT.
IF YOU STILL THINK ABOUT THE
FULL COST.
SOME OF THAT CAN BEAT CAN BE
DEVOTED --
TO SUPPORTING TEACHERS IN
GETTING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE SO
EASY YOU JUST HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT THE COSTS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY AND LAYER THEM
DIFFERENTLY IN OVERTIME BECAUSE
MORE AND MORE INTO SALARIES AND
LESS AND LESS AND LESS INTO.
PREPARING PEOPLE.
HAD I DO KATIE WAS THAT CLOSE.
CAPE HELP ME PRACTICE THAT I
THINK -- AND
I WANT TO SAY WE HAD A 2% SET
ASIDE FOR ARE ALL FROM MY OFFICE.
OUT OF THE FOR TOTAL BUDGET AND
SET IT.
SO THAT WE COULD FIND RESEARCH
AND AND ADD TRY TO DO
EXPERIMENTS WE DIDN'T EXPERIMENT
OF LOOKING AT LONGER DAY VERSUS
SHORTER DAY WE DIDN'T AT DO A
LANGUAGE.
SO WE TRIED TO THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE GOOD ANSWERS
FOR WE HAVE A NOW FOR YOU SO YOU
DON'T NEED TO DO THAT BUT IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS THAT COME UP YOU
DON'T HAVE GOOD ANSWERS FOR
RATHER THAN WHOLESALE DOING
ACROSS THE WHOLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
TRY IT OUT A COUPLE PLACES
BEFORE YOU.
BUTTE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T RIGHT
THE SHIP IS REALLY HARD TO WRITE
ONCE IT ONCE IT'S ONCE IT'S IN
PLACE.
AND THEN THE THE NEXT SIDE.
TALKS A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OTHER
CRITICAL DECISIONS AND I'VE
HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT SOME OF
ALREADY SO IT WON'T SPEND A LOT
OF TIME ON BUT YOU WERE JUST
TRYING TO THE GOVERNANCE ISSUE --
AND ALSO ADMINISTRATION DO YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THIS ALL HOUSING
ONE AGENCY DO YOU MAY ADMINISTER
CLOSER TO THE GROUND AND A MORE
LOCAL LOCAL WAY --
OBVIOUSLY WHAT WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE PART OF THIS IS A
DECISION THAT HAS TO BE MADE --
AND THEN HOW DO YOU DISTRIBUTE
THE FUNDS ARE THEY IS A
COMPETITIVE AS IT DIRECTOR
PROGRAM OR DO YOU HAVE SOME
INTERMEDIARY AND OUR CASE IT WAS
A SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS THE
INTERMEDIARY --
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS ARE.
FACILITIES AN INTEGRATED DATA
SYSTEMS YOU YEAH YOU CAN MAKE
THIS HAPPEN TO YOU CAN INSURANCE
CAN BE HIGH QUALITY IF YOU DON'T
SUPPORT THAT THOSE --
AND THEN --
WE ARE TO TALK ABOUT THE PROGRAM
THE PROGRAM COMPONENTS --
BUT I ANOTHER THING THAT I THINK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT WE'RE SEEING
IN NEW JERSEY.
AS YOU HAVE TO BUILDING
MECHANISMS FOR SUSTAINABILITY
AND NOT JUST OF THE FUNDING BUT
OF A QUALITY.
THAT WE WE HAVE I CAN POINT YOU
TO A COUPLE OF STATES WERE
QUALITY HAS BEEN ERODING IN NEW
JERSEY IS ONE OF THEM AND IT'S
VERY CONCERNING.
AND SO THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT YOU BILLS
HERE IT IS IS STILL HERE IN
TWENTY YEARS.
AND THEN I HAVE TO EXAMPLES FROM
OTHER STATES AND I'M NOT SURE
WHETHER YOU ALL ARE GETTING
TIRED OF HEARING ME OR I SHOULD
KEEP GOING.
OKAY.
OKAY -- THE
I JUST WANTED. TO TO REDUCE THE
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY TALKED ABOUT TO
A TO READ STATES IN ALABAMA
NORTH CAROLINA ARE GOOD EXAMPLES
OF THIS THERE.
THEY ARE LEADERS IN AND PRE K.
NORTH CAROLINA --
AND AN EARLY LEADER IN ALABAMA
I'M MORE RECENT --
ONE OUT I LOVE ELEMENT IN THE
NAME OF ALLAH CLASS.
FIRST CLASS FREE K..
F. -- AND
THE THINGS THAT ARE INTERESTING
ABOUT ALL OF THEM I WILL FIRST
OF ALL IF IT MEETS ALL OF THE
TEN BENCHMARKS AND HAS A VERY
STRONG ENABLING ENVIRONMENT.
IT IS GOVERNED OUT OF A
STANDALONE EARLY LEARNING
DEPARTMENT.
AT A SECOND IT HAS A SECRETARY
LEVEL APPOINT LEAD.
AND I THINK THAT CAUSES PROBLEMS
IN TERMS OF THE CAGE WALL
CONTINUITY BUT IT ALSO.
IT MAKES THINGS EASIER ACROSS
THE WHOLE SPECTRUM --
ZERO TO FIVE AND THEY THEY USE A
COMPETITIVE GRANT NEXT DELIVERY
SYSTEM SO THEY HAVE TO THAT
MEANS THAT THE THAT THEY ARE
DEPARTMENT HAS.
TO APPROVE EVERY GRANT THAT
COMES IN FOR A PRE K. PROGRAM --
SO THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
YOU HAVE TO WEIGH IN IN IN
THINKING ABOUT IT.
THEY'VE HAD REALLY RAPID
EXPANSION FROM 6% OF THEIR FOUR
YEAR OLDS 224% IN LESS THAN FIVE
YEARS AND THEY AVE ALL THEY
HAVE A PLANNED EXPANSION I THINK
THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL THEY
THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO SCALE.
THIS FOR FOR ALL KIDS ARE LONE
CAM K?T IT'S IT'S STARTING LOW
INCOME BUT IT WILL BE UNIVERSAL
AND I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER THING
IN WHICH CHILDREN ARE YOU GONNA.
IN NEW JERSEY WE ARE EXPANSION
HAS WORKED WITH FIRST THESE LOW
INCOME SMALLER DISTRICTS IT WAS
UNIVERSAL WITHIN THOSE DISTRICTS
YOU COULD BE A WEALTHY.
FAMILY IN YOUR CHILD IS STILL
GOING TO ELIGIBLE BECAUSE PUBLIC
SCHOOL.
AND THE WE'RE EXPANDING NOW IT
TO THE NEXT.
NEXT HERE OF DISTRICTS SAID
THERE'D LESS LOW INCOME
DISTRICTS BUT THEY'RE STILL HAVE
A HIGH PROPORTION OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES --
AND SO THAT'S ONE WAY TO THINK
ABOUT TEARING THIS SO THAT
YOU'RE SO YOU'RE MEETING THE
NEEDIEST FIRST BUT KNOWING THAT
PRE K. AS IT --
IS BENEFICIAL TO ALL.
SO IT AND AND ALSO THERE'S OTHER
REASONS WE WE HAVE SOME SOME.
HENCE THAT A CRITICAL MASS
COMING INTO KINDERGARTEN MATTERS
SO IF YOU'RE ONLY SERVING LOW
INCOME CHILDREN.
WHO HAVE HAD THIS PROGRAM --
YOU THE KINDERGARTEN DOESN'T
MISS WHAT AND THEN THAT MAY BE
ONE REASON WE'RE NOT SING
PROGRAMS --
SO --
ALABAMA SOUND EFFECTS INTO.
ENTER THE SCHOOL GRADES NORTH
CAROLINA IS A MUCH LONGER
STANDING PROGRAM IT'S BEGINNING
IS ONE OF THE STATES THAT
PROGRAMS IT'S GETTING ERODED.
AND IT WAS PART OF JIM HUNTS
HOLD EDUCATION APPROACH WERE HAD
A CHILDREN'S CABINET AND THERE
WAS A GREAT DEAL OF EMPHASIS ON
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION AND NOW
NORTH CAROLINA AT THE TIME.
THEY ALSO EXCEEDED THEM NEAR TEN
BENCHMARKS THEY HAVE.
THAT THE TEACH PROGRAM WHICH IS
A REALLY INTERESTING WAY OF A
PROVIDING SCHOLARSHIP AND
SUPPORTED TEACHERS AS THEY GO
BACK TO SCHOOL WAS FOUNDED IN
NORTH CAROLINA AND ACTUALLY
CREATED BY THE STATE THERE.
BUT IS NOW BEING USED IN TWENTY
OTHER STATES --
YOUR WAGES PROGRAM THAT YOU'VE
USED IS ALSO ONE THAT CAME OUT
OF NORTH CAROLINA AND THE VISION
AND SOME LOCATIONS --
THEY HAVE PAYING ENHANCEMENT.
OUTSIDE OF THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
CLASSROOMS BUT NOT PAY PARITY.
AT EVENT THEY ALSO HAVE AFFECTS
INTO THE SCHOOL GRADES.
SO I'M HAPPY. TO TO TALK MORE
ABOUT OTHER STATES BUT LET ME
JUST MAKE A FEW CONCLUSION.
INCLUSIONS WE KNOW THAT MANY
PRESCHOOL FUNDS ARE NOT
DELIVERING.
THE DESIRED RESULTS.
AND WE THINK AN ADEQUATE.
AND ADEQUATELY PREPARED TEACHERS
IS LIKELY ONE OF THOSE REASONS --
BUT AGAIN NO SINGLE INGREDIENT.
I'M.
THE ONE THING WE DO KNOW IS THAT
ONLY PRO HIGHLY EDUCATED WELL
PAID TEACHERS [inaudible]
HAVE.
ON AFFECTS THAT ARE LASTING.
WHEN WE LOOK ACROSS ALL THE BODY
OF RESEARCH THAT ONCE THAT THAT
SHOW THAT HAD TEACHERS LIKE THAT
THEN THAT'S?
THAT'S THE AND SO THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT AND COMPELLING REASON
THE OTHER IS.
THAT.
THIS THEN BUILT A WORKFORCE THAT
IS WELL PAID AND AND AND IS A
GOOD AT AND AND IT HELPS THE
COMMUNITY IN GENERAL
[inaudible]
THE IT'S NOT SUFFICIENT.
AND ALL KINDS OF WORKING
CONDITIONS ARE IMPORTANT IN
ADDITION TO THE PAY.
BUT ALL THE OTHER PROGRAM.
COMPONENTS THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT NEED.
ALSO NEED TO BE IN PLACE.
AND FINALLY JUST TO SHOW THAT
I'M.
AN EDUCATED UNIVERSITY PERSON I
HAD TO HAVE A LITERARY QUOTE FOR
YOU.
FROM EVER IN EBENEZER SCROOGE
WHICH FALLS IN THAT LITTLE KIDS
AND TAYLOR.
OKAY THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FROM THE NUMBER OF CARS.
AT THE END THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
IT'S IS IT FREED DOT THREE
PRETTY DOCTOR PRETTY WELL FIRST
OF ALL AB.
BE ELECTED PERSONNEL GOING ON MY
LIMóN TO ARE NEVER SEEN ANYONE
USE EBENEZER SCROOGE QUOTE IN A
PRESENTATION AND IT WORKS.
RESOLUTIONS --
AND YOU KNOW WHAT.
ALTHOUGH YOU INDICATE THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF INGREDIENTS THAT.
INDICATE --
DEGREES SUCCESS ONE IN THAT
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE AND I MEAN
OFTENTIMES TALK ABOUT.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION --
PRE K. AND PEOPLE THINK THAT
IT'S A GLORIFIED BABY TEACHER A
BABY HAVE BABYSITTERS --
WE KNOW THAT'S NOT THE CASE AND
I THINK THAT YOU KIND OF
REITERATE THAT THREE EUROPORT --
AND AND SO ALL THE AND AND ENTER
INTO THIS TO THE THE STANDARDS
ARE METRICS ARE.
ALL IMPORTANT BUT IT ALWAYS
COMES BACK TO KIND BEST IN
PEOPLE.
AND AND WHICH CERTAINLY COSTS
MONEY.
BUT YOU HAVE BEEN DOING A
PROGRAM OF THIS NATURE AND NOT.
PUTTING THAT INVESTMENT UP FRONT
YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE AS AS YOU
INDICATE TO REPORT THE RESULTS
THAT WE ARE DESIRING YOU'LL JUST.
HAVE A PROGRAM AND IT'S NOT IT'S
JUST GOING TO BECOME.
GLORIFIED BABYSITTERS RATHER
THAN THE ACTUAL EDUCATORS THAT
WE NEED AT THAT EARLY LEVEL.
AND I LOOK AT YOUR REFERENCES SO
YOU SOMETIMES PEOPLE DO LOOK AT
THE END OF THE OTHER FREE.
I LOOK TO THE REFERENCES AND SEE
THAT YOU'VE WRITTEN A COUPLE OF
PAPERS.
ABOUT THE LONG TERM EFFECTS.
OF THE BRISTOL PRESCHOOL AND
WHAT HAVE YOU.
AND LOOKING AT LOOKS LIKE
LOOKING AT NEW JERSEY
[inaudible]
CAN WE HAS IT OVER THE IN IN
THESE REPORTS THAT YOU'VE DONE.
IS THERE A CO QUANTIFICATION
EITHER MONEY OR OTHER IN OTHER
RESOURCES AS TO WHAT.
THE STATE SAVES MAY BE A
REDUCTION ACROSS RACIAL RATES
MAY BE ABOUT --
TO APE.
OF EMPLOYABLE.
GRADUATES COMING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE IS YOUR
INCREASING YOUR TAX BASE.
OF IT CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT
AND AND SAY IT SEE IF THERE IS
DATA OR IF NOT IF THERE WE CAN
EXPECT DATA SINCE THESE PROGRAMS
ARE GETTING TO A POINT WHERE.
THOSE LITTLE DOLLARS NOW ARE YOU
ENTERING THE WORK FORCE ONE IDEA.
THEN THEY'RE NOT QUITE THE
ALMOST IRVINE HIGH SCHOOL OF THE
CULVERT WERE STUDYING M. IS IN
HIGH SCHOOL OKAY AND WE'RE WE
JUST GOT FUNDING TO LOOK AT THAT
THEM.
FURTHER ON AND AND MUCH TO MY
DISMAY.
ISN'T IT AND IS ALSO AN
ECONOMIST HAS NOT DONE THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS YET.
SO HE IS THE WAS THE INITIAL
ECONOMIST ON THE PERRY PRESCHOOL
STUDY AS WELL AS ON APPOSITE
DERIAN STUDY --
BUT THE REASON THAT HE HASN'T IS
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
DATA.
THAT TO TO TO DO WE COULD DO
SOME VERY VERY FUZZY.
THE KIND OF THING ECONOMIST TO A
WHOLE LOT OF OF YET PREDICTING
WHAT WHAT MIGHT BE THE EFFECTS
BUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
WAIT A LITTLE BIT AND AND WE'RE
SO LITTLE UNDER FIND IT SO IF
ANY OF THE ONE OF THE FIRST SHIP
SOME.
CALIFORNIA DOLLARS TO US TO FUND
THIS WEEKEND.
WILL BE BETTER BUT I THINK THE
THING WE KNOW IS THAT THE
SAVINGS COME FROM THREE TENSION.
THAT THAT CRIME AND DELINQUENCY
EAT MOST MOST OF THE SAVINGS
FROM THAT COME IN ADULTHOOD BUT
SOME COME IN IN HIGH SCHOOL --
AND THEN THE TAXPAYER OBVIOUSLY
THEY HAVE TO GET INTO THE WORK
FORCE BEFORE WE CAN.
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO STUDY THIS COHORT THAT
WELL -- TECH
BUT WE CAN BEGIN AT LEAST WITH
THE ADMINISTRATIVE DATA I THINK
THEY'LL BE VERY HELPFUL IN
PARTICULAR IN A COUPLE YEARS
WHEN THEY DO INTO THE WORK FORCE
YOU CAN SEE HOW MANY WERE.
DROP OUTS HOW HOW MANY MADE
UNFORTUNATE COME ADDRESSES SOME
VERSES.
ARE COMPATIBLE POPULATIONS THAT
DON'T HAVE THAT REALLY CHALLENGE
CASE BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THE
QUESTIONS ALWAYS GONNA COME UP
AS ARTICLE A COUPLE TIMES OF THE
COST.
AND SO WE CAN SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY A SAVE US A
WHOLE LOT OF MONEY EVEN PUTTING
TEACHERS GOING IN THE COLLEGE
DEGREE IS MAKE SURE THEY'RE
CERTIFIED.
YES THAT COST A LOT UP FRONT BUT
IT WILL SAVE US A WHOLE LOT MORE
LATER ON AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
THE THOROUGHNESS OF YOUR OF YOUR
REPORT AND THE WORK YOU'RE DOING
SO THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THANK YOU BEFORE I GET --
TO SO MEMBERS MET I JUST WANNA
KNOW DOT ON YOUR POINT IS THAT
INTUITIVELY WE KNOW IT'S IT'S A
GOOD INVESTMENT BUT BUT MAYBE
NOT -- NEW
JERSEY BUT THE LANDMARK PERRY
STUDIES SHOW THAT KIDS WHO WENT
TO HIGH RATES I THINK --
INCREASE BY ABOUT 50% AND THEIR
INCARCERATION RATES IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM DECREASED BY
ABOUT A THIRD.
AND YOU KNOW TO AN OLD JUVENILE
HALL LA COUNTY IS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE GRAND A
YEAR.
PER KID.
AND YOU KNOW I KNEW REPORTED
SAYS WE SPEND ROUGHLY SIX
THOUSAND ENOUGH FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL PART DATES WHEN LASSEN
THAT FILLED A BIT MORE.
BUT THINK HOW MANY.
LET'S LET'S JUST SAY AVERAGE
THAT SIX THOUSAND LET LET'S SAY
WE WANT TO GO OUT.
TO THE NATIONAL AVERAGE COST OF
TEN DOLLARS OR SHOULD BE.
YET YACHTS THATTWENTY FIVE KIDS
IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
IN IN LA COUNTY SO SO THINK OF
IT THAT WAY.
YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
PICKING UP ON THAT CONCEPT TO
THE MEMBERS WHO APPROACHED IT I
MEAN I JUST KNOW ANECDOTALLY TO
HAVE HAVING RECENTLY SERVED ON A
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD.
THERE ARE DEFINITELY SAVINGS TO
BE GARNERED IN THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM WITH WHAT WE DON'T END UP
SPENDING ON RESOURCE SPECIALIST
IN READING AND MATHEMATICS AND
IN SPEECH PATHOLOGY BECAUSE
WE'VE DONE THAT WORK AT THE PRE
SCHOOL LEVEL --
IT WHEN WE HAVE A GOOD
COMPREHENSIVE A PRESCHOOL
AVAILABLE DOCTOR FREE I
PARTICULARLY --
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AROUND
HAVING STANDARDS BASED
CURRICULUM AND AS WELL AS
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN'S I'D NOT
THAT THIS REALLY FOR US IS ABOUT
ELIMINATING.
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND FOR I
THINK TO CONFLATED THE CONCEPT
OF CHILD CARE WHICH IS NOBLE AND
WORTHY IN ITS OWN RIGHT AND
HAVING I'M PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN A CHILD
CARE SETTING THAT IS SAFE FOR
THEM BUT WE'RE GONNA ACHIEVE
THIS NEXT LEVEL --
OF EQUITY AND OF SUCCESS IN A
UNIVERSAL --
A PRE K. ENVIRONMENT IT REALLY
DOES NEED TO BE STANDARDS --
BASED AND AND FOCUSED ON ON
ELIMINATING THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP
AND IT A BIG PIECE OF THAT
REALLY THEN DOES GO TO THE
QUALITY OF INSTRUCTION THAT'S
OFFERED IN THE CLASSROOM THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND AT YOU KNOW I BY
BIG THE COMMITTEES PARDON THAT
THIS SOUNDS A BIT.
OF A HUMBLE BRAG BUT I HAVE A
DAUGHTER WHO'S A LIBERAL STUDIES
MAJOR TEST YES YOU --
DURING HER TIME THERE SHE IS IN
A PRESCHOOL CLASSROOM AND THE ON
SITE CHILD DEVELOPMENT CENTER
LOVES THE WORK WOULD ABSOLUTELY
LOVE TO STAY IN PRESCHOOL
TEACHING.
SHE'S PURSUING A LIBERAL STUDIES
DEGREE WITH A SPECIALIZATION IN
MATHEMATICS AND A MINOR IN
CULTURAL PROFICIENCY SHE WOULD
BE AN IDEAL TEACHER TO BE IN
THIS KIND OF ENVIRONMENT BUT SHE
KNOWS SHE CAN'T AFFORD TO
SUPPORT HERSELF ON A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER SALARY.
SO HOW DO WE CONTINUE --
TO EMPOWER THIS WORK FORCE IN
CALIFORNIA IN OTHER CREATIVE
WAYS AND I'M SPECIFICALLY MY
QUESTION IS THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND THE
SPEAKERS BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION.
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
REQUIRING INCREASED COMPETENCIES
FOR THE EARLY EDUCATION TEACHER
WORK FORCE MEANING THAT WE FOCUS
MORE ON HOW CONCEPTS ARE APPLIED
TO IMPROVE TEACHING INSTEAD OF
JUST FOCUSING ON THE UNITS TAKEN --
HAS THIS BEEN DONE IN OTHER
STATES ARE THEIR SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS THAT DON'T REQUIRE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE BUT HAVE HIGH
QUALITY BENCHMARKS AND OUTCOMES.
SO.
I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY OTHER
STATES THAT USE A COMPETENCY
BASED --
SYSTEM THAT WE LOOK FIRST ABOUT
THE SYSTEM IN NEW JERSEY.
I AN ULTIMATE AND I KNOW THAT A
COUPLE OF OTHER STATES DID AS
WELL WE WE CAME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT IT WOULD COST AS
MUCH AND BE SUCH A CUMBERSOME
BUREAUCRACY.
THAT IT IT JUST WASN'T.
AT WHICH IT WE ARE.
ALSO WANTED THIS TO BE SEEN AS
IT BECAUSE IT WAS PUBLIC
EDUCATION --
AND SO WHY SHOULD THE STANDARDS
AND AND MAKE IT DOESN'T SPEAK
DIFFERENT THE DIFFERENT SHOULD
BE THAT THE TEACHERS ARE
PREPARED FOR THIS AGE LEVEL.
AND FOR TEACHING WELL IN THE
SENSE LEVEL BUT WE WE REALLY WE
WE STRUGGLE WITH THAT I WILL SAY
THERE ARE OTHER PLATE PLACES
TRYING TO COME UP WITH THAT --
PHILADELPHIA RIGHT NOW IS
LOOKING AT THIS FOR THEIR CITY
FUNDED PRESCHOOL PROGRAM --
AND I AND I KNOW THAT SEATTLE M.
IS LOOKING AT AN APPLIED VA --
WHICH WOULD DOES NOT COME WITH
THE CERTIFICATION --
BUT I HAVE NOT I DON'T KNOW THAT
I NONE OF THEM HAVE ANY.
BENEFITS TO SHOW FROM IT YET
BECAUSE THEY THEY HAVEN'T EVEN
BEEN DONE THEY'RE JUST
CONSIDERING IN AND AND I THINK
IT'S IT'S A IT'S I I CERTAINLY
THINK THAT IT THAT HAVING I I
NEGLECTED TO TELL YOU THAT WE WE
TOOK SIX YEARS TO GET THERE.
THAT I NEGLECTED.
SORRY IT WAS IN MY NOTES.
BUT THE THE COURT ALLOWED.
A FOUR YEAR WINDOW.
FORGET THE CURRENT WORK FORCE TO
GET THEIR DEGREE --
DURING THAT TIME THEIR THEIR
SALARIES NOT IN ANY KIND OF
REGULATED WAY BUT WERE AND
IMPROVED.
BUT THEY COULDN'T GET THE FULL
SALARY TILL THEY GOT THE FULL
QUALIFICATION.
F. THREE YEARS AND WE SAW
TEACHERS WERE WORKING HARD
TOWARD THIS BUT WEREN'T GOING TO
GET IT AND AND AND FOR YEARS SO
WE WENT BACK TO THE COURT THE
STATE.
WENT WITH THE PLAINTIFFS TO THE
COURT WHICH WAS THE ONLY TIME AN
EVENT THAT HAPPENED AND TWICE --
AND ASK THE COURT TO ALLOW US TO
MORE YEARS SO THE TEACHERS WHO
ARE MAKING GOOD PROGRESS AT THE
THREE YEAR MARK WERE BY THEN IT
WAS NOW THE FOR YOUR MARK --
AT HAD TWO MORE YEARS TO
COMPLETE THEIR DEGREES I THINK
TAKING.
TIME IS IMPORTANT --
BUT BUT HAVE INCENTIVES BUILT IN
ALONG THE WAY.
IT THAT THAT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN A NUMBER OF STATES.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THEM
RESPECT.
A GOOD STRATEGY THANK YOU.
DOCTOR PRETTY --
I'M LOOKING AT YOUR SLIDE NUMBER
[inaudible]
FIVE AND THE ONE THAT HAS WAY
TOO MANY GRASSROOTS WELL.
I AM.
NOT NOT TOO BAD BUT I I
ESPECIALLY I'M INTERESTED IN --
THE REDUCTION IN THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS --
FROM THE INVESTMENT IN IN
PRESCHOOL ARE THIS 5% DROP.
IN SPECIAL AS A SAID IN MY
READING THAT GRAPH RIGHT THAT
IT'S A 5% DROP IN --
IN A SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS NOT
COST PLACE.
PLACEMENT OKAY YES SIR SO --
CHILDREN WHO DID NOT ATTEND
ABBOTT PRE K. WERE 17% OF THEM
WERE.
WERE PLACED IN SPECIAL EDUCATION.
M. AS OPPOSED 212% OF CHILDREN
WHO DID ATTEND.
AT THAT PRICE TICKET PROGRAM DO
YOU KNOW LIKE --
AT THIS TIME.
WHAT THE PERCENTAGE?
OF COST SAVING ONCE BUT WE WERE
WE'RE TALKING THAT I IT IT IT
DEPENDS A LOT ON THE
CLASSIFICATION SO WE'D HAVE TO
EACH INDIVIDUAL CLASSIFICATION I
WE COULD DO A KIND OF GENERAL
ESTIMATE.
THAT I AM I'M SORRY I THAT'S NOT
MY FIELD AND I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE PER PEOPLE
COSTS ITS MISSION THAT IS ACROSS
THE BOARD.
THESE ARE PROBABLY THE CHILDREN
KNOW WHO --
HAD.
A MORE MINOR IF THE COST OF
THEIR SPECIAL EDUCATION WOULD
HAVE BEEN LESS EXPENSIVE THESE
ARE NOT PROFOUNDLY IMPAIRED AND
AT STUDENTS.
A AND AND AND SO THAT THE ONES
RIGHT ON THE ON THE EDGE OF
EITHER BEING PLACED IN SPECIAL
ED OR NOT AND WHERE THIS THEN
ENDED UP BEING AMELIORATIVE FOR
THEM AND THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
SAY.
YEAH I NINE SIR AG PROBABLY
FOCUSED ON AND THE MATERIAL THAT
I MISTER QUESTION --
YOU KNOW.
IT SEEMS THAT THE I AM HEARING I
A COMMON THEME THAT WE OFTEN
HEAR AN EDUCATION WHICH IS THAT
THE THE MOST IMPORTANT --
WAY TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
IN THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION IS
TO GET THE BEST TEACHERS IN THE
CLASSROOM.
AND AND YET WE IN --
IN AND CALIFORNIA AND I SUSPECT
THE NOW IN NEW JERSEY --
WILL YOU KNOW WE ARE FACING A
TEACHER SHORTAGE --
AND AND SO I YOU FOR SPECIFIED
SEVERAL TIMES IN YOUR
PRESENTATION THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING A YOU KNOW FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES COMPARABLE SALARIES
SCHOLARSHIP SIGNING BONUSES --
YEAH THIS IS A AND SO AMENABLE
ARE ARE ARE THOSE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO TO ATTRACTED
TEACHERS INTO THE THE THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION --
SPACE WELL I THINK.
I THINK IT'S A HARDER ISSUE
BECAUSE IT'S CERTAINLY NOT JUST
AT THIS HOUR IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
THE WORKING CONDITIONS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT.
THE IN OTHER WORDS THAT YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU HAVE HAVE SOME A TIME
TO BE IN YOUR IN YOUR WORK IN
YOU AND YOU AND ENJOY THE PP
WORK LESS THAN THAT YOU HAVE ALL
THAT SUPPORTS THAT YOU NEED YOU
THAT YOU GET --
PAID TIME OFF AND THAT ALL THOSE
THINGS ARE IMPORTANT AND THAT
YOU ARE GETTING GOOD
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
WHEN YOU HAVE A PROBLEM THERE'S
SOMEONE THERE WHO CAN HELP YOU
HELP SUPPORT YOU TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM --
DOES IT THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT
CONDITIONS THAT IN THAT SENSE OF
INITIALLY ATTRACTING I'M I'M NOT
THAT'S MAJOR AREA OF EXPERTISE
BUT I WOULD SAY --
IF WE COULD GET A BETTER.
IF THE PUBLIC WE HAD A BETTER
PERCEPTION OF TEACHERS AND
TEACHING IN GENERAL LIKE THEY
DID WHEN I WAS COMING UP.
I MEAN THAT WAS A NOBLE
PROFESSION THAT WAS VERY WELL
RESPECTED AND I DON'T THINK IT
ISN'T AS MUCH ANYMORE AND I
DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU CAN SOLVE WITH
LEGISLATION --
BUT I SO YOUADD TO THAT THAT
IT'S THE POORLY PAID.
AND IT'S GONNA BE HARD TO TO
ATTRACT OKAY.
I WISH I COULD ANSWER THAT FOR
YOU KNOW I I I I AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY EVERYONE DOESN'T
WANT TO BE A PRESCHOOL TEACHER
AT IN.
SORRY MIGHT MY LAST QUESTION FOR
NOW IS --
YOU YOU HEARD DOUG --
MISTER DONALD STRODE OFF THE HIS
PRESENTATION BY TALKING ABOUT
HOW.
YOU KNOW WE WE WE LOVE PRE K.
BUT WE DO WANT TO SPEND OUR PROP
NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS ON IT --
AND IN AYE AYE AYE.
TO COMES OUT OF YOU KNOW A
MEASURE OF CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
FACING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE YOU KNOW IT'S BECOMING
INCREASINGLY --
A A A FACT THAT IS BEING FOCUSED
ON THAT CALIFORNIA DEPENDING ON
WHO YOU'RE TALKING TO IS FORTY
FIRST IN THE NATION IN PER PUPIL
SPENDING SO WHEN WE ARE READY.
YOU KNOW --
IN THE BOTTOM FIFTH IN THE
NATION IN PER PEOPLE SPENDING
AND AND AND AND YET WE RECOGNIZE
ALL THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT.
TO ABOUT PRE K. --
AND SO YOU KNOW I I KNOW.
IT'S OUR JOB TO TRY.
TO BALANCE ALL THE PRIORITIES
GIVEN THE THE THE LIMITED
DOLLARS BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS AS TO YOU KNOW HOW WE
ANY ADVICE ON AND HOW WE WE WE
CAN STRIKE THAT BALANCE I COULD
MAKE IT WORSE FOR YOU BY SAYING
THAT YOU REALLY SHOULD BE
WORKING ON THE WHOLE.
BIRTH TO FIVE SYSTEM AS WELL
THAT.
BUT I I I DON'T LIKE.
AND I KNOW YOU DON'T LIKE BEING
PUT IN THE POSITION OF A YOU
KNOW SOPHIE'S CHOICE FOR YOU
HAVE TO CHOOSE AMONG YOUR
CHILDREN.
AND AND I I SO I I CERTAINLY AM
AM SYMPATHETIC TO TO THE
POSITION --
AND I JUST I GUESS I WOULD GO
BACK -- TO
SOME WOMEN MCCARTY'S POINT ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL SAVINGS AND IS A
CHILDREN'S LIVES AND HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU MAKE THAT
CHOICE NOT TO INVEST IN THEM AND?
AND I YOU KNOW I CAN'T BEGIN I
HAVE NO EXPERTISE ON
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET OR HOW YOU
SPEND YOUR MONEY AND SO I I
CAN'T LIKE I I WOULDN'T BE OF
MUCH USE AND THERE IT'S NOT.
THERE'S NOT SOME SIMPLE ANSWER
IN TERMS OF YOU CAN MANUFACTURE
IT SOMEHOW IT'S IT IN NEW JERSEY
WE JUST TOOK IT OUT OF THE
BUDGET.
AND IT WAS YEAH.
WE WE ALSO WERE HAVING LOTS OF
TROUBLE.
I WISH I COULD.
HAVE I WISH I HAD THAT PRINTING
MACHINE FOR YOU.
WELL YOU KNOW THAT'S THE THE
THREE BILLION DOLLAR QUESTION
AND YOU KNOW WE SERVE ON THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE GATHER SO
WE'LL HAVE. TO TO ADDRESS THAT
AND I KNOW THE GOVERNOR HAS
TALKED ABOUT FULLY EMBRACING
THIS IN TRYING.
TO IDENTIFY NEW REVENUE SOURCES
FOR IT AND CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WE
WE THAT NEW REVENUE SOURCES PLUS
AS YOU SAID FOR OUR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS THAT.
YOU KNOW THESE PROGRAMS ARE K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS YOU KNOW T. K.
PROGRAMS ARE IN THE PUBLIC
FUNDED PROP NINETY EIGHT STATE
PRESCHOOL.
AND THE NOT ONLY A STATE
PRESCHOOL PART DAYS IS --
HIS PROP NINETY EIGHT SO.
IT IT'S IT'S THERE AND IT HAS A
BIG IMPACT ON SERVING OUR KIDS
AND OUR AND OUR FAMILIES TODAY --
BUT BUT YEAH THAT IS THE ISSUE
THAT -- WE
WANT ABOUT.
WE WENT ABOUT WE DON'T TO MAKE
THAT THAT CHOICE OF ONE OR I
DIDN'T WANT TO GET BACK TO TO
SPECIFIC ISSUES.
A KIND OF FOLLOW UP ON SOMEONE
MEMBERS MISS --
QUESTION ON THE ON THE WORK
FORCE SAID.
YEAH YOU KNOW --
PEOPLE WHO DO THIS WORK --
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T DO IT FOR
THE GREAT PAY YOU KNOW THEY CAN
GO WORK AT COSTCO LITERALLY AND
WAKE WAY MORE MONEY THAN.
THE NON LEE TEACHER FOR A STATE
PRESCHOOL EVEN A LEAD TEACHER
CAN SOMETIMES WORK IN RETAIL AND
WAKE -- MAKE
WAY MORE MONEY AS THEY DO IT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY CARE.
AND IT'S HARD --
TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GO TO THE
WORK FORCE.
AND EVEN GET A BA WHEN THEY'RE
SO FAR BELOW.
WHAT A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER
MAKES AND SO IF YOUR DAUGHTER
GOES AND GETS TO BE A BECOMES A
PRESCHOOL TEACHER?
AND YOU CAN MAKE YOU KNOW TWENTY
THOUSAND OR MORE --
TWICE AS OURS DOLLARS --
MORE BEING A KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER AND YOU LOOKING AT OUR
HOUSING COSTS IN CALIFORNIA
PAYING FOR YOUR YOUR OWN KIDS
PRESCHOOL.
YOU KNOW WHY WOULD WE DO THAT SO
I REALIZED.
IT'S WORKFORCE PREPARATION AND
ADEQUATE PAIN YOU KNOW WE'RE
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS THAT IN
OUR PROPOSAL NOT TALK ABOUT HERE
TODAY PER SE AND WE LEARNED THAT
FROM VISITING THESE COSTS AND
AND THE NEW JERSEY THINK.
I DO WANT TO ASK THEM SPECIFIC
THING ON THE CREDENTIALS PIECE
AND THE TRAINING BECAUSE I
REALIZE THAT EITHER QUALITY
ELEMENTS.
THAT IS KEY IS HAVING THAT.
THE ADEQUATELY TRAINED WORKFORCE
AND THE WHOLE ISSUE WOULD THAT
BE A AND SO FORTH --
I'M KIND OF AT A LOSS TO SORT OF
GET HELP ME WITH THIS BECAUSE I
CAN I CAN SEE HYPOTHETICAL OF A
OF AN INDIVIDUAL.
GETTING A BE A IN SOCIOLOGY.
AND REALLY NEVER TAKING A LOT OF
EARLY AD COURSES BUT YOU HAVE A
BA.
AND YOU CAN BE PERCENT AA THAT
GOES TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHO
GETS IN A WOULD LET'S SAY TWENTY
FOUR UNITS IN A SPECIALTY.
IN EARLY EDUCATION AND LET'S SAY
HALF OF THOSE UNITS.
ARE LIKE A PRACTICUM WHERE YOUR
YOU KNOW IN EXTERNSHIP YOUR IN.
A CLASSROOM AND SO THOSE TWO
PEOPLE IN YOUR EYES OR IN THE
EYES OF RESEARCHERS WHO HAS MORE
VALUE.
IN SERVING LITTLE THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS SOMEONE WHO HAS THE
FOUR YEAR DEGREE IN SOCIOLOGY
WITH MINIMAL.
PRE K. --
EDUCATION OF THE PERSON WHICH IS
THE TIME.
FOCUSING ON EARLY EDUCATION
ACADEMIA I CAN'T ANSWER THAT --
THE RESEARCH CAN ANSWER YEAH
WHAT WHAT WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
WOULD YOU THINK WELL.
WHERE WOULD YOU PUT YOUR MIND?
WHERE WOULD YOU PUT YOUR LITTLE
KIDS -- WELL
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT OTHER SUPPORT
TODAY ALL THINGS BEING EQUAL
OKAY TO TEACHERS TO CLASSROOMS
[inaudible]
SOMEONE FAIR.
THE BUT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WHAT
I RECOMMEND.
EITHER OF THAT THE I'M I'M
RECOMMENDING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
WITH CERTIFICATION SO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF THOSE TWO THINGS
NOT THE STATE'S DON'T HAVE.
THE BACHELORS WITH THE
CERTIFICATION --
WELL I DON'T KNOW THEN I WOULD I
WOULD DO AN EXPERIMENT YEAH HE
DID AN EXPERIMENT YEAH.
I BECAUSE I I THERE ISN'T THERE
ISN'T A RIGHT ANSWER TO THAT
YEAH I KNOW THAT HEAD START.
HAS HAS THAT AND THEY'RE FACING
SOME CHALLENGES IN IN IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE THAT THAT THE PAY
AND THEY LOSE OUR TEACHERS RIGHT
AWAY YOU'LL GET A BE A AND THEN
YOU HAVE. TWENTY GRAND THE
AVERAGE CSU STUDENT AS NORTH OF
TWENTY GRAND IN DEBT.
AND YOU GO BE A LEAD PRESCHOOL
TEACHER.
AND YOUR SALARY UNLESS SOMEONE
IS A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME
GETTING A TEACHING CREDIT YEAH
HE'S GOT ROCKET UP EVEN MORE I
WORK FOR FOUR YEARS FOR LARGE
HEAD START GRANT TO THAT.
OPERATED IN FOR STATE SO I KNOW
THAT.
SCENARIO REALLY WELL --
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE STATE PRE K.
PROGRAM DECIDED THEY WERE GOING
TO EXPAND SO THEY REDUCE THEIR
REQUIREMENTS AND I AT LEAST KNEW
THAT MIKE VALLEY WELL PREPARED
TEACHERS THAT I WOULD WORK SO
HARD WITH.
WERE MOVING.
WERE STILL TEACHING LITTLE KIDS --
WHEN THEY JUMP SHIP BUT --
I I I DON'T KNOW I WOULD LOVE TO
DO AN EXPERIMENT OF A HIGH
QUALITY A VERSES A HIGH QUALITY
BA NOT A HIGH QUALITY A PERSON'S
AND HE'LL BE I AM.
BUT BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WHAT WE WOULD GET FROM THAT --
AB AND I ALSO IT DEPENDS SO MUCH
ON THE OTHER SUPPORTS AROUND
THAT THE TEACHER BUT I I HAVE TO
TELL YOU I THINK THE RESEARCH
HAS UNIQUE BOTH A BA.
WITH CERTIFICATION [inaudible]
AND I I MEAN THAT'S ALL I CAN
WORK FROM AS WHAT THE RESEARCH
THAT AGAIN THAT'S WE LEARNED IT
IN NEW JERSEY AS I WAS REALLY
IMPRESSED.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE NEXT PANEL.
THAT IT WAS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
FOR A LOT.
OF WORK.
FOR GETTING THE HIGHER
CREDENTIAL AND THEN PAYING THEM
ADEQUATELY AND IT HELPS THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES --
BUT ALSO STATE BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT THE NEED TO JUMP TO GO.
OUT OF WORK IN A SCHOOL DISTRICT
OR A DIFFERENT INDUSTRY
ASSISTANT TEACHERS ALSO GOT
CORRECT.
SO I DO HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION
BUT I DO ALSO WANT TO WELCOME
SOMEONE MEMBER --
BONTA WHO'S THAT WHO'S NOT ON ON
THE COMMITTEE BUT JOINING US
TODAY IN A BIG CHAMPION OF OUR
PRE K. FOR ALL MOVEMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- MY
LAST QUESTION FOR YOU IS ON THE
THE THAT THE THE RATIO SENATE
AND THE BENCHMARKS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S PRETTY SAD THAT THEIR
THIRTY ONE OTHER STATES WHO.
WHO -- PART
GOING BEYOND WHERE WE'RE AT
TODAY AND YOU'RE TIED WITH THE
WHOLE MATCH.
TO SO AS FAR AS THE THETHAT
RATIOS FIRST IS THAT THAT THE
CLASS SIZE.
YOU KNOW IT IT'S ALL YOU KNOW
BASED UPON HOW MUCH RESOURCES WE
HAVE IN IS MISTER MARTZ ISSUE
SAID WE'RE TRYING TO SQUEEZE
MORE TO OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEMS.
AND FACILITIES I UNDERSTOOD
STILL IS ALL THAT EVEN IF YOU
HAD THE HIGHER CLASS SIZE AS
LONG AS YOU HAVE.
ADULT TO CHILD RATIO DOZEN THAT
DO THE TRICK BECAUSE YOU
EXPLODED LAST UP IN.
REMOTE ADDRESS.
THEIR NATION ABOUT THE QUALIFY
TEACHER.
HOW MANY QUALIFIED TEACHERS HE
AND I HAVE IN THAT YEAH AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S MY CONCERN --
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF DATA ON A
LOW RATIO WITH A WITH A HIGH
CLASS SIZE SO I I DON'T I CAN'T
SAY FOR SURE BUT IT'S PRETTY
HARD YOU'RE YOU'RE STILL
DELUDING THAT THE HIGHEST
QUALIFIED YET EACH YEAR THE
AMONG TEACHER WITH YOUR CHILD IS
THE SECOND.
OR TEACHER WOULD HAVE.
ALSO STRESS THAT COMES FROM NOT
NOT JUST FOR THE TEACHERS.
BUT STRESS FOR THE CHILDREN THAT
COMES FROM BEING IN SUCH LARGE
GROUPS --
AND I I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THINGS WE DON'T KNOW I'M JUST
NOW I'M DOING MY I'M DEVELOPMENT
PSYCHOLOGIST SO IT'S NOT
ARMCHAIR PSYCHOLOGY I'M ACTUALLY
AM A PSYCHOLOGIST.
BUT I I I SO I DON'T HAVE DATA
TO SAY THAT.
THE LARGER THE CLASSES THE MORE
STRESSFUL IT IS BUT IT CERTAINLY.
IS A REASONABLE TERM AND NOT
THAT I'M SANCTIONING THIS BUT
THE T. K. RATIOS ARE JUST
ATROCIOUS AND I CAN IMAGINE.
THAT TOO K. TEACHER WITH TWENTY
FIVE DON'T HAVE. EIGHT TWELVE
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND
SO WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE THE
FACT THAT WE'VE HAD WE HAVE HAD
SUCCESS WITH OUR T. K.
IMPLANTATION AND I LOOK NEAR.
GET A RESEARCHER A ARE WHEN THE
GROUP DID A STUDY RECENTLY AND
THEY SHOWED.
GREAT GAINES AND THOSE CLASSES
HAVE THESE CRAZY TEACHER STUDENT
RATIO SO HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
SORT THAT OUT.
I DON'T KNOW --
I I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S JUST THAT
THEY ARE SUCH A RESTRICTED AGE
RANGE THAT THAT OLDER FORCE YEAH
THAT THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE --
LA AND I'D LIKE TO SEE IF IT HOW
IT HOW IT IMPACTS IN THE LONG
RUN -- NTK
ISN'T AS IT'S NOT INCOME AND
THERE'S NO INCOME ELIGIBILITY
THERE EITHER AND I THINK I THINK
I WOULD SAY THAT I I DO BELIEVE.
FIVE AND AGAIN AT PLEASE WHEN I
SAID I BELIEVE IT MEANS THAT I'M
BEING RESEARCH INFORMED ABOUT
NOT RESEARCH BASED --
THAT -- THAT --
THE THE LESS CONCENTRATION OF OF
POVERTY THAT YOU HAVE IN THE
CLASSROOM [inaudible]
IN OTHER.
POTENTIAL --
CHARACTERISTICS THAT CAN MAKE
THE FIVE HARDER FOR CHILDREN --
THE LARGER THE CLASS I SCAN.
SO IN NEW JERSEY FOR EXAMPLE OUR
CLASSES IS QUITE LOW IT'S
FIFTEEN WHICH AT THE TIME WAS
THE BEST EVIDENCE THE BEST
EVIDENCE WE HAD SAID THAT IT
SHOULD BE FIFTEEN IN A ONE TO AS
SEVEN OR EIGHT RATIO BUT WE'RE
EXPANDING. TO THESE LESS HIGH
CONCENTRATED POVERTY DISTRICTS
WITH.
FIFTEEN SHOULD WE BE
EXPERIMENTING TO SEE IF EIGHTEEN
WHICH WOULD BE OKAY AND SAVE
SOME MONEY THAT WAY AND BE ABLE
TO EXPAND MASTER.
AGAIN I WOULD SAY EXPERIMENT
FIND OUT RATHER THAN JUST DO IT
AND THEN FIND OUT.
AND I DON'T WANT CHILDREN TO
LOSE ANOTHER YEAR AND FALL WE
AND WE'RE NOT SURE ABOUT.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL.
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANKS HOW YOUR RELATIONS WITH
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY PANEL NUMBER FOUR IS --
UNITY BASED UPON KEY TO IT KEY
TAKE AWAYS FROM OUR RECENT TRIP
TO THE EAST COAST NEW YORK
BOSTON AND NEW JERSEY TO LEARN
ABOUT CREE QUE FOR ALL
UNIVERSITY QUE PROGRAMS. THREE
HAVE ERIN GABLE FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA FIRST AND THEN
CERTAIN OF A MORGAN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AARON GABLE
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA AND I WAS.
SO HONORED TO BE A PART OF THE
PRESCHOOL DELEGATION TO THE EAST
COAST AND TO SHARE MY AHA
MOMENTS WITH YOU.
TODAY -- YOU
HAVE HEARD AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT
AROUND ACCESS RATES AND QUALITY
FOR OVER A DECADE FROM ADVOCATES
LIKE MYSELF.
IN THIS HEARING IN THE TRIP WAS
ABOUT GOING DEEPER.
ARE NOT JUST RESOURCES BUT
STRATEGIC UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
QUALITY PROGRAMS THAT WOULD MOVE
THE NEEDLE FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ALIKE.
AND THAT IS THE JOURNEY THAT'S
IN FRONT OF CALIFORNIA OPPOSED
TO THE JOURNEY THAT HAS BEEN
BEHIND US WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
EXCITING.
SO TO QUOTE OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT WE ARE CALIFORNIA.
SO WE HAVE OUR OWN CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL VISION --
ARE TWIN VISION TO SERVE WORKING
FAMILIES AND CHILD DEVELOPMENT
HAS NOT YET BEEN FULLY ACHIEVED
BY OTHER STATES AND THAT WAS MY
FIRST AHA MOMENT.
WE HAVE A LOT TO LEARN FROM
OTHER HIGH PERFORMING STATES BUT
SOME OF THIS ROAD WILL BE
UNIQUELY CARVE BY CALIFORNIA'S
VALUES AND IT WILL SET A NEW
GOAL LINE FOR THE COUNTRY WHICH
IS VERY EXCITING.
AHA MOMENT NUMBER TWO WAS --
DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT BY
PREVIOUS PANELISTS AND BY THE
MEMBERS THAT'S THE CRUCIAL
CONTEXT OF RESOURCES AND
ARTICULATION.
WE WERE NOT JUST SEEN HIGH
QUALITY WELL RESOURCE TO PRE K.
PROGRAMS LIVING IN ISOLATION WE
WERE SEEING PRE K. PROGRAMS
NESTED IN HIGH QUALITY.
WELL RESOURCE K. TWELVE SYSTEMS.
HIGH PERFORMING STATES ARE NOT
HAVING A SHOULD WE FIND PRE K.
AT THE EXPENSE OF K. TWELVE
DEBATES.
THEY'RE RAISING ALL BOATS. ONE
YEAR STRATEGIC INVESTMENT IN
CHILDREN OR CANNOT BE CONSIDERED
A SILVER BULLET FOR THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IT'S PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO BEING
THE FORTY FIRST NATION IN PER
PUPIL SPENDING.
COMPARED TO SECOND SEVENTH AND
EIGHTH IN THE NATION WHICH IS
WHAT WE WERE SAYING ON THE EAST
COAST.
AND THIS ARTICULATION AT THAT WE
SAW HAD RESPECT FOR COMMUNITY
BASED MIX DELIVERY CHILD
DEVELOPMENT BASED APPROACHES
WASN'T ABOUT PUSHING KATE TWELVE
DOWN.
INTO WHAT WORKS FOR CHILDREN BUT
BEING RESPECTFUL WHAT HAS BEEN
SEEN FOR GENERATIONS THAT WORKS
FOR CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
WE SAW PRE K. PROGRAMS
ARTICULATED IN TWO K. TWELVE FOR
TEACHER PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT
ASSESSMENTS AND CURRICULUM.
TEACHERS IN THESE PROGRAMS ARE
SUPPORTED THROUGH THOUGHTFUL PRE
SERVICE PROGRAMS AND SYSTEMS AND
HIGHER EDUCATION.
EXPERT COACHING BASED ON
OBSERVATION TOOLS GREAT
CURRICULUM AND REAL TIME DATA
AND YOU'LL HEAR MORE FROM MY
EXPERT COLLEAGUE FROM CD ABOUT
THESE FRIENDS.
AND SPEAKING OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION MY THIRD
ALL HOT TAKE AWAY WITH HUMAN
CAPACITY AND WELL AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
THIS IS COMPLEX IMPLEMENTATION
WORK AND REQUIRES HIGH LEVEL
ROBUST SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
WE HAVE START OUR STATE LEVEL
SYSTEMS FOR DECADES AND WE HAVE
TO BUILD.
AND THE MY LAST ALL HOT THAT I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU BECAUSE THEY
WILL SEE THE TABLE TO MISS NEVER
MORGAN WHO I WILL AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING SHE SAYS.
WE DIVIDED LABOR --
IS SYSTEMS CAPACITY FOR DECADES
CALIFORNIA HAS STRONG TOGETHER
LITTLE CRUMBS OF EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS AROUND INSTRUCTIONAL
SUPPORT FOR TEACHERS IT MAKES ME
THINK OF THE PRESCHOOL TEACHERS
FOR LOOPBACK LESS.
YOU KNOW AND SO RATHER THAN HAVE
A COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM OF
INSTRUCTIONAL SUPPORT THAT WE
SEE IN HIGH PERFORMING
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONAL
CLASSROOMS.
AND OTHER COMMUNITY SETTINGS
INSTEAD OUR TEACHERS HAVE IS FOR
THE BACK OFFICE.
AND SO THAT NECKLACE HAS TO BE
REPLACED WITH SYSTEMS CAPACITY
HIGHER EDUCATION CAPACITY
MENTORING CAPACITY AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SYSTEMS
AND STARTING WITH JOB IN BED ITS
SUPPORT FOR ALL TYPES OF
SETTINGS.
SO THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THEY'RE
DOING AT NIGHT THIS IS SOMETHING
THEY'RE DOING ITS PART OF THEIR
JOB [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU AND
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IF
THEY'RE NOT A MORGAN WITH THE
EARLY LEARNING CARE DIVISION.
IN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND SO
AS YOU HEARD FROM SUPERINTENDENT
THEY'RE MEANT HE REALLY SEES
EARLY LEARNING AS PART OF THE
EDUCATIONAL CONTINUUM.
AND AS CORPS TO ADDRESSING ALL
OF THE OPPORTUNITY GAPS THAT CAN
HELP PREVENT THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
WE KNOW THAT DECADES OF RESEARCH
HAVE STAND THAT SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN THE EARLY YEARS
OF A CHILD'S LIFE HAVE AN
ENORMOUS POSITIVE IMPACT ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM OF OUTCOMES.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN MAKING
POSITIVE STEPS TOWARDS EXPANDING
ACCESS TO QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
CARE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE SAVA
PASSED SEVERAL YEARS.
AND WE THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON NOT AND WERE ALSO
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO HAVE A
GOVERNOR WHO IS NOW JUMPING AND
FULLY.
INTO THAT AS WELL AS A
SUPERINTENDENT.
AS WE CONTEMPLATE EXPANDING
PRESCHOOL AND DEVELOPING A
BLUEPRINT FOR SYSTEM EXPANSION
TOWARDS MOVING FORWARD THERE WAS
A LOT TO LEARN FROM FROM OTHER
STATES.
BUT I THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE
THAT CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS A LOT
TO SHARE AND A LOT OF ASSETS
THAT ARE MORE UNIQUE TO ASK.
ON THE TOUR ITSELF AND WE WERE
REAL MAKE THIS HAPPEN SAID EARLY
ADS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS REALLY BROUGHT TOGETHER
SOMETHING THAT HELPED US SEE.
AND LEARN FROM OTHER STATES.
IT GIVES A LOT OF FOOD FOR
THOUGHT SO AS WE LOOK AT
LEVERAGING QUALITY AND
ADDRESSING OUTCOMES THERE WERE
SOME REALLY CORE COMPONENTS THAT
WERE IN ALL THREE OF THE SYSTEMS
WE LOOKED AT SO IN NEW JERSEY
AND BOSTON AND NEW YORK.
THEY LOOKED IT EXPANDED ACCESS
THEY AT THE HIGHER TEACHER PAY
WITH PROGRAM REIMBURSEMENT RATES
AND JUST A QUICK NOTE THAT WHEN
WE LOOK AT A CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND WE LOOK AT
OUR STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
IT IS LOWER THAN THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE AND MANY OF OUR
COUNTIES AND IS ACTUALLY LOWER
THAN THAT FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE
AN IN SAM COUNTIES THE LICENSE
EXEMPT RATE IS THE SAME.
AS OUR STATE PRESCHOOL RIGHT.
AT THERE ARE ALSO AMPLE TEACHER
EDUCATION AND TRAINING SUPPORT
SERVICES AS WELL AS LOOKING AT
FACILITIES AND REALLY CRAFTING
PROGRAMS THAT FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN WOULD WANT TO GO INTO.
SEVERAL ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM'S
PARTICULARLY STOOD OUT TO US ON
NOT.
INTENTIONAL INTEGRATION WE WERE
SO IMPRESSED WITH HOW THE IT
INTEGRATED ALL COMPONENTS TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN WERE SERVED
AND THE HIGHEST QUALITY SETTINGS
POSSIBLE.
AND THAT TRANSITIONS TO
KINDERGARTEN WERE OPTIMIZED AS
WE LOOKED ACROSS SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS THE USE OF CURRICULUM
FLOWED FROM THE EARLY PRESCHOOL
TO THE OLDER PRIEST CALL AND
THEN UP INTO THE KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS.
WITH REALLY WESTING LESS.
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COACHING
AND SUPPORT SUPPORT SUPPORT
SYSTEMS FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
THE EXPANSION OF PRESCHOOL IN
EACH OF THESE SYSTEMIC OUT OF
THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM.
HAVING ROBUST COACHING SYSTEMS
AND OTHER PIECES TO ENSURE THAT
THE HIGH QUALITY WAS THERE.
AND DOCTOR FREEDIA.
JUST SHARED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
PHASING IN THAT BACHELOR'S
DEGREE PROGRAM AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY THAT CHAIR
MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THAT
ACTUALLY I THINK MOVED US ALL.
WHEN WE HEARD THAT WITH IN NEW
JERSEY AND WITH IN A VERY LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY?
THAT DE AND RAISING UP A
BACHELOR'S DEGREES AFFECTED
MULTI GENERATIONS SO NOT ONLY
DID IT SUPPORT THE QUALITY OF
THE TEACHING.
BUT IT ALSO CREATED ADDITIONAL
RESPECT FOR THE PRE SCHOOL
TEACHERS IN THE COMMUNITY.
IT INCREASE THEIR SENSE OF SELF
WORTH AND VALIDATION AND THE
CHILDREN THEIR CHILDREN ENDED UP
GOING ON TO ALSO GET DEGREES SO
THAT WAS THE MULTI GENERAL.
GENERATIONAL A FAX SO HELPING
THE CHILDREN IN THE PROGRAM BUT
ALSO HELPING THOSE FAMILIES IN
THE WORK FORCE AT THE SAME TIME.
AND JUST A PIECE AROUND PAY
PARITY THERE THEY STARTED OUT
INITIALLY WITH PAY PARITY BUT
LOST SOME OF THAT OVER TIME AND
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT CREATING
SUPPORTS THAT KEEP ADDRESSING
SOME OF THOSE PAY PARITY ISSUES
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
WELL WE MAY NOT BE FULLY READY
TO RID OF REQUIRE BA DEGREES FOR
PRESCHOOL TEACHERS THERE'S A LOT
AROUND NOT TO THINK OF AROUND
FOR EXPANDING ACCESS IN
IMPROVING QUALITY.
AND IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT.
HAD A LOT OF AROUND THEM SO AS
WE LOOK AT THE SUPPORT SYSTEMS
AND CREATING EFFICIENCIES.
IT'S NOT JUST INCREASING HIGHER
AD WHICH IS COR BUT IT'S ALSO
ENSURING THAT THEIR SUPPORT'S
FOR THE WORK FORCE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
IN GOING BACK TO SCHOOL AND
GETTING THEIR DEGREES SAID
THINGS LIKE COHORTS HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN CALIFORNIA THE
PAST WHERE YOU WOULD HAVE GROUPS
OF TEACHERS EVEN FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS.
GO THROUGH TOGETHER TO GET A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE WE ALSO HAD
GENERAL EDUCATION COURSES SO
THOSE MATH AND ENGLISH COURSES
THAT TEND TO BE SORT OF THE
STICKING POINT FOR A LOT OF OUR
WORK FORCE.
TIED IN LINKED TO CHILD
DEVELOPMENT COURSE AS WITH OTHER
SUPPORT SO THAT PEOPLE COULD
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE AND MAKE IT
THROUGH THEM.
AND THEN PROVIDING COACHES TO
TEACHERS THAT'S REALLY
INTEGRATED WITH AN A
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM STRESSING IN
EMPHASIZING THE QUALITY SUPPORTS
FOR THAT.
AND THE LAST PART AND THAT IS
THE DRESSING EQUITY WE HAVE TO
ENSURE.
THAT WE'RE BUILDING CAPACITY
ACROSS THE CONTINUUM OF SETTINGS
AND SO THE MIX DELIVERY IS THERE
BUT ALSO ACROSS OUR STATE WE
KNOW THAT OVER THE YEARS SOME
AREAS OF OUR STATE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD MORE WITH
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS.
THAN OTHER AREAS OF OUR STATE
AND SO ADDITIONAL ENHANCE
SUPPORTS WE NEED TO HAPPEN TO
REALLY REYES APP AND SUPPORT THE
SECTORS THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND.
MOVING ON FROM THE HERITAGE AND
SUPPORT WOULD BE CURRICULUM AND
MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED IT
BRIEFLY AND IT WAS REALLY
TRANSFORMATIVE TO ALL OF US TO
SEE.
HOW DEEP AN INTENTIONAL THEY'RE
FOCUSED ON CURRICULUM AND
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THE WORK FORCE ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF CURRICULUM WAS
A PIECE OF THAT?
AND HOW THEY PHASED OUT OVER
TIME SAID THAT IS YOU'VE GOT
TEACHERS HAD BEEN IN THE PROGRAM
MORE THEY NEEDED LESS AND LESS
SUPPORT LESS AND LESS FIDELITY
TO THE CURRICULUM BECAUSE THEY
HAD MORE TOOLS IN THERE TOO
ABOUT.
BUT NEW TEACHERS NEED A LOT MORE
SUPPORT AROUND THAT.
AND THEN MOVING BACK INTO THE
MIX TO LIVE WE SAW IN THE OTHER
STATES WAS THAT THEY HAD
DIFFERENT BLANKS AND FOR
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS.
THAT WAS REALLY FASCINATING TO
SEE WHERE SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL
BASED PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS CAME
MEN VERSES THE COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAM AND ENSURING THAT IN ALL
COMMUNITIES BOTH WERE THERE.
KNOWING THAT WE DO HAVE WORKING
FAMILIES AND SO A SIX HOUR
PROGRAM IS NOT --
ACCESSIBLE TO SOME OF OUR
FAMILIES WHO CANNOT LEAVE WORK
SAID THE COMMUNITY MADE SURE
THAT BOTH WERE AVAILABLE FOR
FAMILIES.
AND THEN THE REAL TIME DATA THE
DATA NEEDS TO BE BOTH AT THE
STATE LEVEL SO THAT WE CAN SAY
MORE ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING SO
WE CAN ADDRESS NEEDED INVESTMENT
CHANGES AND LOOK AT EQUITY IN
WHERE THE FUNDS ARE GOING ACROSS
THE STATE.
BUT ALSO WITHIN EACH PROGRAM
SAID THE TEACHERS THEMSELVES
HAVE THAT AND CAN READ THE
REFINED THE CURRICULUM IN THEIR
SUPPORTS FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL
CHILD.
SO AS WE START TACKLING THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE CONTINUUM WE KNOW WE
HAVE TO ALSO IN DRESS AND MOVE
FORWARD INFANT TODDLER.
AND NOT LOOKING AT INFANTILE
THERE WITH MOVING PRESCHOOL ARE
COMBINED AND I THINK A
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN SAD WE
WANT TO BE COMPETITIVE IN THIS I
THINK WE ALL LEFT GOING OKAY WE
CAN DO IT.
WE'RE GONNA GET THERE WERE
ALREADY PART WAY THERE BUT WE
WILL ACTUALLY AND MOVE FORWARD
SO THAT OTHER STATES COME TO
PASS TO VISIT OUR PROGRAMS.
AND I THINK OUR POTENTIAL IN
THAT LEADERSHIP IS REALLY
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE MIX
DELIVERY THAT WE'RE MOVING FOR A
STRONG PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND
ALSO SUPPORTING INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
THAT WERE INSURING THAT DO A
LANGUAGE LEARNERS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ASSETS IS FULLY
INTEGRATED WITH A BILINGUAL
PROGRAM AND SUPPORTING CAPACITY
BUILDING AROUND THAT.
AND LASTLY ENSURING THAT ALL
CHILDREN CAN PARTICIPATE SAID
THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE FULL
INCLUSION AND REALLY SUPPORT
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES.
SAID THAT THE CLASSROOMS AND
PROGRAMS ARE FOR EVERYONE.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
PRESENTATION I I WANTED TO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
BERMAN -- TO
THE HEARING TODAY NOT ON THE BUT
A BIG SUPPORTER OF ECT AND FIRST
RAN FOR OFFICE SO AS TO MAKE
SURE WE STEP IT UP IN CALIFORNIA
SO THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
SEVEN YES I WANTED TO ASK YOU.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS OF YOU IN
THESE THIS WILL ALSO BE FOR THE
FOR THE NEXT PANEL AS WELL.
SO FOR ALL THE TALK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA AT STEPPINGUP AND
BEING A PRE K. FOR ALL STATE.
I THINK FOR SOMEONE PERSON
WATCHING CASUALLY FROM THE
SIDELINES YOU THINK WE DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING HERE BUT WE WE
ALREADY DO WE HAVE OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM WHICH SERVES.
YOU KNOW HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE APPROXIMATE THAT KIDS THREE
AND THREE AND FOUR ALONE CAN
KIDS AND SO.
WE DON'T WE'RE NOT REINVENTING
THE WHEEL AND WHERE WE WOULD BE
BUILDING UPON THAT IF WE STEPPED
UP SOME LIKE SOME OF THESE OTHER
STATES THAT.
MEASURE MEDICALLY EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY SO MY QUESTIONS FOR
YOU.
TO ARE RELATED TO YOUR OUR TRIP
AND WHAT WE HAVE HERE WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE THE THAT LOGISTICAL
LESSONS LEARNED AND THE BARRIERS
IT'S WE COULD APPLY IF WE YOU
KNOW IT NEW JERSEY THAT THOSE A
SIX YEAR --
ROLLOUT.
IS TALKING ABOUT A THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLD LIST LET'S SAY WAS
A FIVE YEAR IMPLEMENTATION WHAT
WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT.
WERE THE AHA THINGS THAT WE THEY
THAT REALLY WHAT WE CAN
REALISTICALLY DO GOING FORWARD.
ABSOLUTELY SO --
I I DON'T THINK IT'S AS IF
SURPRISED ANYBODY THERE'S A
NUMBER OF BILLS MOVING TO THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
IN RESPONSE NOT ONLY TO WHAT WE
SAW ON THE EAST COAST.
BUT ALSO MANY THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY IS BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION HAS BEEN TACKLING
OVER THIS PAST YEAR THAT IS
INSPIRED VERY COMPREHENSIVE
THINKING.
ABOUT ALL THE DRIVERS OF OUR
CURRENT PRE CASE SYSTEM AND HOW
IT ARTICULATES THERE ARE ZERO
THROUGH AGE TWELVE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM.
AND NUMBER ONE IS THE ADEQUATE
PER CHILD FUNDING ISSUE THE IDEA
THAT WE HAVE IN AT INADEQUATE
FUNDING TO EVEN MEET THE
STANDARDS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
IS AN UNDERLYING CHALLENGES IT
DRIVES COMPENSATION FOR OUR WORK
FORCE AND IT DRIVES THE QUALITY
OF THE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT THAT
THE CHILDREN ARE IN PERIOD.
AND SO UNTIL WE CAN TACKLE THAT
PIECE -- YOU
THAT THERE IS IT'S IT'S I WOULD
SAY THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE FIRST
SEQUENCE STEP WE NEED TO TAKE --
AND THEN YOU ALSO SEE OTHER
IMPORTANT LEVERS THAT
ARTICULATED IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET THAT WE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON TOGETHER
THIS YEAR. TO THINK ABOUT THE
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE YOU NEED
TO BUILD THE NEW CLASSROOMS THAT
YOU NEED IN A MIXED DELIVERY.
SYSTEM TO LOOK AT THE SUPPORT
CURRENTLY IN PLACE AND THEN
EXPAND --
WHEN WE ALREADY HAVE AN IMPACTED
TEACHER PIPELINE ACROSS K.
TWELVE THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER BY MEMBERS --
SO HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT THE PRE
SERVICE PIPELINE THAT MAKES
SENSE IN A SHORT TERM.
AND LONG TERM AND THEN HOW DO WE
BUILD OUT ON GOING CONTINUOUS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AS PART
OF THE PROFESSION.
QUITE A BIT OF WORK IT'S BEEN
DONE IN THAT AREA IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE A LOT MORE TO DO IN
TERMS OF BUILDING CAPACITY --
AND THEN OF COURSE LAST BUT NOT
LEAST IT'S IT'S THE THE ISSUE OF
ACCESS IS NOT A UNIVERSAL ISSUE
ACROSS THE STATE BECAUSE AS THE
CHAIRMAN SAYS WE HAVE BEEN
GETTING STEADILY SO MUCH CLOSER
TO UNIVERSAL.
ACCESS FOR SOME TYPES OF
PROGRAMS --
FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS.
A LOT OF KIDS HAVE ACCESS TO
PARTY PROGRAMS THAT MAY NOT BE
MEETING THEIR WORKING FAMILIES
NEEDS WE HAVE TO GET OUR ARMS
AROUND THAT AND NOT ASSUME THAT
APART DAY SLOT.
MEANS BOTH THE WORKING FAMILIES
NEED AND THE CHILD'S NEEDS ARE
BEING MET --
WE HAVE AREAS WHERE WE HAVE
GREAT CHALLENGES TO EXPANDING
FULL DAY FULL YEAR OR TWO K. AND
EXPANDED TO KEEP PROGRAMS THOSE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED SO WE CAN THINK ABOUT.
THE TWIN MISSION OF CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRAMS.
I'M JUST GOING OUT A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE ERIN CAPTURE THAT SO
WELL BUT IN AS WE LOOK ABOUT AT
THAT CAPACITY I THINK.
I'M TRANSFORMING SOME OF OUR
HIGHER END COMPONENTS AND
PROVIDING SUPPORTS FOR THEM SO
THAT MORE OF THE COURSES ARE
PRACTICE BASED SAID THERE REALLY
TAKING THEORY BUT IT'S FOCUSED
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT
THEORY.
SO WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE IN A
CLASSROOM THE GROUND WITH
CHILDREN EVERY DAY THAT IS COR
AND WE SEE A LOT OF TEACHERS
COMING OUT AND THEY NEED SUPPORT
ON THE TEACHING COMPONENT.
OF WHAT THEY'RE LEARNING SAID
THAT STRENGTHENING OUT PIECE AND
THEN FOUR AND JUST THE STATE AS
A WHOLE WE REALLY DO SEE SOME
EQUITY ISSUES.
AND WE THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
PHASED IN APPROACH ALSO TO HELP
PROGRAMS APPLY AND MEET THE
STANDARDS OF A HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
OTHERWISE WE'RE JUST GOING TO
GET MORE PRESCHOOL IN SOME AREAS
AND SO REALLY SUPPORTING
ALLOWING TIME FOR ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN EVEN APPLY AND
RESPOND TO APPLICATIONS.
AND THEN ALSO HAVE THE PROGRAM
AND THE STAFF READY TO IMPLEMENT
AT AND THAT NEEDS ADDITIONAL
TIME IN SUPPORT AS WELL.
THE FOR LOOP NECKLACES AT LOCAL
LEVELS WELL [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRING UP OUR FINAL PANEL HERE.
THIS IS FROM A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE
WE WANTED TO HAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT --
AS WELL AS A NON PROFITS.
EARLY EDUCATION PROVIDER THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
A CONTRACTOR PROVIDE AS A
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE.
FOR FROM COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
TO STEP IT UP.
NOT A PROBLEM I WAS A SAY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT STRUCK ME AM I
MISSING ONE OF THE THINGS FROM
THE EARLY LEARNING THAT I REALLY
PICKED UP ON WAS THAT IN.
WHEN WE WERE IN NEW JERSEY THEY
HAD AT OUTDOOR PLAYGROUND?
AND THERE WERE TWO YEAR OLDS AND
IT MUST HAVE BEEN THIRTY DEGREES
OUTSIDE.
THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I TELL YOU HOW MANY PHONE CALLS.
FROM PARENTS WHEN IT'S SIXTY
DEGREES OUTSIDE IN THE KIDS ARE
GOING OUTSIDE SO I THINK ONE OF
THE LEARNING.
MAN THOSE KIDS HAVE SOME GREAT
TO GET OUT THERE WHAT.
TIME RIGHT YEAH TODDLERS YET AND
THEY WERE CRAWLING ON THE GROUND
THEY WERE DOING EVERYTHING THAT.
YOU WOULD DO US ANY DAY --
I'M GONNA SAY.
I WAS REALLY EXCITED TO GO
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS IS.
BEING FROM A SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
TO SEE WHAT OTHER STATES ARE
DOING SEE WHAT OTHER AND LARGER
DISTRICTS.
AND SO FOR ME WAS REALLY
INTERESTING TO TO IN NEW YORK
BECAUSE WE HAVE TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND KIDS IN OUR PROGRAM BUT
THEY MANAGE TO LIFT FROM EIGHT
THOUSAND EIGHTY THOUSAND IN THE
YEAR.
SO I THINK ONE OF THE BIG THINGS
THAT I TOOK AWAY FROM THAT WAS.
JUST THE AMOUNT OF AMNESTY INTER
AGENCY COLLABORATION THAT NEEDS
TO TAKE PLACE TO GET SOMETHING
LIKE THAT TIME.
AND THE WAY THEY DID IT WITH
INCLUDING EVERYTHING FROM THAT
FIRE DEPARTMENT TO LICENSING TO
THEIR DEPARTMENT OF ADD
PROVIDING.
YOU KNOW OVER THREE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT KINDS OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE YOU KNOW I'M.
WHICH JUST TO MANAGE THE PROGRAM
THE CURRICULUM THAT WAS CREATED
ALONG WITH I JUST THINK THAT THE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT OF THAT.
WAS PRETTY AMAZING TO ME I'M
GONNA SAY THE OTHER THING THAT I
TOOK AWAY FROM THAT WAS THAT.
WE HAVE SOME REALLY GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA I
THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF AGENCIES
WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS WHO WANT
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
AND ABOUT INVESTING IN OUR WORK
FORCE I THINK THERE'S FOLKS THAT
WANT TO DO THAT THAT REALLY SEE
THE IMPORTANCE AND I CAN SPEAK
FROM A KIND OF A LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE IN THAT.
I THINK BEING INNOVATIVE AND
WITH THE FUNDS THAT WE'VE HAD
YOU KNOW IN LA UNIFIED WAS USING
TITLE TO FUNDS. TO SUPPORT OUR
TEACHER PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROBABLY SPENT ABOUT A HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS ON TEACHER PD
BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO BRING IN
OVER.
THREE HUNDRED TEACHER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND SO
I THINK THAT'S A BIG PIECE.
AND FRESH TOHAVE IN OUR SCHOOL
BOARD AND THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
LEADERSHIP ON BOARD.
BEING ABLE TO INCLUDE EARLY
EDUCATION AS PART OF THEIR AL
CFS.
WAS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT KIND
OF LEVERAGE DOLLARS IN FINES TO
MAKE SURE THAT EARLY EDUCATION
STATE AND FRANK.
I AM AND THAT WE WERE ALSO BEING
MONITORED AND LOOKED AT AS FAR
AS ALL OF OUR CENTERS
PARTICIPATED IN THE QUALITY
RATING IMPROVEMENTS SYSTEM AND
AND I'M NOT SURE KIND OF BLEAK
NUMBERS FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
IN OUR INITIAL RATINGS WE HAD
SIXTIES IN ON A RATING OF ONE TO
FIVE WE HAD SIXTY SEVEN SCHOOLS
THAT WERE RATED AS A TWO MAY
TWELFTH SCHOOLS THAT WERE RATED
AS A THREE AND TWO SCHOOLS THAT
WERE RATED AS A FOUR BUT ONCE
THE BOARD KIND OF GOT.
ON BOARD AND REALLY STARTED
PUSHING EARLY EDUCATION STARTED
MAKING THOSE INVESTMENTS.
AND WE BOUGHT AN ADDITIONAL
COACHING THROUGH AND AT AT THE
TIME IT WAS ALLEY AT BUT CHILD.
THREE SIXTY IN OUR LAST ROUND OF
SCORES WE HAVE ONE SCHOOL AT A
TWO WE HAVE FORTY THREE AT A
THREE AND THIRTY NINE OR THIRTY
DOING THAT KIND OF WORK REALLY
DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND THEN
I THINK THE OTHER PART OF IT
THAT KIND OF MAKES WST KINDA
UNIQUE IN THE SENSE THAT.
WE DO PARA TEACHERS A LIVABLE
WAGE IN EARLY EDUCATION PART OF
IT IS BECAUSE THEY'RE PART OF
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT
WITH YOU TLA.
SO WHATEVER HAPPENS THERE AS FAR
AS BENEFITS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
ALSO BEEN OF OUR BENEFIT OUR
TEACHERS.
SO TEACHER IN LA UNIFIED
BENEFITS AFTER FIVE YEARS WOULD
MAKE AROUND SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO THAT'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE COMPARED.
TO A LOT OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OUT THERE.
AND I THINK OTHER THINGS THAT
REALLY MAKE US UNIQUE AND REALLY
KIND OF MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION SOMEBODY HAD MENTIONED
ABOUT.
IS THE EARLY AT CENTER PLACE
WHERE PARENTS WANT TO PUT THEIR
KIDS.
WE'VE INVESTED A LOT OF MONEY
INTO OUR INTO OUR WIRELESS
INTERNET AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AHMED ABOUT TWENTY POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS USING BOND
FINDING.
THAT WE'VE AND WE STARTED
CREATING OUR FIRST WE HAVE OUR
FIRST SEVEN STEAM CERTIFIED
EARLY EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE TEN OUTDOOR NATURE
EXPORTS CERTIFYING CLASSROOMS
AND WE HAVE THIRTEEN DUAL
LANGUAGE PROGRAMS IN EARLY
EDUCATION.
SO I THINK THOSE THINGS ALSO
SPEAK WELL OF I'M GONNA SAY THAT
DISTRICTS SUPPORT AND THE
BACKING OF IT.
SO.
I THINK THE LONG TERM ISSUE AND
WHAT WE'VE HAD TO CHANGE THE
CONVERSATION AROUND AND THIS IS
KIND OF AT ALL LEVELS IS REALLY
MAKING.
EARLY EDUCATION SEEN AS AN
INVESTMENT.
AND NOT AN ENCROACHMENT.
YOU KNOW FOR A LONG TIME IF YOU
TALK ABOUT EARLY EDUCATION IS AN
ENCROACHMENT.
IT REALLY LENDS ITSELF TO BEING
CUT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT AND AS AN
INVESTMENT AND WE COSTED OUT IF
96% OF THOSE KIDS THAT WE HAVE
AN EARLY EDUCATION STAY WITH US
TO FIRST GRADE?
THEN WE RECOUP ALL THE COST PLUS
ON IN EIGHTY A SO AS A DISTRICT
THAT ENROLLMENT PIECES BEEN VERY
SIGNIFICANT SO.
I AM.
BUT I DO THINK GOING BACK TO
WHEN DOCTOR FREE SAID IS THAT
REALLY LOOKING LONG TERM AND HOW
DO WE GET A QUICK MARK.
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE AND WITH
KATE GETTING A BA IN NEW JERSEY
WHEN THE TEACHERS TALKED ABOUT
WHAT THAT MEANT FOR THEM AND YOU
KNOW AND I'M GONNA SAY.
THEY WERE VERY PROUD OF IT I
THINK THAT WOULD ALSO SPEAK TO
OUR PARENTS AND THEN IT WAS ALSO
THE PEACE THAT ONE OF THE
TEACHERS SAID THAT.
IT WASN'T JUST GETTING HER
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IT WAS BEING
ABLE TO TELL HER PARENTS OF HER
KIDS WHY IT WAS IMPORTANT TO GET
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
I THINK THOSE KINDS OF
STATEMENTS AND PROGRAMS IN
BELIEVES BY THE TEACHERS ALSO
MAKE A LONG TERM DIFFERENCE SO.
AM I MISS IT SO THOSE ARE
CONSENT KIND OF SOME OF MY TAKE
AWAYS AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE KIND OF DOING IN LA U.
S. T. TO KIND OF MAKE AN TO MAKE
A BIG DIFFERENCE FOR OUR KIDS.
OKAY THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
STAFF --
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE SCOTT MORE --
WITH KID ANGO COULD DANGO IS THE
BAY AREA'S LARGEST CHILD CARE
PRESCHOOL ORGANIZATION --
WE GET A LOT OF MONEY FROM SERRA
AND SUPERINTENDED BACK THERE --
AND HEAD START EARLY HEAD START --
AND AND FIRST FIVE AND LOCAL --
GOVERNMENT FUNDING AS WELL --
AND YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN AROUND
ACTUALLY THIS YEAR'S OUR
FORTIETH BIRTHDAY SO WE'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR FORTY YEARS --
AND YEAH I I GUESS YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT FRUIT
LOOPS WERE WERE A COUPLE OF
LOCAL FRUIT LOOPS HERE --
BUT OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW LIVING
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THE OF THE
STATE --
POLICY AND LEGISLATIVE DECISIONS
THAT ARE MADE HERE AND HUMAN YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT WAS --
WHAT'S BEEN SAID EARLIER WE
POINT SEVEN BILLION A YEAR WE
SIR FOREIGN SEVENTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN --
AND YET NONE OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW --
OF ALL OF THEM AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF THEM MEET THE STANDARDS THAT
RESEARCH SHOWS ACTUALLY RESULTS
IN LONGITUDINAL GAINS FOR FOR ME
NOW.
CHILDREN --
WHETHER YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE OR YOU KNOW
IMPROVEMENTS OF LATER IN LIFE.
AND YOU KNOW THERE THERE WASN'T --
ANY COST BENEFIT DATA IT'S COME
OUT OF NEW JERSEY BUT WE
CERTAINLY EFFORT KLEINIAN YOU
REFERENCED --
NOBEL LAUREATE JAMES HECKMAN AND
HE OFTEN SAYS YOU KNOW FOR EVERY
DOLLAR YOU INVEST YOU GET SEVEN
DOLLARS BACK.
I'M IN I'M SURE THERE ARE MANY
CONFERENCES ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
VERACITY OF THAT I THINKING IN
TODAY'S DAY AND AGE OF A NOBEL
LAUREATE SAYS THAT WE JUST SAY
OKAY IT'S TRUE --
IT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME BUT YOU
KNOW THE MATH ON THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT FIVE BILLION --
IS YOU KNOW AT THIRTY FIVE
BILLION BACK AND BENEFITS --
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU'RE TO
TAKE SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS AND
INCREASE THEM TO THE LEVEL.
OF STANDARDS AND QUALITY I
INVEST IN THEM OF MONEY RIGHT
HAAS SO THAT PEOPLE CAN GET PAID
MORE.
ON THE BENEFITS BACK WOULD BE
HUGE THE WE HAVE VERY FEW
RESEARCH ON OUR PROGRAMS --
ONE STUDY THAT WAS ALREADY
ALLUDED TO IS THE OUR STUDY --
THAT LOOKED AT TI QUE IN
PRESCHOOL --
AND YOU KNOW THE RESULT WAS YET
THE KIDS THAT WERE IN TWO K. IT
LOOKS A LITTLE BETTER THAN THE
KIDS THAT WERE IN PRESCHOOL --
BUT THE REALITY IS IS THAT.
NEITHER OF THEM ARE CLOSING THE
GAP --
GAP IN THE WAY THAT --
WE SEE SOME OF THESE OTHER
STATES AND CITIES DOING --
SO I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW.
FANTASTIC THAT A GROUP WENT AND
VISITED THESE OTHER PROGRAMS AND
I DO THINK WE NEED TO BE LOOKING
TO THEM --
AS AS YOU KNOW NORTH STARS OF
WHERE WE NEED TO BE HEADED LONG
TERM ALMOND WITH THOUGHTFUL
PLANNING AND INVESTMENT.
IN.
THE SAN JOSE.
WE PROVIDE A LOT OF PRE SCHOOL
BOTH FULL THEN PART DAY --
IN A SCHOOL DISTRICT CALL ALUM
ROCK -- IT'S
ACTUALLY AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALLERS DISTRICT --
AND WE RECENTLY --
COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT A PLANNING
EFFORT AROUND HOW DO WE GET
CHILDREN --
AS MANY CHILDREN AS WE CAN TO
PROFICIENCY BY BY THIRD GRADE
BOTH IN LANGUAGE AND MATH --
AND WE LOOKED AT ONE MAJOR --
CORNERSTONE OF THAT IS CREATING
PRESCHOOL FOR ALL --
AND WE HAD THE DISTRICT AND WE
HAVE THE COUNTY OFFICE AND WE
HAD COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE CUTTING GO WE
ALL CAME AROUND THE TABLE.
HIGH AND THE DISTRICTS THAT YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO EXPAND OUR T. K..
ON A COUNTY OFFICE THAT WE WANT
TO EXPAND OUR HEAD START AND WE
SAID WELL WHAT WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
EXPAND.
STATE PRESCHOOL WOULD LIKE TO
EXPAND EARLY HEAD START AND
INSTEAD OF FIGHTING OVER WHO
GETS THE FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE WHO
CATS WHICH KIDS --
YOU KNOW WE SAID OKAY IT'S CAN
GO INTO T. K. THAT MEANS WE GET
THE SERVE MORE THREE YEAR OLDS
HOW DO WE BRING IN MORE INFANTS
AND TODDLERS YOU KNOW WHERE THE
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT
AND WE PLAN TOGETHER BECAUSE IF
WE'RE EVER GOING TO GET TO A
PLACE.
WHERE WE ACTUALLY ARE SERVING
MORE LOW INCOME THREES AND MORE
LONG COME INFANTS AND TODDLERS
WITH SOMEONE'S GOT TO DO THAT?
RIGHT AND OFTEN TIMES --
THOSE ARE THE CBO'S.
ARE THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT --
ARE THE EXPERTS IN IT AND AND
CAPABLE OF DOING IT --
SO WE BROUGHT ALL OF US TOGETHER
AND WE DIDN'T JUST TALK ABOUT
WHO SERVES WHICH KIDS BUT HOW DO
WE SERVE THOSE KIDS AND WE HAVE
A HIGH POPULATION.
OF DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS ON A
IN THE SAN JOSE --
SO WE WORKED WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AROUND OKAY I YOU HAVE
SOME TO A LANGUAGE IMMERSION
SCHOOLS WELL LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT THE PRESCHOOLS ON THOSE
CAMPUSES ARE ALIGNED TO THAT
CURRICULUM --
YOU KNOW WE WE HAD A LOT OF
CASES OF TRAUMA --
WHERE WE ALL SAID WE PORTS A
MENTAL AND SO WE CREATED A MODEL
AROUND THAT --
CAN FOR US WHAT REALLY --
MADE THE BIGGEST IMPACT --
AND AND AND SPEAKING
PARTICULARLY IF COULD BANGO IS.
OF A CONTINUOUS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT APPROACH --
WHERE WE FIRST STARTED IN THIS
IS SPECIFICALLY AROUND LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT WE LOOKED AT ONE OF
THE MOST PREDICTED SKILLS --
THAT -- SHOW
THAT IF CHILDREN ARE MEETING
CERTAIN LEVELS OF PROFICIENCY IN
VOCABULARY AND SOUNDS AND
LETTERS AND RHYMING ALLITERATION --
BY THE TIME THEY START
KINDERGARTEN THAT IT'S THE BEST
CHANCE THAT THEY HAVE FOR
READING BY THE END OF THIRD
GRADE --
THEN WE LOOKED AT THAT WE LOOKED
AT SOME EVIDENCE BASED CURRICULA
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY IMPART THOSE
SKILLS --
AND THEN WE STARTED WORKING WITH
OUR TEACHERS AND WE STARTED TO
INVEST IN THEM ME AND NOT THIS
IS REALLY ALL ABOUT WHETHER
YOU'RE INCREASING THEIR SALARIES
ARE INVESTING IN THEIR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT --
IN OVER A NINE MONTH PERIOD WE
WE TRAIN THEM IN THIS CURRICULUM --
BUT WE AS WE KNOW THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO JUST MONTH --
SO THAT EVERY TIME THEY WENT
BACK TO THEIR CLASSROOMS THEY
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE
THEIR PRACTICE REFLECT ON IT AND
THEN.
THEY WOULD COME BACK THE NEXT
MONTH FOR TRAINING.
AND THEN THREE TIMES A YEAR WE
LOOK AT DATA THAT SHOWED HOW
CHILDREN WERE PROGRESSING SO
THAT INFORM THE INSTRUCTION --
AND IN FRANKLY WAS A GREAT
MOTIVATOR FOR OUR OUR TEACHERS
FROM FRANKLY FOR EVERYONE THE
ENTIRE ORGANIZATION.
ON AND FOR PARENTS AND A AND
THEN EVENTUALLY AS THE CHILDREN
ON THE KINDERGARTEN FOR THOSE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS TWO X.
EXCITED TO SEE.
HOW MUCH BETTER PREPARED --
THESE CHILDREN WERE.
SO YOU KNOW THIS IS JUST AN
EXAMPLE.
OF HOW LOCAL AFRICAN COME
TOGETHER WITH YOU KNOW.
OUR MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM AND
REALLY LOOK AT EXPANDING ACCESS --
IN HIGH QUALITY ACCESS. FOR OUR
CHILDREN THAT NEED IT THE MOST --
BUT I THINK WHETHER IT'S LOCAL.
OR STATE WIDE THIS IS THE
CONTACT GOING ON AT ALL LEVELS --
SO.
I'M HAPPY FOR ANY QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
A COUPLE YES SOMEONE OVER SMITH
[inaudible]
YEAH -- I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PERSPECTIVE --
IN PARTICULAR I I HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT I WOULD DO THEME PARK.
INTERESTING.
SO AT BECAUSE YOUR PRESCHOOL
TEACHERS ARE PART IN PART THAT
HE CAN KIND OF PROVIDED ME
PERSPECTIVE THEN ON WHAT ARE THE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS REQUIRED
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO I AM.
YEAH IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I
KNOW JUST COMING OFF OF A WORK
STOPPAGE YOU KNOW THE TOPIC IS
PRETTY FRESH IN EVERYBODY'S MIND
AND SOME OF US ARE STILL
RECOVERING FROM IT.
SO BUT IT BUT IT WAS ALL GOOD
I'M IS A FAR TEACHERS.
ORIGINALLY WE HAD SET A A A AND
AND WITH A MINIMUM OF SIXTY
UNITS.
TIME TO BE AN EARLY EDUCATION
TEACHER SINCE THAT TIME THOUGH
WE'VE GROWN WITH ABOUT 82% OF
OUR TEACHERS HAVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE.
BECAUSE THERE WAS ALSO A
PROVIDED AT BONUS INCENTIVE IF
THEY GET THEIR BA SO THEY CAN
MOVE ALONG THE SALARY TABLE SO
WE'RE SEEING THAT GOING AT I I
DO THINK THAT ONE OF THE
LEARNING SO WE TOOK AWAY OR THAT
I TOOK WAY PER [inaudible] 18%.
TO FINISH THEIR BACHELOR'S
DEGREES AND I THINK PROVIDING
SOME KIND OF SCHOLARSHIPS OR
STIPENDS OR ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DID WITH OUR PT AND IT WOULD BE
SOMETHING TO CONSIDER AS FAR AS
TEACHERS.
GOING BACK TO FINISH THEIR
DEGREES IS OFFERING.%
CLASSES THAT ARE YOU KNOW
THROUGH THE INSTITUTES OF HIGHER
AT IS TO OFFER CLASSES THAT.
MEET THEIR WORK HOURS.
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY HARD FOR
THEM TO TAKE OFF IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE DAY TO TO GO BACK AND
TAKE CLASS OF THE IDEA OF
PROVIDING SUBSIDIES KAY AND WHAT
WE DID WITH OUR PD IS WE PUT
THEM ON SATURDAYS.
AND WE ALLOWED THEM TO GET THEIR
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH HOURS AND
FOR EACH U. K. ANTI K. TEACHERS
WE USE SOME OF OUR TITLE TO
FINDING.
TO PAY THEM --
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
YOU
START AS A TEACHER'S AIDE WE CAN
PUT YOU ON A PATH TO GETTING
YOUR BE A AND WE CREATED A
PROGRAM WHERE WE WILL PAY UP TO
FIFTY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR ANY OF OUR TEACHERS TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL AND CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION --
AND THAT ALLOWS THEM TO EARN A
HIGHER WAGE I WILL SAY I MEAN I
CAN'T SAY IT ENOUGH.
ARE THE INCREASES THAT WE'VE HAD
IN THE YOU KNOW STYLE FIVE RATES --
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS HAVE
BEEN MONUMENTAL YOU KNOW WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO RAISE OUR TEACHER
SALARIES.
BY 45% IN THE LAST THREE AND A
HALF YEARS AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
MAINLY DUE BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASES IN RIGHT SO --
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S NOT ENOUGH
AND WE CERTAINLY NEED MORE BUT
IT'S BEEN A HUGE HUGE HELP OUR
MINIMUM WAGE IS GONE FROM ELEVEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR TO SIXTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR --
SIXTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR STILL
NOT ENOUGH BUT WORST INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL --
TO BEEN ABLE TO INCREASE IT FROM
THE CAN I ADD ONE THING ONE
THING THAT WE WERE LOOKING AT IS
IS.
AN WE STARTED DOING A LOT OF
SCHOOL INCLUSION CLASSROOMS FOR
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND SO SOMEBODY HAD MENTIONED
COST BENEFIT AND I DON'T HAVE
THAT COST BENEFIT BUT YOU KNOW
IN AYE AYE SENT DOWN AND I ASKED
REALLY QUICKLY OUR PRESCHOOL
SPECIALIZED TEAM TO PULL THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX OF THESE
COLLABORATIVE CLASSROOMS.
THAT ARE STAFFED WITH THAT EARLY
CHILDHOOD SPECIAL LIKE
CREDENTIAL TEACHER AN EARLY
EDUCATION TEACHER AND THEN TO
AIDS ONE SPECIAL AID AND ONE
GENERAL AT EIGHT AND SO SHE SENT
BACK THE DATA AND IT WAS.
OF OUR THREE HUNDRED FORTY SIX
KIDS WHO WERE IN TIME ET QUE --
SLASH PCC THESE PRESCHOOL
COLLABORATIVE CON THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO WENT TO
KINDERGARTEN WITH SUPPORT.
BUT DID NOT GO TO A SPECIAL DAY
CLASS.
AND THEN OF OUR AND THIS IS THE
ONE THAT I HAVE LAST OUT ON BUT
OF OUR FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE KITORANG ET QUE STE AND PCC
WITH THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
I'M SORRY.
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WITH
THEM AT THE PCC ATTACHED THERE
WERE FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
KIDS. NINETY EIGHT OF THOSE WENT
TO A A FULL TIME AT GENERAL
EDUCATION KINDERGARTEN CLASS.
NOW MIND YOU OF THOSE PCC SLASH
YES PP SOME OF OUR THREE YEAR
OLD SO SHE DIDN'T KNOW HOW MANY
OF THOSE FOUR YEAR OLDS.
HAD ACTUALLY MATRICULATED BUT IN
EITHER CASE THAT'S OVER 50% OF
THE KIDS WHO WERE IN THE SPECIAL
DAY PROGRAMS THAT HAD GONE INTO
A GENERAL EDUCATION CLASSROOM.
SO HAD THAT NOT BEEN THE CASE
WERE TALKING ABOUT NO ALMOST
NINE HUNDRED KIDS WOULD HAVE
STARTED KINDERGARTEN BUT
PROBABLY BEEN IN A SPECIAL DAY
CLASS.
SO.
CHECK.
IS IF YOU COULD BOTH SPEAK TO
OUR COST RITUAL THAT MIGHT BE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEIGHBORING.
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THAT IS
CURRICULA SPECIFIC FOR INSTANCE
THE STEAM PROGRAM LANGUAGE
PROGRAM HOW THOSE VERY FRIENDLY.
YOUR STANDARD.
BUT THERE IS A COST DIFFERENCE
AT ALL [inaudible]
SURE.
YEAH I MEAN THERE.
ARE -- YOU
HAVE TO INVEST.
IN YOUR YOU KNOW TEACHERS --
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO DELIVER
ANY CURRICULUM RIGHT SO --
IF YOU'RE USING --
MORE GENERAL CURRICULUM LIKE IN
CREATED CREEK COMES PROBABLY THE
MOST WIDELY USED --
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY COST MORE
TO DO A STEAM SPECIFIC CURRICULA --
BUT TO DO ANY CURRICULAR WELL
YOU ABSOLUTELY NEED TO BE ABLE
TO INVEST IN BOTH PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TO EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT.
YEAH AND I I'D SAY WITH OTHER
THAN -- THE
MATERIALS COSTS SO FOR OUR DUAL
LANGUAGE PROGRAMS --
WE WE DO USE CREATIVE CURRICULUM
BUT IT'S THE SAME THING IT'S NOT
NECESSARY THE CURRICULUM IT'S TO
SUPPORT YOU PUT BEHIND IT.
AND SO WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
TRAINING I MEAN EVERY TEACHER
HAS GONE THROUGH THAT TRAINING
AND THEN.
GONE THROUGH WHAT WE CALL
CREATIVE CURRICULUM PART.
TWO WHICH IS NOW THAT YOU'VE HAD
A YEAR OF USING AT WHAT ELSE DO
YOU NEED TO NOW.
AND I THINK WITH THAT.
AND THE COACHING IS A BIG PIECE
OF THAT WITH OUR DOOR LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS THE COACH IS GOING
THERE AT LEAST.
ADMINISTER ALMOST WEEKLY.
TIME TO VISIT THE TEACHER SO
THAT ANY OF THE STRATEGIES THAT
THEY'VE LEARNED THROUGH THE
FOURTEEN DAYS OF PD THAT THEY GO
THROUGH DURING THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR.
WE CAN MONITOR AND WE CAN WORK
WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE STRATEGIES.
THAT ARE REALLY BASED AROUND OR
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT ARE BEING
USED.
AND THEN WE GET A SUMMER BRIDGE
PROGRAM WHERE THAT TEACHERS CAME
FOR TWO WEEKS STRAIGHT.
AND WORKED IN AN EARLY EDUCATION
CENTER CLASSROOM TO PRACTICE
THOSE LESSONS AND AND SOME OF
THE STRATEGIES THAT WE CAN.
IN THAT THEY FOUND THAT THEY
FELT LIKE THEY STRUGGLED WITH.
SO IT'S KIND OF A LESSON STUDY
MODEL BUT I THINK THOSE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS AND BE SUCKED INTO
BE SIGNED STATE MATERIALS COSTS
ARE THE ONES THAT YOU KNOW.
REALLY BENEFIT THE TEACHERS. ONE
FINAL QUESTION.
I THINK I'M SORRY MY LIGHT KEEPS
GOING OFF HARD TO TELL IF I IF
YOU CAN HEAR ME NOW I KNOW YOU
CAN HEAR ME --
I PARTICULARLY LIKE THAT YOU --
HIGHLIGHTED YOUR STATISTIC ON
PERSISTENCE THROUGH FIRST GRADE
AND THE COSTS --
YOU KNOW RECOUP TO THEIR WITH
OFFERING HIGH QUALITY PRE K.
PROGRAMMING WHAT OTHER KINDS OF
LONGITUDINAL DATA IN BOTH
PROGRAMS THAT ARE YOU COLLECTING
AT THIS POINT ON STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATE.
IN YOUR PROGRAMS AND AND DO YOU
TRACK THEM THEN ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM.
WHAT I CAN SEE WE HAVEN'T
TRACKED HIM ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM?
AND WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO WE'VE
BEEN WE'VE STARTED TO TRACK THEM
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS FROM AN
EARLY HEAD PROGRAM TO THE
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
AND THE FIRST DATA WE LOOKED AT
WAS NOW IT'S THE L. PACK BUT WE
USED TO WE LOOKED AT CELL DATA.
WHICH IS THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT TEST.
SO WE COULD JUST SEE.
IN COMPARISON TO KIDS YOU'VE
NEVER HAD A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
AND HOW OUR KIDS SOMETHING IN SO
WE FOUND OVERWHELMINGLY.
ALL THE KIDS WHO WERE COMING OUT
OF AN EARLY AND PROGRAM I'M I'M
GONNA SAY OTHER THAN A FEW
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
I'M SOUTH AT A TWO OR THREE AND
MANY OF THEM I FACT SO WE KNOW
THAT.
DOWN THE LINE IT SAVES THE
DISTRICT MONEY FROM HAVING TO
INVEST IN PROGRAMS FOR AL TELLS
OR LONG TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS.
AND THE OTHER DATA WE USE IS
DOUBLES AND SO WE LOOK AT
DOUBLES DATA AND AND IT'S KIND
OF RESTRICTIVE BECAUSE IT REALLY
LOOKS AT JUST A FEW AREAS.
BUT THEY'RE GOOD PREDICTORS OF
READING FLUENCY AND AND AND
LATER ON SO WE'VE DONE THAT NOW
WE'RE ENTERING OUR SECOND YEAR
OF LOOKING AND IT'S WE HAVE
KINDERGARTEN FIRST GRADE DATA.
AND I WISH I HAD IT IN FRONT OF
ME BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN KIDS WHO HAD
AN EARLY AT PROGRAM AND THOSE
WHO DIDN'T IT'S VERY DRASTIC.
TIME.
FROM KIDS WHO HAVEN'T HAD ANY
PRESCHOOL EXPERIENCE --
THANKS TO A LOCAL PILOT WE'VE
JUST STARTED --
TO ASSIGN OURSTUDENTS IN
PRESCHOOL WITH CAL PADS ID'S
THAT ARE ASSIGNED BY THE
DISTRICT --
WHERE THEY LIVE --
IT SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LONGITUDINAL DATA BUT IT'S
HOPEFULLY ON THE WAY I MEAN I
THINK.
HE WITH HAVING A CONVERSATION
EARLIER WITH WITH ERIN CABLE AND
WE'RE SAYING YOU KNOW DATA WHAT
DATA WE JUST WE HAVE SUCH A
DEARTH OF DATA ESPECIALLY AT THE
STATE LEVEL --
AND YOU KNOW IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US --
I WILL SAY.
WE WE DO HAVE AN ON GOING --
STUDY RIGHT NOW THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO'S
CONDUCTING.
ON OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF A
LANGUAGE --
CURRICULUM THAT I JUST SPOKE
ABOUT AND THEY WILL BE LOOKING
ONLINE TO TO NEWLY AT HOW
CHILDREN DO --
ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH THIRD
GRADE SO.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THE QUESTION.
RIGHT AND AND WE NEED TO START
FINDING OUT WHAT THE ANSWER IS.
THANK YOU I WANTED TO ASK BOTH
OF YOU THE QUESTION I ASKED THE
PRIOR PANEL.
SO OF COURSE WE HAVE OUR STATE
PROGRAM IF YOU WENT TO A OF PRE
K. FOR ALL PUSHED WE BUILD UPON
OUR EXISTING.
EFFORTS WHICH YOU TO THE RIGHT
LA US THE ESTATE PRESCHOOL
CONTRACTS AS CAM DANGO.
SO IF WE HAD AT YOU KNOW AT THAT
LET'S SAY A FIVE YEAR INCOME
ELIGIBLE --
FOUR YEAR OLDS AND EXPECTS
BANNING.
MAYBE IN IN YOU KNOW HIGH NEED
AREAS LIKE IT IN IN NEW JERSEY
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE WHAT ARE SOME
OF THAT LESSONS THAT THAT WE
LEARNED FROM.
THE EAST COAST AND APPLY THEM
AND SOME OF THE PRACTICAL ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND UP AND PLAY THEM AND PAINT
PAINT A PICTURE FOR US AS FAR AS
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE. TO GET THERE.
YEAH -- WELL --
YOU KNOW SOME OF THIS YOU KNOW
AND IT'LL SOUND OBVIOUS BUT WE
STILL DON'T REALLY DO IT IN THE
STATE -- YOU
KNOW YOU NEED CLASSROOMS.
IN ORDER TO SERVE KIDS --
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY PRE
SCHOOL FACILITIES FUNDING --
AVAILABLE SO YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES
AT THAT HAS MEANT IN THE PAST IS --
YOU KNOW YOU FIND YOU KNOW YOU
SERVE KIDS WERE YOU CONFINED
SPACE RIGHT WHICH ISN'T
NECESSARILY WHERE THERE IS THE
MOST NEED IN FACT A LOT OF TIMES
WE TALK ABOUT PRESCHOOL DESERT'S --
THERE'S A REASON WHY THERE ARE
YOU KNOW IT'S NO PRESCHOOLS
THERE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
CLASSROOMS IN ORDER --
TO SERVE THEM --
AND I'M TELLING YOU THOSE DARN
LITTLE TOILETS ARE EXPENSIVE.
COST MORE THAN WIFI EVEN --
NGUYEN THAT'S EXPENSIVE --
TO TESTING IN THE WORK FORCE --
ATTRACTING AND RETAINING --
AMAZING TEACHERS IS NOT EASY --
WITH THE SALARIES THAT WERE WERE
PAYING -- I
WILL SAY YOU KNOW SINCE WE'VE
STARTED TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE
WAGES MOVE INVESTED IN OUR WORK
FORCE --
WE'VE SEEN OUR YOU KNOW TURN
OVER CUT IN HALF WHICH IS GREAT
IT'S NOW AVERAGING AROUND 16%
AND FOR OUR MID AND AN UPPER
LEVEL --
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS OF THESE
ARE ARE SO SHE TEACHERS AND THE
TEACHERS --
THAT TURN OVER RATES DOWN 28%
WHICH IS FANTASTIC THAT MATTERS
A LOT BECAUSE THEN YOU'RE NOT
CONSTANTLY HAVING TO FILL
EXISTING POSITIONS IN YOU CAN
START TO EXPAND.
AND SERVE MORE KIDS SO --
YOU KNOW INVESTING IN CLASSROOMS
IN INVESTING IN PEOPLE.
ARM ARE BOTH CRITICAL.
YEAH I WOULD ECHO THAT --
THE FACILITIES IS ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE AND WHEN WE LOOK AT RE
OPENING SOME OF OUR CLOSE ENTERS
AND AND TRYING.
TO AND THE COST BEHIND IT.
HE YOU MIGHT THINK TEN POINT ONE
MILLION GOES A LONG WAY BUT THEN
WE STARTED LOOKING AT ALL THE
EIGHTY A UPGRADES AND SMALL
SMALL TOILETS YEAH [inaudible]
IT SO WITH TEN POINT ONE IT'S
IT'S NOT A LOT THE UNIT CAN
ACTUALLY HAPPEN I THINK WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT PAINTING A PICTURE.
MA'AM I THINK LONG TERM WE NEED
TO DEVELOP BETTER CAREER
PATHWAYS FOR FOLKS --
INCLUDING CONTINUING AD --
I THINK BRINGING BACK SOMETHING
LIKE THE EARLY HEAD CREDENTIAL
THAT WAS ON THE BOOKS IN CTC
WOULD BE A HUGE THAT.
TIME IT EXISTS.
AND NOW IT'S A MATTER OF GETTING
HIGHER INSTITUTES OF HIGHER ADD
TO ONE AND ALSO BRING THAT BACK.
THINK THAT FEEDS THE WORK FORCE
AND THAT REALLY WANTS TO WORK
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW I CAN TELL YOU AS A
FIFTH GRADE TEACHER.
AND HAVING TO BE.
PICK MY CLASS SELECTION BASED ON
SENIORITY AND THEN THAT YOU KNOW
FIVE YEARS LATER ALL OF A SUDDEN
FINDING OUT THAT I'M NOT GONNA
TEACH FIFTH GRADE AND I'M GONNA
TEACH KINDERGARTEN.
YOU NOW AFTER THAT FIRST TO HAVE
KIDS CRYING I WAS IT I WAS READY
TO CALL IT QUITS.
BUT I THINK THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS BECAUSE IF YOU INVEST IN
THEM AND YOU INVEST IN PEOPLE
WHO REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH OUR
YOUNG CHILDREN AND THEN YOU PAID
THEM.
INAPPROPRIATELY YOU'RE GONNA GET
THEM AND BUT IT'S A MATTER OF
ALIGNING THOSE OTHER PIECES SO
IN FIVE YEARS.
I CAN DEFINITELY SEE WORKING
WITH HIGH INSTITUTES OF HIGHER
ED WORKING WITH CTC TO BRING
BACK AN EARLY A CREDENTIAL OR
EVEN AN ADDED AUTHORIZATION FOR
PEOPLE HAVE A MULTIPLE SUBJECT.
NEAR THAT WANT TO GO BACK AND DO
SOMETHING.
AND I THINK ALSO BRINGING KIND
OF CLOUD CERTIFICATION TO EARLY
EDUCATION TEACHERS WHERE THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO WORK WITH.
DOOR LANGUAGE LEARNERS BUT ALSO
BE VERY VERY HELPFUL AND I THINK
TEACHERS WOULD FIND IT HELPFUL.
TIME.
ON HIM.
IF WE HAD MENTIONED TRAUMA
INFORMED AND I THINK WITH THE
POPULATIONS WE WORK WITH A LOT
OF TIMES WITH SUBSIDIZED
PROGRAMS.
I THINK YOU NEED TO ALSO BRING
BACK ORDERED LOOK AT PROVIDING
TRAINING FOR TEACHERS AND TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE AND WHAT DOES IT
LOOK LIKE FOR THEM AS TEACHERS
IN THE CLASSROOM.
SO THIS WOULD BE KIND OF SOME OF
THE IN. FOR STEPS IF.
AS FAR AS THE CREDENTIAL OF
COURSE IT COMES WITH
COMPENSATION I GUESS IT'S HARD.
TO FOR SOMEBODY TO GET THE
CREDENTIAL OF THEIR NOT GONNA
GET.
PAID.
ACCORDINGLY TO HOW MUCH THEY
COULD MAKE DURING ANOTHER CAREER
DRESS STUDENT LOANS AND SO FORTH.
SO AT THAT COULD TANGO YOU SAID
YOU GIVE YOUR WORK FIRST FIVE
GRAND A YEAR TO GO BACK. TO
SCHOOL AND THEN GET IT WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE WE'LL
PAY YOU GIVE THE REWARD TEACHERS
WHEN THEY GET THAT.
BA SO WHAT'S WHAT'S THE DIFF
BETWEEN THAT AND SOMEBODY
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE --
THE THE SALARY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A TEACHER AIDE --
AND ARE SORT OF HIGHEST PAID
HEAD START --
TEACHER WHICH IS A BE A LEVEL.
HOBBY A WITH YOU KNOW TWENTY
FOUR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
UNITS -- NOT
JUST THE LAME POLITICAL SCIENCE
DEGREE LIKE I HAVE --
IS SAID THE TEACHER RATE IS AT
SIXTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR AND BILL
THE TEACHERS ANYWHERE BETWEEN
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY FIVE SO
THAT ALL OF YOUR LEAD TEACHERS
HAVE A BA.
BY IN HEAD START YES YES --
MUSICAL NOT FOR STATE PRESCHOOL
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT --
AND THAT YOU'RE STATE PRESCHOOL
TEACHERS YA GET TO TEACHERS TO
CLASSROOMS ONE HAS THAT.
THE A IN ONE DOES NOT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE TWO THE
SALARY LEVEL FOR OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL IS OF THE TEACHER IS --
AROUND TOO IT'S TWENTY ONE
DOLLARS AN HOUR.
NOW 222-1 YEAH ACTUALLY TWENTY
ONE SO THEY FIND IT IT'S WORTH
THEIR WHILE.
TO THE DIFFERENTIAL FOR THE BE
THE COST GETTING A BA --
I CAN'T NECESSARILY SPEAK FOR
THEM -- THE
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE FEW HERE
TODAY WHO WHO WELL ALL I WILL
SAY -- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE AMAZING EXAMPLES OF
THE OUR TEACHERS WHO HAVE IN
OVER YEARS WORKED HARD TO GET
THEIR BA'S AND YOU KNOW THE
INVESTING IN THEM HAS ENABLED
THEM TO DO THAT.
I AND IT'S CHANGED THEIR LIFE IN
IN MANY RESPECTS BEYOND JUST.
YOU KNOW HIGHER SALARY --
AN IT DOES OPEN UP OTHER DOORS
FOR THEM --
SO YOU KNOW WE CAN PROVIDE EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN THEY CAN DO THAT.
WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE --
THEY CAN GO ON AND GET THEIR
MASTER'S DEGREE AND BECOME A
REALLY TELL THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTANT WHICH WE ALSO DO --
OR THEY CAN LEAVE US WE'VE HAD
FOLKS LEAVE US AND BECOME
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS --
CREDENTIALED SPECIAL ED TEACHERS
I MEAN THESE ARE FOLKS WHO HAVE
YOU KNOW TEN FIFTEEN YEARS
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN THAT ARE NOW GOING TO
BE YOU KNOW KINDERGARTEN OR
FIRST OR SECOND GRADE TEACHERS
WHICH IS GREAT.
YOU KNOW I MEAN WE LOSE THEM BUT
WE SELL ACCOMPLISHMENT AT THE
SAME TIME [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION --
I I JUST WANT AS I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA PUBLIC COMMON NOW BUT FOR
THE STATE TO THIS TOWN THE
OTHERS THIS WAS EXTREMELY
HELPFUL. TO UNDERSTANDING --
YOU KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AS FAR AS EARLY
LEARNING AND CALIFORNIA'S GONNA
FILL THAT PRE K. FOR ALL PROMISE
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO DO IT RIGHT
AND DO IT WELL.
UNDERSTANDING.
WHAT OTHERS ARE DOING WHERE
WE'RE AT TODAY AND BUILDING UPON
OUR EXISTING SYSTEM IS IS WHAT
IT'S ALL ABOUT SO?
THANK YOU ALL AND WITH THAT WE
WILL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS TAB.
NOW SERVE FOR THOSE OF YOU
INTERESTED IN.
PARTICIPATING COULD LINE UP IN
THE MIDDLE AND WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO ASK INDIVIDUALS. TO KEEP
THEIR COMMENTS --
TO ROUGHLY A MINUTE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ON YES --
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BUT
THE SALE SIGN ON I'M THE
AFFECTED EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE EDGE CALIFORNIA --
AS THE ORGANIZER OF THE EARLY
LIVING TOURISTS GREAT TO SEE ALL
THIS TRACTION HAPPENING AND AND
THIS IS WHY WE DO THIS TO
TOWARDS TO HAVE THIS MEETINGS
WHERE WE SHARE OUR LEARNINGS.
AND FOR ME --
YOU KNOW I WAS A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER WHO WAS GREAT TO SEE.
THESE PLACES WHERE THEY VALUE
TEACHERS US YOU KNOW --
A PROFESSION THEY PAY THEM THEY
SUPPORT THEM AND THAT HAPPENED
TO ME WHEN I WAS A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER I HAD A GREAT --
COACH I HAD OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TRAINING AND THAT TOOK ME HERE
AND NOW FOR ME IT'S MY WAY OF
GIVING BACK.
JUST SAYING YEAH WE NEED WE NEED
TO CHANGE THIS WE NEED IS THE
TIME FOR EARLY LEARNING TO BE
SEEN AS A PROFESSION.
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE A GOVERNOR
EARNING SO WE ASK YOU KNOW
THAT'S ADVOCATES AND OTHERS HERE
NEED TO COME TOGETHER AND MAKE
THIS HAPPEN THOUGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
HELPING LEAD THE THE TOWARD TO
THE EAST COAST THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR RON
RAP ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS --
I WANNA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
YOU BEEN A VERY STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND WE WE
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT IN A PLOT
THAT -- YOU
KNOW GET THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS ACROSS THE
STATE I HAVE A COUPLE OF THEM
WITH ME TODAY. TO PROVIDE SOME
INPUT.
WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED
EFFORTS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IN
FACT WERE CO SPONSORS OF YOUR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
PACKAGE --
ONE TWO THREE ONE TWO FOUR ONE
TWO FIVE AND WE'VE BEEN VERY
ACTIVE IMPROPER ON PROVIDING
INPUT INTO THAT PACKAGE SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY --
AS I TALK TO MY EARLY CHILDHOOD
MEMBERS --
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT THEY'VE BEEN TELLING ME
PARTICULAR REGARDING REQUIRING
THE BA --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT THEY
SAY IS NECESSARY IS A
GRANDFATHERING CLAUSE OR A
WAIVER OR SERVICE CREDIT FOR
GETTING THOSE --
THOSE DEGREES WE HAVE HAVE BEEN
TEACHING FOR TWENTY YEARS TO
REQUIRE THEM TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL -- TO
GET A BE A IS IS BURDENSOME AND
A LOT OF WAYS ON THE SECOND
THING THAT THEY TELL ME IS IF
YOU'RE GOING TO REQUIRE IT --
YOU NEED --
TO YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S AN ADEQUATE TIME LINE I
THINK THE PROPOSAL'S EIGHT YEARS
CURRENTLY THEY'RE SUGGESTING TEN
YEARS THAT'S I THINK NEGOTIABLE
CERTAINLY --
IN MANY OF THESE IDEAS CAME OUT
TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
HEARING --
ANOTHER THING THAT TENTH THEY'RE
TELLING ME IS THAT THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL SO
YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE DOLLARS. TO
GET THE BE A NOT ONLY TO WISHIN
FEES BOOKS BUT ALSO RELEASED
TIME AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS
CAME UP SO IT HAS TO BE A
SYSTEMIC APPROACH IN A PACKAGE.
TO TO RATCHET UP THE QUALITY OF
OF OF THE TEACHING WORKFORCE AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING THE SALARY THAT
OTHER.
T. K. TWELVE TEACHERS ARE
GETTING CAN YOU IMAGINE LIVING
ON SIXTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR AND
SAN FRANCISCO IN LA AND SAN JOSE.
SO THERE HAS TO BE SOME LANGUAGE
THAT GUARANTEES THAT NOT JUST AN
INCREASE AND REIMBURSEMENT RATES
BECAUSE THAT'S NO GUARANTEE BUT
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET THAT SALARY IF THEY GET THE
BA.
SO I WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
TO MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY --
DOCTOR BETTY ROBINSON OR FORTY
SEVEN YEARS IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SHE'S THE FIRST ONE TO SPEAK
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH
THIS CONVERSATION THAT FELL OVER
DO AS RUN SAID I'VE BEEN WORKING
IN THE CLASSROOM AT FOUR FORTY
SEVEN YEARS FORTY FIVE OF THOSE
YEARS HAVE BEEN IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THE OTHER THREE YEARS WERE IN
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA.
AS I STAND HERE I SPEAK FOR THE
TEACHERS AND EDUCATORS OF SAN
FRANCISCO --
FROM UNITED EDUCATED SAN
FRANCISCO I AM CURRENTLY THE
EARLY EDUCATION CHAIR FOR U. S.
F. UNITED ITS KIDS OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M ALSO THE CHAIR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
SO AS I SPEAK I CAN CONFIDENTLY
SPEAK.
WITH THEM IN BACK OF ME.
IN TERMS OF HOW THEY FEEL.
AS WE LOOK AT WHAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR EARLY HEAD WE CUT TO
REMEMBER THAT TKD.
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT FROM EARLY
IT'S WE GOT TO KIND OF MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP A CLEAR LINE
BETWEEN THOSE TWO BECAUSE OF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS VERY CLEAR WHERE
THEY DEVELOPED THE TKO PROGRAM.
SOME KIND OF TALK ABOUT EARLY
EDUCATION AS WE TALK ABOUT EARLY
AND I WANNA.
MAKE SURE THAT WE REMEMBER
FEELING THAT.
EARLY IT'S TO BE A PLATE PATH.
WITH THE EMPHASIS OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
SOMETIMES WE FORGET SOMETIMES
YOU WANT TO WATER IT DOWN.
THE KEY TO THE KINDERGARTEN
CURRICULUM FOR A PHASE I WANT TO
STRESS HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
FOR EDUCATORS TO BE COMPENSATED --
TO HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION THAT
IS INFORMED AND ALSO SUPPORTED.
FOR THE THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
TO BE THERE ALONG WITH HIGH
EXPECTATIONS FOR STUDENTS.
SOMETIMES WE FORGET.
THAT THERE SHOULD BE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AVAILABLE IF POSSIBLE.
OF THOSE THINGS REALLY ARE
IMPORTANT.
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT.
WHEN WE HAVE THE LITTLE DARLINGS
AND I'M STILL IN A IN THE CLASS
OF THE WHEN I GO BACK TO SCHOOL
TOMORROW MY TO THAN THE GOT A
SAFETY TO PAY THE WAY HAVE YOU
PAY IF I'M GOOD ENOUGH THAT
THEY'LL THEY'LL?
I HAVE BEEN IN SACRAMENTO GUN AT
THE SHOW THEM THAT AT WITH THE
SHIELD WHERE SACRAMENTO IS AND
THAT KIND OF THING BUT WE ALSO
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT.
WOULD DEAL WITH THE WHOLE CHILD.
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS WHEN THAT
CHAO WALKS IN THE DOOR.
THE A BRING WITH THEM ALL
THERE'S ALL THEIR LUGGAGE.
ALL OF THEIR FAMILY STUFF ALL OF
THE COMMUNITY THINGS SO.
SOMETIMES WE FORGET THAT THAT
LITTLE PARTS OF THIS DEATH NOT
OUT OF OF EMPTY.
EMPTY VESSEL THEY COME WITH
THEIR OWN STUFF TO THE WE HAD TO
BE PREPARED TO DEAL WITH THAT.
AGAIN I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT --
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SAY WIN THESE VENUES
HAPPENED WE WOULD LOVE THE
EDUCATORS THE PRACTITIONERS WHO
IN THE CLASSROOM EVERY SINGLE
DAY WE WOULD LOVE TO BE A PART
OF THE CONVERSATION.
SO THANKS AGAIN THANK YOU AND
YOU ARE BUT YOU BEING HERE TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR MCCARTY
AN HONORABLE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RICO TAMAYO AND I AM PRESIDENT
OF THE EARLY CHILDHOOD T. K.
TWELVE COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
BEFORE THAT FORTY POUNDS AGO I
WAS A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER IN
COMPTON CALIFORNIA --
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING I BASICALLY WANT TO SAY --
KIND OF PIGGY BACK ON WHAT BETTY
WAS SAYING ABOUT PRACTITIONERS
AND I WAS GOING TO BE WHAT I
WROTE SO IT'LL BE QUICK AND I
WILL GO ON AND ON AND ON YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR ANSWERS.
IN PLACE AS FAR AWAY.
BUT ARE YOU LOOKING AT WHAT IS
WORKING HERE.
AT HOME IN CALIFORNIA.
I MEAN HAS ANYONE REALLY STUDY
PROGRAMS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE IN
PLACE.
TEACHERS WHO ARE IN THE
CLASSROOM AND KNOW THE DAY TO
DAY STRUGGLES THAT THEY IN THEIR
STUDENTS FACE KNOW BEST.
WHAT WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T HAVE
THESE PRACTITIONERS BEEN TALKED
TO HAVE THEY BEEN SURVEYED IS
THERE?
RESEARCH ON THAT WHY NOT SPEND
SOME OF MONEY AND I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MONEY AND IT'S
ALWAYS ABOUT MONEY BUT WHY NOT
FIND SOME HIGH QUALITY
CLASSROOMS AND PRACTITIONERS.
AND PAY THEIR SALARY FOR A YEAR
GIVE THEM A SABBATICAL SO THAT
YOU CAN HAVE A THINK TANK OF
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY REALLY KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE AND
HOPEFULLY WHAT THE ANSWERS ARE.
I MEAN GIVE THEM TIME TO TO
REALLY HELP BE A PART OF THE
PROCESS.
I'M GONNA MENTION THIS BECAUSE
IT'S TRUE BUT I THINK IT SHOULD
BE MENTIONED.
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING ABOUT A YEAR AGO
YEAR AND A HALF AGO AND THEY'RE
STILL WORKING ON IT TRYING TO
OVERHAUL THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
CREDENTIAL.
I WAS A MEMBER OF THE FIRST TASK
FORCE TO LOOK INTO THIS.
I WAS NEW THERE WERE SIXTEEN
PEOPLE THAT WERE WERE PART OF
THIS TASK FORCE THAT WE'RE GONNA
TO DETERMINE THE FATE.
OF TEACHERS ACROSS THE STATE I
WAS THE ONLY ONE THAT HAD BEEN A
PRACTITIONER.
AND THAT WAS NINE YEARS AGO I'VE
BEEN OUT OF THE CLASSROOM FOR
NINE YEARS.
AND I ADDRESS THAT TO DOCTOR
LINDA DARLING HAMMOND AND THEY
PUT THE BRAKES ON EVERYTHING
THERE LIKE ONO WE GOTTA GET
PEOPLE INVOLVED.
SO YOU DON'T REMEMBER ANYTHING
FOR WHAT I SAY TODAY PLEASE GET
PRACTITIONERS AND PRESCHOOL
TEACHERS RT TEACHING INVOLVED IN
WHATEVER YOU'RE GOING TO DO.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH WHAT
DEAN WAS SAYING FROM L. A. U. S.
T. I MEAN THEY'RE RIGHT THERE IT
SEEMS LIKE A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION I'M BOWLED AWAY THAT.
82% OF THEIR TEETH --
AND I ALSO AGREE WITH DEAN ABOUT
BRING BACK THE EARLY AT
CREDENTIAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOONTHANK YOU MY NAME
IS ERIN SOLOMON AND I AM FROM
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING --
SOME QUESTIONS CAME UP TODAY
REGARDING WHAT THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN FOR THE LAST
FOUR PLUS YEARS AND WE WOULD
VERY MUCH LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH SOME ANSWERS TO
THOSE QUESTIONS --
I DON'T WANT TO YOU KNOW ENGAGE
IN A SORT OF A RESPONSE WITH
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN SAID BY PREVIOUS FOLKS BUT
I WOULD LIKE --
TO ASSURE YOU THAT THE
COMMISSION BROUGHT TOGETHER A
CHILD DEVELOPMENT PERMIT
ADVISORY PANEL FOUR YEARS AGO
AND WE WERE VERY CAREFUL. TO
ENSURE THAT THAT PANEL OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY PLUS PEOPLE
REPRESENTED --
PRACTITIONERS SO TEACHERS IN THE
FIELD --
ADMINISTRATORS OF THOSE PROGRAMS
IN THE FIELD PREPARERS OF THE
WORK FORCE FROM BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHICH DOES THE BULK OF THE
PREPARATION OF THIS WORKFORCE
CURRENTLY.
AND ALSO FROM THE A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS --
FACULTY REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
PUBLIC THEY WERE OPEN PUBLIC
MEETINGS US THAT WE HAD A LOT OF
GROUPS THAT DID ATTEND WE ALSO --
WHEN WE HAD SOME DRAFT PRODUCTS
FOR THE FIELD WE PUT THEM OUT
FOR PUBLIC SURVEY FOR STATEWIDE
PUBLIC SURVEY RECEIVED THOUSANDS
OF RESPONSES AND WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION
WITH YOU?
AND WITH ANYBODY ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IT MUCH AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SPEAKING WITH YOU IN
THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ALLEN DOCTOR
AND I'M WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
E. C. E. PROGRAM AND WE JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING.
AND WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD WILL
ADD TO WORKING WITH YOU THIS
YEAR IN PARTICULAR ON INCREASE
CHAIN STAFF WAGES AND FUNCTIONAL
FACILITIES FUNDING THIS YEAR
THANKS A LOT YOU'RE FROM THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
NOW WITH THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND THE LOCAL
PLANNING COUNCIL WHICH IS HOUSED
AT THE COUNTY [inaudible]
THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON A HOUSE ABOUT
WITH UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA --
I JUST WANTED TO QUICKLY EXPRESS
THE GRATITUDE OF OUR STATEWIDE
NETWORK.
OF LOCAL UNITED WAYS FOR THIS
JOINT COMMITTEE AND LEADERSHIP A
KEY PRIORITY OF OUR MEMBERS AND
IS INVESTING IN THE EARLY YEARS
OF CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
THE SCIENCE AND DATA PRESENTED
TODAY -- IN
ADDITION TO WHAT HAS BEEN IN THE
NEWS LATELY I REALLY BEARS OUT
WHAT WE SO WHAT WE HAVE ALWAYS
INTUITIVELY KNOWN --
CHILDREN DO BETTER THEY THRIVE
WHEN THEY'RE SUPPORTED EARLY --
AND UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA
AND AGAIN OUR MEMBERS STAND --
AS PARTNERS REALLY CLOSELY ON
QUALITY IN CAPACITY SO
CALIFORNIA CANISTER PUBLISH
ITSELF AS A NATIONAL LEADER --
AS GOVERNOR NEWSOME
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND AND TO
THE MEMBERS OF THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE HAVE RIGHTLY CALLED US
TO DO TOGETHER SO I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WHAT ARE
HAPPY TO PARTNER IN ANY WAY IN
THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN HEREBY ARE ON
PICKING HIS CELL AND I'VE
TRAVELED FROM STANFORD GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION RIGHT
DIRECTION EARLIER IN PROJECT
THERE --
BECAUSE I WANTED TO THANK YOU IN
PARTICULAR OF MR MCCARTY FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA --
IT'S A TODAY I'M JUST GOING TO
MENTION THAT I BEGAN MY CAREER
AS A TEACHER'S AIDE.
IN HEAD START CUSTOM CUSTOM IN
THE EAST HARLEM.
AND FROM THERE MY CAREER PATH
TOOK ME TO OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
OF TO HARVEST TO YALE AND NOW TO
STAND.
FOR SO CAREER PATHWAYS ARE
POSSIBLE AND PEOPLE LIKE YOU
MAKE THAT POSSIBLE SO THANK YOU --
I WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT I
SUPPORT COMPLETELY MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE DR FREEBIES OF REMARKS
TO YOU AS WELL AS THOSE OFSERRA
NEVER MORGAN.
ENDEARING GABLE ALL OF THIS IS
TOTALLY COMPLETE.
AND STARTED FEE HAS PROVED TO
YOUTH IS ALSO AN ADDITIONAL
OLDER STUDY CONDUCTED AT A VERY
LARGE SCALE IN CHICAGO.
WHICH SHOWS THE SAME RESULTS SO
THAT POINT IS NOW DONE WE CAN
SHOW THAT LONG TERM GAINS DO
OCCUR FROM THESE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS.
SECONDLY --
WHAT MATTERS IN ADDITION IS
TEACHERS WITH THESE DEGREES
THESE BA DEGREES THAT HAVE EARLY
CHILDHOOD SPECIALIZATIONS?
AND THE LINDA DARLING HAMMOND OF
WHO HAS BEEN A PROFESSOR AT
STANFORD AND IT'S NOW BEEN
RECENTLY APPOINTED THE PRESIDENT.
OF THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
A AND HER COLLEAGUES CONDUCTED A
VERY EXTENSIVE SYNTHESIS OF THE
RESEARCH ON THIS ISSUE.
AND SHE CONCLUDED AND I QUOTE.
PK TEACHERS WHO HAVE EARNED
BACHELOR'S DEGREES AND HAVE
ADDITIONAL SPECIALIZED TRAINING
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
HAVE GENERALLY BEEN FOUND TO BE
MORE EFFECTIVE.
THAN THOSE WITHOUT THESE
QUALIFICATIONS.
THE NURSES TO FOR EDUCATION
EARLY EDUCATION RESEARCH A WITCH
DOCTOR FREE AS YOU KNOW IS CO
CHAIR.
HAS ALSO CONDUCTED AN EXCELLENT
META ANALYSIS WHICH FOUND THAT
CHILDREN WHOSE TEACHERS HAD
EARLY CHILDHOOD BACHELORS
DEGREES.
ACHIEVED BETTER SIR COGNITIVE
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL OUTCOMES.
SO AGAIN I THINK ON THIS POINT
TO BE OF THE GENIUS OF YOUR
APPROACH OF MISTER CARTY AND
THOSE OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
IS THAT YOU'RE NOT JUST FOCUSING
ON THE ACQUISITION OF A
SPECIALIZED DEGREE.
BUT YOUR UNDERSTANDING THE
INTERNET INTO.
BETWEEN COMPENSATION SO RESEARCH
ALSO SHOWS THE CALIFORNIA PK
TEACHERS.
UP IN NINETEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EARNED SIXTEEN DOLLARS
IN NINETEEN CENTS PER HOUR WHAT
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS EARNED
THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS AND THIRTY
THREE CENTS PER HOUR STILL NOT
ENOUGH.
BUT THAT THE GAP IS ENORMOUS ARE
CHIPPING GAP IS UNDOUBTEDLY
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THIS KIND OF
SELLING CAM IS WELL.
WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA YET BUT
WE COULD PRODUCE SAID I'M SURE
WITH THE RIGHT KIND OF RESEARCH.
SO THE FACT THAT YOU ARE TRYING
TO BRING COMPENSATION FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL TEACHERS.
CLOSER TO THAT LEVEL EXPERIENCE
BY TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS IS TO BE
UTTERLY COMMENDED.
UP THERE'S BEEN ONE OF THING I
WANT TO SAY THIS BUT A LOT OF
TALK TO THIS MORNING ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTY OF LOOKING OUT OVER
THE LONG TERM. FOR OUR RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IS RESEARCH DONE THAT
I THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL TO YOU
MISTER CARTY AT CORNELL BY
PROFESSOR NAY MILDRED WARNER --
THAT WHO IS HAS A PROJECT.
FOR LINKING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN CHILD CARE RESEARCH.
AND IN THAT PROJECT SHE SHOWS
THAT --
ACROSS ALL FIFTY STATES BUT
PARTICULAR EVERY DOLLAR THAT YOU
INVEST IN CHILDCARE AND OF
COURSE THAT WOULD APPLY TO PK'S
WELL.
TRANSLATES INTO TWO DOLLARS
INCREASE ECONOMIC WELL IN A
PARTICULAR REGION OR IN STATE
WELL I'LL TAKE THE EGGMAN SEVEN
DOLLARS OVER THERE.
I'M SORRY THIS IS MORE IMMEDIATE
YEAH OKAY THIS IS NOT TO DENY
THAT THE ALONG THE OF THE ONE
ONE HALF AND HALF ASKED TO WRAP
IT UP TO YES I THINK SO BUT YOU
GET.
WHAT I'M SAYING TO YOU IS THAT
YOU CAN GET BOTH THE ONE TO
SEVEN AND THE WANTED TO THIS IS
JUST BEEN PARTICULAR AREA
RESEARCH HAS BEEN NOT VERY WELL
KNOWN YET?
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ADAM
NORTH OF EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. TO HEARING THESE
ISSUES TODAY THANK YOU TO ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO SPOKE IN
FAVOR OF THESE I INVESTMENTS AND
HE'S ISSUES WERE LOOK AT TODAY --
WE'RE VERY EXCITED AS OTHERS
HAVE EXPRESSED BEFORE ME THAT
CALIFORNIA IS MAKING OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS --
PRIORITY --
WE ENTHUSIASTICALLY IN SUPPORT
OF COURSE IS PROCESS AND WE WANT
EVERYONE TO STAY MINDFUL OF THE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND LOOK
TO BUILD UPON THE SUCCESSES.
AND ESPECIALLY EXPANDING ACCESS
TO THESE HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS --
AT EVERY CAL CALIFORNIA WE OF
COURSE STAND IN IN THESE YEAH
SICK OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
ANYONE AND PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND
CLEAN THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS UP
ALL A I AM A PRESCHOOL SPECIAL
ED TEACHER.
AND I WERE FOR BERRYESSA UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THIS IS MY
TENTH YEAR.
WITH THE DISTRICT OF BY ABOUT
THIRTY TO FORTY YEARS EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH PRESCHOOL SPECIAL
AT SUCH AS MEDICAL OF NOTES HERE
AND I JUST WAS HOPING TO KIND OF
CLEAR YOU'RE WORKING AS A
PRESCHOOL AND YOU HAVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
A YOU NEED A MASTERS TO DO THAT
JOB ACTUALLY AND IT'S A DISTRICT --
YOU GET HIRED BY THE DISTRICT SO
I AM PART OF CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO --
I HAD ALL THESE THINGS ON MY
MIND OF A JUST A BLACK.
SO.
PART OF THE THING THAT I'M
REALLY REALLY OF MINDFUL OF IS
THE TERM ALL BECAUSE A LOT OF
TIMES WE SAID ALL BUT IN OUR
MIND WE'RE THINKING OF
EVERYTHING BUT SPECIAL ED.
AND SPECIAL IT TENDS TO KIND OF
GO IS THAT AFTER THOUGHT SO
WE'RE MISSING ALL I THINK ONE OF
THE WAYS WE COULD REALLY HELP
ALL PRE SCHOOL STUDENTS.
IS TO HAVE INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOL
WITHIN THE DISTRICTS AND PUT IN
MONEY FOR THAT BECAUSE IF YOU
LEAVE IT TO THE DISTRICT THEY
WILL SAY THEY DON'T HAVE MONEY
I'VE APPROACH MY DISTRICT MANY
TIMES.
WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT IDEAS OF
HOW TO HAVE INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOLS
AND IT DOESN'T GET ANYWHERE.
I KNOW THAT SANTA CLARA UNIVERSE
ARE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
ED HAD A REALLY GREAT PROGRAM ON
INCLUSIVE COLLABORATION AND HOW
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN --
AND I THINK AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WHEN WE LOOK AT OF FOR THE LEGAL
THINGS A FOR FREE.
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC EDUCATION I
DO BELIEVE THAT INCLUSIVE
COLLABORATION GOES INTO THAT I
STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORT HAVING
TEACHERS.
WITH -- OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD UNITS OF AND I
DO THINK THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER WITH THAT.
AS FAR AS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO I DO THINK
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE REALLY
ISN'T PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS --
AND THE RESIDENT OF
COLLABORATION TIME EITHER BUT I
DO BELIEVE THAT IF WE HAVE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IT
SHOULD SOLELY FOCUS OUR EARLY
CHILDHOOD ISSUES WHETHER IT'S
OUR IN EARLY CHILDHOOD OR
WHATEVER IT IS --
THANK YOU ATTACK INVEST OKAY
WELL THAT'S GOOD BUT I MEAN MOST
OF MY POINTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT COIL.
I AM A PARENT OF FIVE OF THE
SITE THREE VOICE.
AND I AM.
SIGH I THAT'S OKAY AT THE DOES
MY FIRST TIME TO WANNA DOING
GREAT ONE OF THE I AM A PARENT
AT CONTAINER IN NAM.
CASTLE MINE IT IS OAKLAND.
MY OLDEST ONE IS HIS NAME IS
ROBERT JUNIOR AND HE WILL IS A
FORMER [inaudible]
HEAD START [inaudible]
KID [inaudible]
AND WHEN HE WAS GOING THERE HE
WAS SHY AND WASN'T.
REALLY WANTED IT.
HANG OUT WITH MANY KIDS AND
DIDN'T NO IS ABC'S ALL ONE TWO
THREES.
BY NOW IT WAS SINCE HE BIT HE
WENT THERE HE'S DOING A GREAT
JOB AT HIS.
KIDDING OSCAR AT PARKER.
AND FOR LAST MONTH HE WAS A STAR
SOON FOR THREE WEEKS STRAIGHT
[inaudible]
BUT FOR MY MIDDLE CHILD DANTE.
HIS --
NICKNAME I GAVE HIM IS
BRAVEHEART.
HE NEVER REALLY HANG OUT WITH
ANY KIDS ALL SORTS YOU'RE A AND
HE'S.
WAS THE SHY TYPE.
N. F. ING.
PRETTY MUCH --
MY MY MIDDLE CHILD HE YOU NEVER
LIKE TO COMMUNICATE IF YOU TAKE
ONE LITTLE THING FOR MANY WAS.
LITERALLY SHUT DOWN ON YOU AND
DON'T WANT.
THE COMMUNIQUE I TALK TO YOU BUT
IT WAS SINCE HE BEEN GOING TO
THIS SCHOOL.
HE BEEN COMMUNICATING TALKING
FIS AND IF YOU TAKE IT DON'T
TAKEN TO A PARK RIGHT NOW LIKE
LITTLE OUTSIDE RIGHT NOW.
HE CAN.
BE FRIENDS WITH ANY KID ON A
PARK AND PLAY OF THEM
[inaudible]
AND I SEC.
GIVEN THE NICKNAME BRAVE I
BECAUSE I'M NOT THAT WAY I'M SHY.
THANK YOU.
FOR AND THEN MY THIRD AND FINAL
ONE HE IS ONE HIS NAME IS
WILLIAM AND HIS NICKNAME IS
NIGHTMARE BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
WE'LL GET INTO THAT LATER SOME
OTHER TIME.
BUT HE'S ONLY ONE BUT ONCE HE
TURNS EIGHTEEN HE WILL BE ABLE
TO GOING TO THE EARLY.
HEAD START AND I'LL BE HAPPY --
TO MAKE SURE HE GOES THERE.
AND I'M ALSO I'M A FORMER HIS
TOSSED K?T MYSELF YEAH.
WELL YOU'RE LUCKY BECAUSE A LOT
OF CALIFORNIA PARENTS WHO DON'T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEND
THEIR KIDS TO HEAD START
PROGRAMS AS WE ARE TRYING TO DO
SO THANK YOU.
AND ALSO IF I KNEW ABOUT THE ON
THESE PROGRAM HI OLDEST SON IN
THERE RIGHT AWAY BUT HE WAS.
ABLE TO GO AGAIN IN THE PROGRAM
AT THE AGE [inaudible]
ABOUT. FOR THREE AND A HALF SO
YOU DIDN'T GET THE EXPERIENCE
THE EARLY HEAD START BUT HE DID
GET EXPENSE THE HEAD START AND
LOOK.
LIKE WE HAVE THAT HE WAS ABLE TO
LINE IS A. B. C.'S AND NOW TO
START DOING THAT AT A SCHOOL AND
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL AND HAPPY
ABOUT THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING UP TODAY.
OF MY NAME IS MERRY GENERAL WIRE
FONG I'M A RETIRED PROFESSOR OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION I
WORKED AT AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE
PRIOR TO THAT I WAS A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER.
AND A DIRECTOR OF AN INFANT
CENTER OF THE STATE FUNDED
DEFERRED CENTER.
PROGRAM AND I HAVE ONE POINT TO
MAKE AND I THINK ROBERT LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR IT BEAUTIFULLY AS
HE DESCRIBED HIS HIS THREE
CHILDREN.
HE DESCRIBED A ONE YEAR OLD HE
DESCRIBED THE THREE AND A HALF
YEAR OLD IT DESCRIBES
KINDERGARTENERS AND I I WANT TO
MAKE ONE POINT AT I'VE BEEN
POURING THROUGH.
YOUR BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND AND OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO SPILL LOOKING AT
CHANGES HOW ARE WE GOING TO
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM FOR INFANTS
TODDLERS AND PRESCHOOLERS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK PUTS KIND OF A FUZZY BLUR
OVER EVERYTHING IS WHAT WE CALL
THESE PROGRAMS WE USE PRE K. WE
USE T. K. WE GET TO USE --
PRESCHOOL STAY PRESCHOOL WE TALK
ABOUT GENERAL CHILD CARE.
I THINK WE NEED TO PULL BACK AND
AND ASK WHO ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ROBERT'S
CHILDREN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHILDREN WHEN THEY'RE BORN.
UP TO THE POINT WHERE WHERE THEY
HIT ABOUT EIGHT YEARS OF AGE
THAT NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR
EDUCATION OF YOUNG CHILDREN
DESCRIBES EARLY CHILDHOOD AS
THAT CONTINUUM BIRTH.
TO EIGHT SO AS WE LOOK AT THE
LEGISLATION BEFORE US THE THE
THE WORK SAID THAT YOU HAVE --
BEFORE YOU WHICH IS WONDERFUL.
HOW DO WE NOT A BIRTH TO EIGHT
PROJECT HERE --
EVERY CHILD DESERVES A WELL
PREPARED WELL PAID TEACHER.
WHETHER THAT CHILD IS ONE MONTH
OLD ONE YEAR OLD THREE YEARS
OLDER FIVE YEAR OLD.
AND HAVING WORKED IN OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION DONE A LOT
OF CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT DONE A
LOT OF PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO FIT
EVERYTHING THAT YOU REALLY KNOW
TO BE THAT FULLY PREPARED
TEACHER IN TO TWENTY FOUR UNITS
AND THAT'S WHAT AN A A DEGREE IS.
IF YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO BE HAVE
A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE IT'S
GOING TO MATCH BUT BE MUCH
BETTER.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT EACH OF THOSE
BILLS LOOK VERY CAREFULLY AT HOW
WE CAN PRESERVE THE RIGHT OF
EVERY CHILD BE THEY AN INFANT
TODDLER OR A THREE TO FIVE YEAR
OLD. TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
PEDAGOGICAL SUPPORT OF A FULLY
PREPARED TEACHER WITH A
BACCALAUREATE LEVEL WITH
SPECIALTY IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION THERE IS A WAY WE CAN
DO IT THAT IS COST EFFECTIVE
WITHIN THE HIGHER AND WE DO NOT
PREPARE A WORKFORCE. FOR THREE
TO FIVE YEAR OLDS.
AND THAT'S NOT IF WE IF YOU WANT
US TO DO THAT THAT'S IT NOT COST
EFFECTIVE WE PREPARE A WORKFORCE
FOR BIRTH TO EIGHT YEAR OLDS.
SO GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO TO FIND A CAREER PATHWAY SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN BE WELL.
PAID FOR THE PREPARATION THAT
THEY RENDER DID THEY BRING FOR
THE THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ON
A RICH ARRAY YES.
I'M A PRESCHOOL TEACHER FOR
SIXTEEN YEAR IT AND CENTER
DIRECTOR FORGET ANGLE PUSH
SECURITY AND A FIGHT TO PROVIDE
SERVICE FOR TWELVE YEARS.
IN MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
BEING A MOTHER OF TWO BOYS TRY
NOT I'VE BEEN HOME FOR SIX ONE
NIGHT IN A WHAT TO DO.
UNLUCKY I HAVE A FRIEND WORKING
A PRETTY COOL PROGRAM THOUGHT ME
OKAY YOU CAN COME IN OUR PROGRAM
AND IN THE THE OWNER AND YOU CAN
TALK TO HER IF YOU CAN GET
PRETTY PRESCHOOL.
AND THE OWNER TOLD ME OKAY YOU
COLD WAR COULD ACT AND THE SAME
THING YOU GOT 50% OFF.
SO FROM THAT.
PERSPECTIVE I REALIZED ALL MY
GUYS TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
BECAUSE I DON'T MAY BE IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT.
AND IN THE FIRST FIVE IN A WHICH
AND OFFERED OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
A COURT.
LUCKILY I GOT UP WHAT YOU NEED
TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL AND A GREAT
MAY BE THE GREAT.
BUT IN THE LAST YEAR OF MY BA
DEGREE.
THE FUNDING IS GONNA TRY ENOUGH
HOBBY A COLLEGE FUND SO I FEEL
LIKE TO PAY FOR IT.
SO FOR ME THAT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO WE'RE WORKING
OUGHT TO HAVE A UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL BUT THE BURDEN FOR
MORE PEOPLE FOR OUR TEACHERS. TO
WORKING ON THE PUBLIC GOING TO
COLLEGE I'M FORTUNATE THAT
WORKING TO TANGO THAT THREE OF
MY TEACHER WORKING WITH ME THEY
ARE DEBATE AGREE.
SO THAT IS THE BEST SUPPORT FOR
OUT.
AND IT'S A FIGHT IF YOU CAN DO
THAT BECAUSE WHAT DID ACROSS THE
BOARD ACROSS CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTING OUR TEACHER.
SECONDLY I WANT TO MENTION LIKE.
OUR TEACHER NEED A LOT OF
SUPPORT AND IF YOU CAN SUPPORT
THE BETTER I TYPE OF COLLEGE
EDUCATION I THINK THE MORE
IMPORTANT.
THE WANTED TO TOLERATE I KNOW
WITH THE DENVER AND A WHAT FOR
PRIDE WHEN YOU TOLD ME.
THAT ARE THERE PUBLIC SCHOOL THE
THE TEACHER FROM PRESCHOOL
ALTHOUGH IT TOOK EIGHT TO TWELVE
DEBATE ATTEMPTING. TO A
CALIFORNIA DURINGTHAT THE BACK
BECAUSE RIGHT THE CHILDREN
BECAUSE SOME OF THE KIDS DO NOT
EVEN QUALIFY FOR EARLY HEAD
START THE PROGRAM OR EVEN THE
FRIDGE COLD.
AND WORKING IN THE HEAD START
PROGRAM AND WORKING IN A TAPE
RECORDER LE PEN CAM DEMENTED ALL
CRICKET GLITTER ALL COMING TO
QUANTIFY IT EVEN A FIFTY DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE. HUNDRED DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE BUT IF WE HOPE YOU
BURKE TOLD FREE SCHOOL IT CAN
HAUL HELP ACROSS THE BOARD ALL
OF OUR CHILDREN AND WE KNOW WHAT
THE BENEFIT FOR THEM.
I'M IT CAN BE DIFFICULT AND
STARTED MY OWN KIDS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN ASIA AND I
AM A PARENT FIRST AND I'M ALSO A
PRESCHOOL EDUCATOR FOR KIDDING
GO -- I IN
MY CAP MONICA TO ME IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA.
SO I WAS GONNA COME UP HERE AND
I WAS IN THE TALK ABOUT HOW.
BEING A PARENT IS --
IS ONE OF THE MOST AWESOME
THINGS THE BENEFITS THAT THE
PROGRAM HAD MAY FROM MY CHILD
CHASING I'M BAKER HE IS STILL.
IN THE PROGRAM HE HAS BEEN THERE
SINCE HE WAS TWO AND NINE MONTHS --
BUT I CAN'T I CAN'T TALK ABOUT
HIM WITHOUT TALKING ABOUT BEING
AN EDUCATOR I CAN'T TALK ABOUT
HIM WITHOUT TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT THAT MEANS WHAT QUALITY IS
WHAT THE QUALITY EDUCATOR ON
WHAT THE CALL QUALITY PROGRAM
AND?
HOW DO YOU GET THAT?
OF MY FIRST POINT WOULD BE
INVESTMENTS.
I DIDN'T GET THE JOB WITH COULD
ANGLE BASED ON WHAT I WAS
QUALIFIED TO DO I GOT THE JOB
BASED ON WHAT WAS ON MY RESUME.
IT WHAT MY RESUME SAID.
CANANGA QUALIFIED TO BE A LEAD
TEACHER THEY INVESTED IN ME THEY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SCHOOLING THEY PROVIDED A CgA
GO TO SO IF YOU'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT QUALITY LOW QUALITY MEETS
ITS INVESTMENTS.
SO INVEST IN TO YOUR TEACHER
INVESTED TO THE EDUCATION
INVESTMENT FOR THE FUTURE THANK
YOU THANK.
I HAVE TO RAISE THIS A LITTLE
BIT HERE --
MY NAME IS PAUL AMERICAN I MET
HAD THE PLEASURE OF MEETING
SENATOR THAT'S GETTING A
SUPPLEMENT.
MCCARTY I ALSO WAS ON THE EARLY
AGE TOUR ON THE EAST COAST --
I WAS THE ONLY TEACHER THERE SO
IT WAS NICE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE --
ESSAY AND HAVE PEOPLE LISTEN
BECAUSE EDUCATORS OFTEN LINK WE
ARE NOT LISTEN.
TO SO THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING --
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING EARLY
CHILDHOOD A NINE JUST TELL IT TO
GROUP THE YOUR TICKET TEACHER
TAMMY T. PAY TEACHER.
AND HOW MANY KIDS ARE IN YOUR
CLASSROOM --
A WEEK AGO I HAD TWENTY SIXTH
HOW -- TO
ONE IT'S ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES
THAT WE WE TALKED ABOUT ON THE
EAST COAST TO OUR IS THE
STOCKING RATIO WITH. EIGHTEEN TO
ONE TEACHER AND ONE FULL TIME
PARA PROFESSIONAL.
NOT TWENTY FIVE NOT --
TWENTY SIX NOT THIRTY THIRTY
THREE IN SOME INSTANCES AS YOU
WERE STANDING DOCTOR FRIEDEL IT
SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE A PRETTY
SORRY.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR THAT
STAFFING RATIO TO BE MAINTAINED.
BECAUSE THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
TO CLIENTS I CANNOT MEET ALL OF
MY STUDENTS MEETINGS AT EVERY
MOMENT BECAUSE THIS JUST ME.
I HAVE TO SAY HOLD ON I'LL BE
WITH YOU IN A MINUTE HOLD ON
HOLD ON HOLD ON AND THAT DOESN'T
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT WHEN YOU
TEACH EARLY CHILDHOOD.
OFTENTIMES LEARNING DISABILITIES
ARE NOT DISCUSS --
IN THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
AND THAT THAT REQUIRES MORE OF
YOUR TIME.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
TO THE FOREFRONT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT --
WE HOPE YOU CONSIDER WHEN YOU
CREATE WHAT IT GOES FURTHER
HAVING ACTUAL CAPS THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CANNOT SAY WELL YOUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
SAYS YOU CAN HAVE THIRTY KIDS.
SO THEREFORE YOU GOT THIRTY
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THEY SAID AT
THE ASSEMBLY AT THE SENATE.
SO.
THINGS THAT YOU PUT INTO PLACE
DISTRICTS HAVE TO FOLLOW WOULD
BENEFIT ALL KIDS.
AND NOT HAVE THAT LITTLE
LOOPHOLE THAT SO MANY THINGS
FALL THROUGH RIGHT NOW WITH AND
WHATEVER YOUR CBA SAYS IS WHAT
IS THE LAW.
PLEASE REMEMBER THAT AS YOU
PROGRESS ON THIS AND ALSO --
WHEN I WHAT ONE OF THE THINGS?
I WANT TO BRING YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE VOICE ON NEW YORK CITY
WAS THERE WAS A RUSH TO PUT ALL
THIS MONEY BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR
WANTED IT.
PUT A LOT OF MONEY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE HOPE WAS
THAT WILL STILL CONTINUE TO COME.
SO THAT'S A CONCERN AS WE LOOK
AT WHERE WE GONNA PUT THESE
CHILDREN PRESCHOOL FOR ALL FOUR
YEAR OLDS IS FANTASTIC WHERE WE
CAN HAVE THEM --
WE WANT QUALITY PROGRAMS NOT
JUST DAY CARE AND I KNOW FOR C.
T. A. AS CHAIR ON CHAIR OF THEIR
FOR THE CHILD EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FOR CTA --
TO WE DON'T WANT THEM JUST IN
SOME.
PROGRAM THE HEAD START PROGRAMS
WE SAW WERE PHENOMENAL AND I
KNOW THOSE ARE FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAMS I'M SURE THEY'RE THE
SAME IN CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT
BENEFITED FROM BEING IN --
ONE THE THE FISH HAVE TAKEN
NOTES LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE DID
THE THE FOR THE I'M TRYING I'M
DRAWN A BLANK GET UP HERE AND I
GET ALL FLUSTERED.
BY -- BUT
THE THE THE HIGH QUALITY FEDERAL
PROGRAMS WHERE THEY HAVE THE
CURRICULUM WHAT WE SAW NEW YORK
NEW JERSEY AND BOSTON.
WAS THAT THEY ALL HAD CURRICULUM
THAT WENT THROUGH ALL THE GRADES
PRESCHOOL.
THE THREE YEAR OLD THE FOUR YEAR
OLD THE FIVE YEAR OLD'S.
IN KINDERGARTEN AND THEY WERE
ALL USING THE SAME TYPE OF
CURRICULUM IF THEY WERE DOING
ENGINEERING AND AS A THREE YEAR
OLD THEY WERE DOING ENGINEERING
IS A FOUR YEAR OLD THEY WERE
DOING ENGINEERING THE FIBRIL
DIDN'T MATTER WHAT SCHOOL WE
WERE IN.
THEY WERE LEARNING THE SAME DEEP
THINKING IDEAS IT WASN'T JUST
YOU'RE GOING TO SIT OVER HERE
AND PLAY WITH BLOCKS THERE WAS
IN A MEETING BEHIND THE PLAYING
WITH THE BLOCKS.
AND AND THAT'S SO IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT SOMETHING FOR ALL
FOUR YEAR OLDS I WOULDN'T WANT
MY CHILD JUST BE CHECKED IN
ACCORD WITH BLOCKS.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
DO I WANT TO QUALITY EDUCATION
SO AS YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS
PRESCHOOL FOR ALL WHAT IS WATER
ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS GONNA DO.
I HOPE WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
THE HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION FOR
THIS FOUR YEAR OLDS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON DEBORAH BROWN
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW AT
THANK YOU AND MISS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH AND AND YOU'RE AT
THE COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS HEARING
AND GIVING US A I GUESS A SMALL
A SMALL PEEK INTO YOUR
COLLECTIVE EXPERIENCES.
ON THE TRIP LOOKING AT OTHER I'M
LOOKING AT PROGRAMS IN OTHER
STATES IS OBVIOUSLY WISDOM AND
GETTING BEST PRACTICES FROM THAT
SO THESE DEEPER DIVES ON BEST
PRACTICES AND ARE ESPECIALLY
TIMELY AND CRITICAL --
AS WE LOOK AT THE ISSUES BEFORE
US DEFINITIONS OF QUALITY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FACILITIES
SCALE AND FUNDING ARE KEY
DECISION POINTS THAT STATE
LEADERS AGENCIES AND ADVOCATES.
NEED TO CAREFULLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY NEGOTIATE HOW DID
HOW THESE DECISIONS IMPACT THE
REST OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SYSTEM ESPECIALLY
INFANT TODDLER CARE MUST ALSO BE
CONSIDERED IF DONE RIGHT
PRESCHOOL EXPANSION CAN BE A
DRIVER TO MOVE. TO A MORE
COHESIVE QUALITY CHILD CARE
SYSTEM THAT TRANSLATES INTO
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT IN KEY
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIFETIMES A HIGHLY
EDUCATED AND PREPARED WORKFORCE
FOR THE FUTURE.
AND COST SAVINGS TO EDUCATION
AND OTHER SOCIAL SYSTEMS OVERALL
SPECIFICALLY RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
CERTAIN COURSE STRUCTURAL AND
PROGRAMMATIC ELEMENTS STRIVE IN
REACHING INTERACTIONS BETWEEN
YOUNG CHILDREN AND ADULTS
INCLUDING LOW ADULT CHILD RATIOS
WELL TRAINED CARE GIVERS.
TEACHERS AND DIRECTORS SO LIKE
OTHER STATES CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
GRAPPLE WITH THESE COMPONENTS
AND LAND ON HIGHER STANDARDS OF
QUALIFICATIONS CONNECTED TO
EQUIVALENT COMPENSATION AND
BUILD IN FROM THE ON SET THE
RESOURCES THAT WILL NEED.
AT THAT WILL BE NEEDED TO
TRANSITION OVER TIME AIMING HIGH
AND RAMPING UP IS POSSIBLE AND
GIVEN THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN A TARGETED
APPROACH TO UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE.
THOSE CHILDREN POVERTY TO
LANGUAGE LEARNERS FOSTER YOUTH
ANOTHER SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES
HAVE INCREASE TAXES FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
THIS YEAR OFFERS A FRIEND ASH
FOUNDATIONAL OPPORTUNITY NOT
JUST PLAN OR CHIP AWAY AT
ADDITIONAL PRESCHOOL SPACES BUT
TO LEVERAGE THE PROPOSED ONE
TIME FUNDS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND FACILITIES. TO
SET MARKERS FOR A LARGER VISION
AND MAKE STRIDES PREVENT IN A
SYSTEMIC WAY THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY FOR BOTH PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE EXPANSION THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI I'M NAOMI UNDER A SECOND WITH
THE LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE
WHERE WE SPENT QUITE A BIT OF
TIME LOOKING AT EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION BOTH IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN OTHER STATES.
I BROUGHT A COUPLE OF OUR BRIEF
THAT ARE RELEVANT TO THE
CONVERSATION TODAY TO SHARE WITH
YOU BUT I WANTED TO ALSO VERY
QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT SOME OF OUR
FINDINGS. ONE IS THAT IN THE
STATE'S WE'VE LOOKED AT WHERE
THEY'VE EXPANDED THEIR SYSTEMS
WITH GOOD OUTCOMES FOR BOTH
CHILDREN AND EDUCATORS.
THEY PRIORITIZE QUALITY AND
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT FROM THE
START.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN NORTH CAROLINA
THEY FOCUSED FIRST ON HIGH
QUALITY STANDARDS BY CREATING A
STATEWIDE QUALITY RATING AN
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM OR Q. R. I.
S..
AND THAT ALLOWS THEM TO DO
THINGS LIKE IMPLEMENT MORE
APPROPRIATE ADULT TO CHILD
RATIOS AND ALSO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO GOOD AT TEACHING ASSESSMENTS
AND CURRICULUM FOR THEIR
PROVIDERS.
IN ADDITION ALL OF THEIR STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS ARE REQUIRED TO
PARTICIPATE IN Q. R. S. AND THEY
HAVE TO MEET A MINIMUM THRESHOLD
OF QUALITY BEFORE THEY CAN GET
LICENSE.
THE OTHER POINT I WANT TO MAKE
FROM OUR RESEARCH IS THAT
LEADING STATES HAVE REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE IMPROVEMENT PART
OF Q. R. I. S..
BY PROVIDING COACHES TO HELP
THEIR PROVIDERS MEET THOSE
HIGHER STANDARDS AND ALSO BY
SUPPORTING EDUCATOR DEVELOPMENT
BY DOING THINGS LIKE PROVIDING
TEACHING STIPENDS.
AND SALARY SUPPLEMENTS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL COACHING FOR BOTH
VETERAN AND NEW TEACHERS IT'S
KIND OF SIMILAR TO INDUCTION AND
OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM.
THAT KIND OF SYSTEMATIC
INVESTMENTS IN EDUCATOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
INSTRUCTIONAL COACHING PRODUCES
BETTER PREPARED EDUCATORS AND
THAT'S BEEN LINKED TO IMPROVED
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN.
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ONLY
14% OF ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS HAD
ACCESS TO CURIOUS FUNDING WHICH
CAN SUPPORT THOSE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES --
BUT THE BRIGHT SPOT HERE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S AND USEFUL CURIOUS
SUPPORTS THAT COULD BE SCALED.
AND OBVIOUSLY YOU ALREADY
RECOGNIZE THIS GIVEN THE TOPIC
OF THE HEARING BUT THERE ARE
THINGS WE COULD POTENTIALLY
LEARN FROM THE EXAMPLE SET OTHER
STATES HAVE SAT.
FORD --
IMPLEMENTING THESE POSITIVE
PRACTICES STATEWIDE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING MY NAME IS
ANNA LOUISE BENITO I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA RULING CAN HEALTH
BOARD AND THE DIRECTOR OF TRIBAL
HEADSTART PROGRAMS AND TRAVEL.
THE CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS OF THAT EIGHTEEN TRIBES
FOR THE DEVELOPMENTAL PART AND
THREE TRIBES FOR HEAD START NOW
WE'RE A LITTLE DIFFERENT IN OUR
PERSPECTIVE OF HOW WE SEE THIS
BILL GOING FORWARD. ONE OF
THINGS THAT.
COMMON GROUND THAT WE ALL HAVE
IS THAT DEVELOPMENT PART.
NOT ONLY GETTING TEACHERS TO GET
THE CREDENTIALS WE RECEIVE TRUE
FEDERAL FUNDING OR LIMITED JUST
IN MY AREA.
WE HAVE BEEN STALEMATED AT THE
FOR THE LAST SEVENTEEN YEARS
THAT MEANS IF I WANT TO PAY MY
TEACHERS MORE.
WE CANNOT THAT'S SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA CAN AFFORD TO DO.
BUT MY ATTRITION RATE IS FORCED
TEACHERS.
VERY MINIMAL MAYBE MAYBE 2%
LEAVE ME.
AND THAT'S NOT BAD BECAUSE WE DO
OTHER INCENTIVES WE ALLOW THEM
TO GO TO SCHOOL AND HAVE TIME
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
YOU BUILD THESE THINGS UP.
YOU TALK SOMEWHERE IN THERE
ABOUT MAYBE DO.
LOCAL COLLEGES THAT TRAIN
TEACHERS WHETHER IT'S THE BE A
OR THE A A THAT THEY HAVE SOME
SORT OF AGREEMENT WITH THE LOCAL.
PRE K. OR IN THIS SYSTEM MAYBE
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT THEY
CAN DO THE PRACTICUM THERE AND
THAT WOULD BE FOR TEACHERS.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY ALREADY THERE
HAVE THE EXPERIENCE.
YOU CANNOT TEACH EARLY EDUCATION
THE SOMEONE WHO WALKS OFF THE
STREET WOULD JUST TO BE A I'M
TELLING YOU THIS FROM EXPERIENCE
I GOT MY POLY SCI BE A AS WELL.
IN MY LAW DEGREE WALKING IN AS A
DIRECTOR OF THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS.
THE CURVE IS HARD SO YOU'VE GOT
A RIGHT NOT IT'S NOT UNDOABLE
BUT IF YOU REALLY WANT QUALITY.
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE YOU'VE
GOT THOSE IN THERE --
ALSO WE PUT MY GLASSES ON
BECAUSE OF REACH THAT AGE --
IN THE YOU ALSO TALK ABOUT YEAH
IT'S THE BENEFIT FOR THE
CHILDREN MOST DEFINITELY.
CONTINUITY.
COMING FROM THESE PROGRAMS MANY
OF OUR FAMILIES DO NOT HAVE THE
CONTINUITY TO HOW THE FULL DAY
THIS WOULD BE IF THIS COULD BE
THE FOLDING.
YOU WERE GOING TO REDUCE COSTS
FOR THOSE PARENTS WHO HAVE TO DO
THE PRE K. AND THEN TAKE THEM
ELSEWHERE.
THE COST ALONE CAN RANGE
ANYWHERE BETWEEN PART TIME.
AS LOW AS MAYBE FIFTY SIX
HUNDRED WITH MUCH AS TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND A YEAR IN CHILD CARE.
TO LAUNCH IN IF THE MINIMUM WAGE
AND THESE ARE JUST OLD NUMBERS I
HAVE.
OF WHEN THEY'RE MAKING ELEVEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR I THINK IT WAS
LIKE THIRTEEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY IS WHAT A FAMILY
WOULD BRING IN.
BUT YOU HAVE TO PAY.
FIVE THOUSAND WORDS THE REST FOR
YOUR RENT.
IT'S THINKING ABOUT THOSE THINGS
THAT MAKE IT A POSITIVE IF YOU
DO THIS ALL AND LASTLY
[inaudible]
THINK [inaudible]
OF HELLO.
WHEN YOU WRITE LEGISLATION LIKE
THIS SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE
PLEASE INCLUDE THE WORD TRIBES?
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW EVERYTHING IS
DONE BY STATUTE AND IF WE DON'T
HAVE AN IN STATUTE SOMETIMES OF
PARTNERSHIPS AND WE'VE BEEN
LUCKY THAT WE DO WORK WITH.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
DURING A MILIEU.
BUT WE NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
SOMETHING.
THREE HELLO.
MY NAME IS SUSAN MONCHO I'M WITH
AMERICAN INSTITUTE FOR RESEARCH
AND SENSE.
THE TOPIC OF SOME OF OUR STUDIES
CAME UP TODAY I THOUGHT I WOULD
JUST -- TRY
TO CLOSE THE LOOP --
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR FOCUS ON QUALITY.
SO OFTEN WHEN THE TOPIC OF
PRESCHOOL COMES UP.
THE MAIN FOCUS IS ACCESS.
AND THE QUESTION IS ACCESS TO
WHAT.
AND YOU'RE ASKING THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
ELS CHAIRMAN MCCARTY MENTIONED.
THE LAST TIME THAT THERE WAS
REALLY AN ESTIMATE OF UNMET NEED.
FOR PRESCHOOL IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A ARE FOUND
THAT THERE WERE. THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLDS ELIGIBLE --
FOR STATE PRESCHOOL WHO WERE NOT
IN HEAD START STATE PRESCHOOL OR
PRE K..
AND ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND THREE YEAR OLDS.
AND WE WERE REALLY LOOKING NOT
JUST AT ALL CHILDREN IN LICENSE
CARE BUT WE TRIED TO LOOK AT THE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS THE CLOSEST. TO THE
NEAR STANDARDS SO WE LOOKED AT
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN IN STATE
PRESCHOOL THE NUMBER IN HEAD
START.
AND THE NUMBER IN TWO U. K..
IF WE HAVE.
NOT RESTRICTED TO THE QUALITY
THAT LEVEL OF QUALITY.
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN SERVE
MIGHT HAVE LOOKED BETTER. TO
LEGISLATORS MIGHT OF BEEN A
NICER NUMBER OF A SMALLER NUMBER.
BUT THE POINT IS EVEN THOSE
THREE PROGRAMS DON'T MEET THE
STANDARDS A DOCTOR PRETTY.
DESCRIBED.
SO THAT WAS SORT OF OUR OUR BASE.
AND WE WILL BE WORKING ON A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
THAT IS PART OF THE FEDERAL
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT THAT
CALIFORNIA.
ONE AND THAT NEEDS ASSESSMENT IS
GOING TO TAKE IN NOT ONLY THE
ISSUES THAT I MENTIONED BEFORE.
BUT ALSO THE UNMET NEED FOR
FACILITIES --
ALSO JUST WANTED.
TO MENTION SOMETHING ABOUT T. K.
SENSE THAT HAS COME UP.
THE STUDY THAT A. I. R. DID OF
TKD DID INDEED FIND THE CHILDREN
NTK.
WERE -- HAD
BETTER [inaudible]
OUTCOMES THAN CHILDREN IN GARDEN
VARIETY PRESCHOOL 80% OF THE
CHILDREN IN THE CONTROL GROUP
WERE IN PRESCHOOL [inaudible]
BUT NOT NECESSARILY HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL.
AND THE OTHER THING ABOUT THAT
STUDY IS THAT THE CHILDREN IN
TWO K..
WERE -- THE
CLASS SIZE AT THE TIME THAT WE
DID THE STUDY THE AVERAGE CLASS
SIZE WAS.
SEVENTEEN AND SOME OF THE QUITE
OF I CAN'T REMEMBER FOR WAS
THIRD OF ABOUT A THIRD OF THE
CLASSROOMS DID HAVE A PARA
PROFESSIONAL FOR PART OF THE DAY.
TO SUPPLEMENT.
THE TEACHER SO I THINK THAT'S
JUST.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU'RE
CONSIDERING --
CHANGING THE STAFF CHILD RATIO
FORTY K. AT THE SAME TIME THAT
YOU'RE CONSIDERING UPGRADING
STATE PRESCHOOL.
ARM FINALLY.
JUST A WORD OF ENCOURAGEMENT.
IT'S ALWAYS A WORK TO DO THAT --
ABOUT.
I THINK NEARLY A DECADE AGO.
A. R. DID A STUDY OF A PRESCHOOL
FOR ALL PROJECT.
YES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS IN SAN MATEO COUNTY.
AND IT WAS FUNDED BY FIRST FIVE
SAN MATTEO AND FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT THE FOUND.
WAS WHAT THE GOAL OF THAT
PROGRAM.
WAS EXACTLY WHAT --
I THINK YOU'RE NOW THINKING OF
DOING.
UPGRADINGTHE QUALITY OF SOME OF
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS LIKE STATE
PRESCHOOL AND HEAD START.
AND OVER A PERIOD OF YEARS.
THE TEACHERS THAT WERE THAT
GAINED EIGHTY EIGHT DEGREES --
THERE WAS A HIGHER REIMBURSEMENT
FOR THEM IT WENT DIRECTLY INTO
SALARIES.
AND THE SAME THING FOR THOSE
TEACHERS THAT GAINED OF A BA
DEGREE.
THEY HAD A HIGHER COMPENSATION
THAN -- THAN
THE OTHER TEACHERS --
THE THERE WAS AN EVALUATION OF
THE IMPROVEMENTS IN PROGRAM
QUALITY [inaudible]
SOME OF PEOPLE IN THE ROOM I'M
SURE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
CLASSROOM ASSESSMENT.
SCORING SYSTEM.
AND IT HAS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
MEASUREMENTS ONE OF THEM IS ON
INSTRUCTIONAL SUPPORT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A PRESCHOOL
CLASSROOM --
THAT IS THE MEASURE THAT SEEMS
TO BE MOST CORRELATED.
WITH --
ACADEMIC.
ACHIEVEMENT AS CHILDREN ENTER
SCHOOL AND NOR THE AVERAGE SCORE
AMOUNT IS TWO POINT SEVEN OUT OF
SEVEN WHEN ONE LOOKS IT OUT --
PRESCHOOLS BUT IN THE SAN MATTEO
PROJECT --
IT WAS OVER FIVE SO BASICALLY
TWICE AS GOOD AND THESE WERE
STATE PRESCHOOL AND HEAD START
TEACHERS PARTICIPATING AND THAT
PROGRAM.
THE KEY WAS.
THE SAME THING EVERYONE IS
SENATE WORKING TOWARD
QUALIFICATIONS IN A PHASED IN
WAY --
COMPENSATING HELPING THE
TEACHERS PROVIDING SO WERE WERE
AND GIVING THEM A REWARD OF OF
GOOD COMPENSATION AT THE YOUNG.
AGE SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS FOR MIRACLE
CALIFORNIA HEAD START --
THE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN GRANTEES
IN CALIFORNIA SERVING ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN ABOUT --
EIGHTY THOUSAND OF THOSE IN.
THE FOUR AND FIVE YEAR THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING AND
FOR ALL THE TESTIMONY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO KNOW A LOT
ABOUT THIS AND I'M NOT TO REPEAT
ANYTHING THEY SAID BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE A WASTE OF TIME.
I AGREE WITH.
A MID MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
SOME OF THESE ISSUES I WANT TO
MAKE A FOR QUICK POINTS AND THE
FIRST IS I I TOTALLY AGREE THAT
TEACHERS ARE THE ALPHA AND OMEGA
OF QUALITY.
THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE GOOD
TEACHERS YOU DON'T HAVE GOOD
PROGRAMS THERE'S REALLY NO WAY
AROUND THAT.
SO I SUPPORT ALL THE INCENTIVES
AROUND AROUND A SALARY INCREASE
FOR TEACHERS.
SEPARATELY I THINK AS YOU GO
FORWARD JUST LEVERAGE THE BEST
OF THE SYSTEM THAT YOU ALREADY
HAVE.
MAXIMIZING EVERY FEDERAL DOLLAR
YOU HAVE INCLUDING HEAD START
BECAUSE THAT'S A BILLION DOLLARS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAXIMIZE.
THIRD.
BE MINDFUL OF THE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF AGENCIES THAT RUN THESE
PROGRAMS IN OUR HEAD START WORLD
ONLY 35% OF THE AGENCIES THAT
RUN HEAD START PROGRAMS.
ARE INSIDE ELLIE ETS.
THE RESTAURANT COMMITTEE ACTION
PROGRAMS AND OTHER PRIVATE NON
PROFITS SO THAT MAKES DELIVERY
SYSTEM WHAT YOU NEED TO APPROACH
FINDING AN ACCESS IN A WAY.
THAT GIVES ALL OF THEM
OPPORTUNITY.
TO CREATE THE MARKET PLACE THAT
WE NEED.
AN AND FINALLY --
JUST A BIG BELIEVER IN TARGETED
UNIVERSALISM THAT IDEA THAT WE
SHOULD PROCEED IN A WAY THAT IS
BEST FOR EVERYONE BUT FOCUSES IN
SERVICE THE GREATEST NEEDS FIRST.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR TODAY
APPRECIATED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M THE LAST.
ONE MY NAME IS ANTHONY LOPEZ AND
I'M A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR QUALITY EARLY
EDUCATION.
IT'S AN A COALITION OF EDUCATORS
RESEARCHERS ADVOCATES FOR DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
AND THE REASON I CAME UP TODAY
REALLY WAS TO BRING ATTENTION TO
DO A LANGUAGE LEARNERS WE TALKED
ABOUT.
ALL THE STRUCTURES AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRED TO SERVE
CHILDREN WELL WHAT WE HAVEN'T
HAD ENOUGH.
CONVERSATION ABOUT HAS BEEN THE
KINDS OF OF ADDITIONAL STE US
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNER POPULATION. 60%
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA IS REALLY
THAT ARE SERVED OUR LARGEST
NUMBER OF DO A LANGUAGE LEARNER
CHILDREN IN THE COUNTRY SOME SAY
THAT THAT LOS ANGELES SERVICE
80%.
OF THE DO A LOT MORE CHILDREN
THAT ARE DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS
AND EIGHT STATES.
I HAVE IN MY FORMER LIFE I WAS
THE DIRECTOR OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION FOR THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF LA RAZA THE LARGEST
HISPANIC.
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
ARE I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR PER
SINCE ITS SUPPORT TO TOWARD.
TO UP PROGRAMS IN TWENTY FIVE
STATES SERVING A TOTAL OF ABOUT
EIGHTY THOUSAND CHILDREN SOME
VERY SMALL NUMBERS OF PROGRAMS
AND SOME VERY HUGE MULTI STATE
PROGRAMS.
ALL OF THEM ALL OF IT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WERE DEDICATED TO
PROVIDING STRONG DO A LANGUAGE
SUPPORT.
I WHAT I HAD PROGRAMS IN NEW
YORK I VISIT THE ALABAMA I'VE
SPOKEN IN NORTH CAROLINA I'VE
BEEN IN WASHINGTON AND SOME OF
THE CITIES THAT ARE ALSO AT A
AND WE GET ADVOCATES IN ILLINOIS
THAT REALLY WORK FOR THE
BILINGUAL CERTIFICATION SO I
FEEL LIKE I HAVE.
A A A LITTLE BIT OF INFORMATION
ABOUT A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES.
OF WHAT WE KNOW IN A RECENT
REPORT BY --
IN A WAY WHITE BOOK.
OF OCTOBER ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR
HIGHER ED INSTITUTIONS ARE
REALLY NOT IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
PREPARED.
TO PREPARE TEACHERS TO SERVE
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS SO IT IS
NOT ENOUGH TO HAVE HIGH
STANDARDS.
THE STANDARDS HAVE TO REFLECT
THE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
ASSETS AND NEEDS OF DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
WE HAVE YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
THEY YOU KNOW OUTCOMES ARE IN
TERMS OF COST BENEFIT BUT WE DO
KNOW.
WHAT BUT WE HAVE EXPERIENCE
SINCE WHEN DO A LANGUAGE
LEARNERS DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF
ADEQUATE EARLY EDUCATION AND
KATE THREE EXPERIENCE?
THAT WILL PREPARE THEM OR THEIR
LIFE LONG LEARNING.
IN CALIFORNIA THE HISPANICS AND
NOT TO SAY THAT ALL HISPANICS
ARE DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
BUT WE ARE 23%.
ALL OF OUR PROFICIENCY IN
READING AT FOURTH GRADERS 23%
LOWER THAN THAT IS FOR WHITE
KIDS.
WE ARE HOW MUCH OF THAT CAN BE
CLOSED BY HAVING AN APPROPRIATE.
TOOL LANGUAGE EXPERIENCE EARLY
LITERACY EXPERIENCES THAT ALLOW
FOR CHILDREN TO CONTINUE TO
LEARN IN THEIR OWN LANGUAGE AS
THEY ACQUIRE A SECOND LANGUAGE
ENGLISH.
OR IF THEIR ENGLISH SPEAKING
LEARNED A TO ACQUIRE CARIBBEAN
OR OR SPANISH OR ANY ONE OF THE
OTHER GLOBAL LANGUAGES THAT OUR
KIDS.
YOUR KIDS.
MY GRAND KIDS WILL NEED TO
REALLY FUNCTION AS FULLY
CONFIDENT CITIZENS IN THE WORLD.
WE ARE YOUR WHAT YOUR BILL THE
NINE I THINK A MRS.
A DOCTOR FREED UP BRIEFLY SAID.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO RIGHT.
A SHIP ONCE YOU HAVE IT IN PLACE.
WE HAVE HAD EARLY CHILDHOOD IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES LAND LAND
ACT.
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A BRAND
YOU YOUR VISION.
NOW TO DATE BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
SHACKLED BY TWO TWO SEVEN WHICH
DID NOT GIVE US THE AUTHORITY
THE PERMISSION.
THAT OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
WE REALLY ARE NOT BUILDING ON
THE BEST WE ARE TO CREATE IT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A NEW GROUND WE
HAVE A NEW FOUNDATION SO I URGE
YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT THE SYSTEM.
WHETHER IT'S Q. R. I. S..
OR CTC THE NEW PERMIT
REQUIREMENT.
OR THE FOUNDATIONS WE BUILT THE
PEACEFUL FOUNDATIONS IN ENGLISH
ONLY ENVIRONMENT.
SO WE KNOW THERE ARE INHERENT
BIASES IN PLACE THAT WOULD KEEP
US NEAR THE STATUS QUO WILL KEEP
US FROM REALLY UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
HAVE AS ASSETS IN OPPORTUNITIES
AND WE CAN WRITE THAT SHIP AND
YOU CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE NOT
JUST FOR THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR BUT
FOR DECADES SO.
I IMPLORE YOU ON BEHALF OF DUAL
LANGUAGE ADVOCATES TO REALLY
CONSIDER NOT JUST BUILDING
STRUCTURES BUT IT BUT REALLY
INVESTIGATING THE BIASES THAT
MAY BE ALREADY IN BED AND THE
STRUCTURES THAT WE ARE GOING.
TO BE A RAISING THIS PROGRAM
MONEY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I
USUALLY HAVE.
A ONE MINUTES --
CUT OFF BUT THIS IS OUR FIRST
YEAR IN THE YEAR IMPORTANT TOPIC
AND YOU KNOW.
WHEN IT TO SHELVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH THAT THIS COMMITTEE
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION OUR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY --
AND THAT THAT FORCE WE DIDN'T GO
UNTIL FIVE O'CLOCK SO.
BUT THANK YOU OFFER FOR REALLY
ADDING VALUE TO THIS
CONVERSATION AND IT'S IT IS ONE
AND NO TWO THAT IT'S IT'S A BIG
TOPIC FOR THE LET THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR.
AT THE ASSEMBLY THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR BUT WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING THIS THROUGH THE POLICY
COMMITTEE THROUGH THE END
COMMITTEE WHICH WHICH YOU SERVE
ON I SERVE ON AS WELL AS THE
BUDGET --
PROCESS AND SO.
WILL HAVE AMPLE OPPORTUNITY TO
DIG IN THE FILL THE THAT FOR THE
PROMISE HEARING IN CALIFORNIA
ARE ALL STRIVING TO DO IS
INCREASE ACCESS FOR ALL.
CALIFORNIA KIDS IN OUR PRE KBC
PROGRAMS THANK YOU OFFER BUT
IT'S BEEN TODAY.
THANK YOU